ओके आई थिंक वी आर लाइव नाउ गाइस प्लीज
लेट मी नो इफ आई एम ऑडिबल एंड विजिबल
आवाज मेरी जा रही है आप लोगों को एक बार
मुझे जल्दी से बता दीजिए सभी लोग जल्दी
बता दीजिए फटाफट बता दीजिए
ओके मैं तब तक इधर इनफॉर्म कर देता हूं
हम
ओके गुड इवनिंग
गुड इवनिंग टू एवरीबॉडी गुड इवनिंग गुड
इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग अ वेरी गुड
इवनिंग
ओके सो आवाज क्लियर जा रही है ना बिल्कुल
बिल्कुल क्लियर है बता दीजिए एक
हम
बिल्कुल क्लियर है। ठीक है। सो सभी को एक
बार आ जाने देते हैं। देन वी विल बी
स्टार्टिंग आज के सेशन।
एज आई सेड हर हर सेशन के साथ जो आपके अ
अपकमिंग सेशंस या जो भी आपके नेक्स्ट
सेशंस होंगे वो और भी ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग
और मजेदार होते चले जाएंगे एंड आपको और भी
ज्यादा मजा आएगा। सो आई होप कि आज आप सभी
कुछ और इंटरेस्टिंग सीखेंगे एंड मजा आपको
इतना ज्यादा आएगा कि
कई ऐसी चीजें हैं जो आपने शायद आज तक नहीं
सीखी होंगी। आज तक आपको नहीं पता होंगी।
एंड वो भी आप आज सीख के जाएंगे। एंड ये
मुझे लगता है कि हर एसओसी सेशन के साथ
होता है। जितने भी सेशंस होते हैं सब में
ऐसा होता है। एंड आई होप आप इस चीज से
एग्री जरूर करेंगे। आई विश। अह सो, मुझे
एक बार बता दीजिए कि अह
आप में से सभी से मैं पूछना चाहता हूं।
सभी से जानना चाहता हूं। जो भी सेशंस होते
हैं एसओसी के आपके आपको कुछ ना कुछ सीखने
को मिलता है या ऐसा लगता है कि नहीं कुछ
खास मतलब सीखने को नहीं मिलता। ऑलरेडी आई
नो ऑलरेडी मुझे चीजें पता है। सो मुझे
प्लीज बताइए इसके बारे में। सो दैट आई गेट
टू नो। थोड़ा आईडिया लेना जरूरी है आप
लोगों से भी।
टोटली अग्री ओके पता चलता है ठीक है
ठीक है ठीक है
ओके चलिए अच्छी बात है एक बार एक बार एक
बार सभी को एक बार ज्वाइन करने देते हैं
कई लोग अभी आए नहीं हुए सो लेट देम कंपेयर
फर्स्ट
106 पीपल आर हियर
सो एक बार सभी को आ जाने देते हैं
बहुत कुछ मिलता है।
ओके। सो
ये मुझे बताइए आप में से कितने लोगों के
क्लास फोर तक कंप्लीट हो चुके हैं? एसओसी
के सेशंस बताइए मुझे एक बार। जस्ट जस्ट
लेट मी नो। कितने लोगों लोगों का क्लास
फोर तक कंप्लीट हो चुका है? बस क्लास फोर
तक कंप्लीट जिनका हुआ है वो बताइए। ओनली
अ ओके डन डन
डन क्लास फोर तक कंप्लीट हो चुका है। चलिए
आप लोगों को इनफ टाइम मिल चुका था ऑलरेडी।
राइट? यू गॉट इनफ टाइम टू कंप्लीट टिल फोर
क्लास फोर। राइट? क्योंकि आपने देखा होगा
कि क्लास फोर के जो आपके रिसोर्सेज थे
राइट अगर मैं क्लास फोर के रिसोर्सेज के
ऊपर चलूं डे फोर की तो आप देखोगे कि यहां
टोटल आपके 23 स्लाइड्स थे। 23 स्लाइड्स
मींस मोर टॉपिक्स अ मोर कंटेंट अ लॉट ऑफ
कंटेंट एक्चुअली दैट यू हैड टू कंप्लीट।
राइट? सो अगर आपने क्लास फोर्थ तक कंप्लीट
कर लिया है तो इट्स ग्रेट। काफी अच्छी चीज
है। आई होप कि अ मैक्सिमम लोगों का हो गया
होगा। एंड अगर फिर भी अगर आपका नहीं हुआ
है, आप ऐसे हैं जिनका अभी भी क्लास फोर तक
नहीं हुआ है। सो आई वुड रिक्वेस्ट यू कि
प्लीज प्लीज प्लीज आप क्लास फोर तक जरूर
कंप्लीट कर लीजिए। टाइमली टाइम रहते
कंप्लीट कर लीजिए। इट विल हेल्प यू मच।
एंड आगे की क्लासेस समझने में आपको ज्यादा
और ज्यादा हेल्प ये करेंगी। ठीक है? चलिए
यहां पे 145 पीपल हैव जॉइंड। अ मैं
एटलीस्ट मुझे लगता है कि 200 लोग ज्वाइन
करेंगे तभी सेशन को स्टार्ट करेंगे। तो
थोड़ा वेट और कर लेते हैं क्योंकि कई लोग
हैं जिनका फिर छूट जाता है। फिर वह मैसेज
करते हैं हमें कि सर अह थोड़ा सा रह गया
था एंड ऑल एक्सट्रा एक्सट्रा राइट
ओके
सर अप्रोक्स मंथ्स टू कंप्लीट दिस कोर्स।
थ्री टू फोर मंथ्स आई थिंक मैक्सिमम। थ्री
टू फोर मंथ्स।
राइट? थ्री टू फोर मंथ्स।
ओके। सो बिफोर बिफोर वी स्टार्ट चलिए मैं
आप सब को सबसे पहले बता देता हूं। यह एक
Lindin पेज है मेरा जहां पे आप मुझसे
कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं एंड मुझे फॉलो कर सकते
हैं। मेरी जो भी जर्नी है उसको फॉलो कर
सकते हैं। दिस इज़ माय पर्सनल Lindin
प्रोफाइल। देन आप डिफ़्रोनिक्स सर्च
करेंगे। Lindin पे यू विल सर्च जस्ट
डिफ़्रोनिक्स। तो आपको हमारा डिफ़्रोनिक्स
का Lindin पेज मिल जाएगा। इस पर आप आके
हमें फॉलो कर सकते हैं। एंड यू विल गेट टू
नो अबाउट आवर कंपनी आवर कंपनी अपडेट्स एंड
ऑल एवरीथिंग। देन हमारी ये Twitter यानी
कि एक्स डिफ्रॉनिक्स पेज है X.com
डिफ़्रोनिक्स aडमी इस पे आके आप फॉलो कर
लीजिएगा। यहां आने वाले कुछ टाइम में आपको
कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें मिलने वाली हैं।
कुछ गिव अवेज़ एंड कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट अपडेट्स
मिलेंगे। तो आप इस पे आ जाइएगा। ये हमारी
वेबसाइट है। यहां हमारा फोन नंबर है। आप
इस पे कोई भी क्वेरीज, कुछ भी रिलेटेड कुछ
भी क्वेश्चंस हैं आप कर सकते हैं। एंड ये
जो है ये तो आपको पता है। हमारा
YouTube चैनल है। तो सब्सक्राइब करा है तो
अच्छी बात है। बट इसमें बेल नोटिफिकेशन जो
है ऑल वाली ये हमेशा इनेबल करके आपको रखना
है। चेक कर लीजिए अभी भी आप अगर आप अभी भी
देख रहे हैं अगर आपका सब्सक्राइब है तो ऑल
करके जरूर रखिएगा क्योंकि तभी आपको
नोटिफिकेशन मिलेगी। अदरवाइज़ नोटिफिकेशन
आपको नहीं मिलेगी YouTube की तरफ से। एंड
द मोस्टेंट थिंग कि किसी भी लाइव एसओसी की
क्लास को ओपन कर लीजिएगा। किसी भी लाइव
जैसे मैं डे फोर की ओपन करने वाला हूं।
ठीक है?
एंड यहां डिस्क्रिप्शन में जब आप जाएंगे
तो आपको दो लिंक्स मिलेंगे। एक WhatsApp
ग्रुप का एसओसी का स्पेशलाइज्ड ग्रुप है
ये। इसका लिंक मिलेगा। आप इसको जरूर जॉइ
कीजिएगा। एसोसिएट से रिलेटेड जितने भी
आपके रिसोर्सेज हैं, जो भी आपके पीडीएफ्स
हैं या जो भी रिसोर्सेज आपकी क्लासेस में
जरूरत पड़ेंगी या अपकमिंग जो इस ट्रेनिंग
के एंड होने के बाद जो सर्टिफिकेशन की
डिटेल्स एंड एवरीथिंग विल बी शेयर विल बी
शेयरर्ड हियर ओनली इन दिस ग्रुप। एंड ये
दूसरा जो लिंक है ये WhatsApp चैनल है
हमारा डेफ्रोनिक्स एकडमी नाम से। आप आके
यहां फॉलो करके यहां पे सारी अपडेट्स के
लिए हमें फॉलो कर सकते हैं। जो भी चीजें
हैं वो आपको मिल जाएंगी। राइट? थैंक यू।
आई होप कि आप सब ने जॉइन करा होगा। चलिए
अभी आप देख सकते हैं कि वी हैव 148 पीपल
ओनली हियर इन द लाइव। अब मुझे बताइए कि
क्या दिक्कत है? मतलब अब मुझे बताइए एक
क्वेश्चन है मेरा आपसे बिफोर स्टार्टिंग।
क्वेश्चन इज स्टार्टिंग में 350 लोग लाइव
थे फर्स्ट डे। उसके बाद लगभग 300 देन 250
देन अभी 150 के आसपास लाइव है। मुझे यह
जानना है आप लोगों से एकदम सिंसियरली मैं
से मतलब सीरियसली थोड़ा पूछ रहा हूं मैं अ
इस चीज को फोकस करते हुए
क्या आप ऐसी ट्रेनिंग के लिए अगर
10-15,000 देते कहीं इंस्टट्यूट्स में तो
क्या आप तब भी ऐसे करते कि किसी दिन नहीं
जाते एंड किसी दिन जाते एंड अपने
अकॉर्डिंग करते। आई थिंक आई डोंट थिंक कि
आप ऐसा करते हैं। राइट? मुझे नहीं लगता कि
आप ऐसा कर पाते। तो आप इसमें इसकी वैल्यू
क्यों नहीं रख रहे? आप इसमें इसको वैल्यू
क्यों नहीं दे पा रहे हैं? मुझे ये नहीं
समझ में आ रहा। जो लोग नहीं आ रहे हैं, जो
लोग रिकॉर्डिंग देख रहे हैं, उनकी मैं बात
कर रहा हूं कि लाइव में आप क्यों नहीं आ
रहे हैं? आप अपनी टाइम को मैनेज क्यों
नहीं कर रहे हैं? आप इसको प्रायोरिटी
क्यों नहीं दे रहे हैं? दैट्स देंट थिंग।
राइट? मैं आपको सच बता रहा हूं।
इस जैसी ट्रेनिंग आपको अभी यहां पे मिल
रही है, आपको कहीं नहीं मिलेगी। इट्स अ
गारंटीड
मैं पूरी ठोक के आपको यह चीज बोल रहा हूं।
समझे? तो, आप इस चीज को समझिए थोड़ा। इस
चीज को फील कीजिए। यू हैव टू अंडरस्टैंड
दिस। बाद में आपको बहुत बहुत रिग्रेट होगा
क्योंकि मैं आपको एक चीज बता देता हूं।
क्लास वन, देन क्लास टू, देन क्लास थ्री।
ऐसे धीरे-धीरे करके वीडियोस को मेंबर ओनली
करना हम शुरू कर देंगे। देन वो वीडियो
आपको दिखेंगी नहीं। फिर आपको ना तो रिवीजन
करने का उसका मौका मिलेगा ना कुछ मिलेगा।
तो अभी एक मौका है आपके पास। एक तो लाइव
अटेंड कीजिए और अभी रिकॉर्डिंग्स को
रिवाइज कीजिए ताकि आप जो है उस चीज को
फुल्ली गैब कर पाएं। है ना? राइट?
तो इस चीज को थोड़ा सा तो गैब करो और लाइव
में जो आएंगे उनको स्पेशल बेनिफिट मिलना
चाहिए ना कि वो सारे वीडियोस उनको फ्रीली
अवेलेबल हो जाए। अब जो बाद में आएगा हो
सकता है उसको ना हो। तो वो तो उनकी गलती
है। राइट? तो उसको थोड़ा सा वैल्यू दीजिए।
मैं आपसे यही रिक्वेस्ट करूंगा। ठीक है?
Lindin पे भी क्लास थ्री तक तो काफी लोगों
ने शेयर करा है। देखो मैं दिखा भी देता
हूं तुम्हें। मैं यहां पर नोटिफिकेशन में
चलता हूं। क्लास थ्री के बारे में काफी
लोगों ने यहां पे शेयर करा है। एसओसी के
देखो क्लास टू हो गई। क्लास थ्री क्लास
फोर में थोड़ा कम शेयर शेयरिंग हुई है।
Lindin पे कम लोगों ने पॉइंट्स डाले हैं।
ये डालिए आप Lindin पे पॉइंट्स डालिए।
इट्सेंट राइट? इट्स रियली वेरी वेरीेंट।
चलिए तो आज की जो जर्नी है हम शुरू करते
हैं। एंड आज जो है वो एक डिफरेंट
अ
माइंडसेट को समझेंगे हमारे क्लास फाइव
में। एंड ये माइंडसेट काफी आपको काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग लगने वाली है। काफी मजा आएगा
आपको इस माइंडसेट को समझ के। तो लेट्स
लेट्स स्टार्ट।
ठीक है?
सबसे पहले आज जो हम टॉपिक करने वाले हैं
वो है साइबर किल चेन मेथोडोलॉजी। हम इसको
थोड़ा सा समझने वाले हैं। साइबर किल चेन
मेथोडोलॉजी। अब देखो वैसे ये बहुत इजी
टॉपिक है। अगर आप वैसे समझोगे तो बहुत ईजी
है। बट मैं आपको मैं आपको जिस तरीके से
समझाऊंगा वैसा आपको शायद किसी ने नहीं
समझाया होगा एंड उस तरीके से आपके दिमाग
में आज तक फिट भी नहीं होगा। तो इस चीज को
समझिएगा। यह बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट कांसेप्ट है।
बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक है। किसी भी साइबर
सिक्योरिटी सर्टिफिकेशन में चाहे आप किसी
लेवल के साइबर सिक्योरिटी के सर्टिफिकेशन
करते हो या जानते हो या करने की कोशिश कर
रहे हो। यह टॉपिक उनमें आता ही आता है।
इनडायरेक्टली हो, डायरेक्टली हो डजंट
मैटर। देयर इज ओनली दिस पर्टिकुलर थिंग जो
आपको हमेशा हर जगह मिलेगी। तो इसको
समझिएगा थोड़ा। ठीक है? हां। हां। और जो
टास्क दिया था मैंने आप लोगों में से किसी
ने टास्कवस किया है कि नहीं किया है? ये
बताइए मुझे। मैंने लास्ट क्लास में कुछ
टास्क दिए थे आपको।
बताइए।
अच्छी बात है तुषार। आप जल्दी आ गए तो।
अ थैंक्स पीतांबर थैंक यू वेरी मच
हम
यस आदि मैंने आपका स्केच देखा था एंड थैंक
यू वेरी मच आपने Lindin पे शायद शेयर किया
था। सो थैंक्स अ लॉट एंड मैंने कमेंट में
आपको मेल आईडी भी दी थी कि आप वहां पर भेज
दीजिएगा क्योंकि दैट वास रियली नाइस एंड
थैंक यू वेरी मच फॉर दैट इट वाज़ रियली
ग्रेट आर्ट।
सो हू शाउट आउट टू
मिस्टर आदि
ओके
जिन्होंने टास्क कर लिया था अच्छी बात है
जिन्होंने नहीं किया प्लीज उसको नेक्स्ट
सेशन से पहले तक कर लीजिएगा इट्स
रिक्वेस्ट क्योंकि मैं आगे और टास्क आपको
देते रहूंगा तो फिर आपको फिर वो लैग
बिहाइंड आपका हो जाएगा।
अब समझते हैं। अरे प्रोटीन पाउडर नहीं है
भाई। प्रोटीन पाउडर बोल रहा है एक बंदा।
प्रोटीन पाउडर नहीं है। दिस इज कॉल्ड
कोल्ड कॉफी। खत्म हो गई। प्रोटीन पाउडर
मैं नहीं पीता बैठे-बैठे ऐसे। मैं कोई जिम
से होके थोड़ी नहा रहा हूं।
सो इट्स अ
हां कोल्ड कॉफी है ये।
होममेड कोल्ड कॉफी।
ठीक है। चलिए साइबर किल चेन को समझते हैं।
एंड हैकिंग मेथोडोलॉजीस साइबर किल चेन के
बीच के डिफरेंस को समझते हैं। दोनों दो
चीजें होती हैं। मैं आपको समझाता हूं
पहले। देखो साइबर किल चेन एक ऐसी
फ्रेमवर्क जो कि बनाई गई थी या इन्वेंट
किया गया था या
उसको
की करा गया था किसके द्वारा? लॉकहि
मार्टिन के तरफ से। लॉकड जो है मार्टिन
इन्होंने इस पर्टिकुलर फ्रेमवर्क को बनाया
था जिसका नाम था साइबर किलचेन। यह साइबर
किलचे क्या था? ये अटैकर्स का एक लाइफ
साइकिल है। एक लाइफ साइकिल जैसे इन्होंने
सोचा कि एक अटैकर जो हैकर जो होते हैं ना
जब अटैक करते हैं किसी सिस्टम के ऊपर में
किसी नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर। इस बात को
ध्यान से सुनिएगा आप लोग। चैट से हट जाओ।
गुड इवनिंग। हेलो सबको बट अभी गुड इवनिंग।
हेलो सर से हटिए और इधर मेरे पे फोकस
कीजिए। ठीक है? कोई बात नहीं आप अभी लेट
हैं बट अभी अभी हम स्टार्ट कर रहे हैं तो
यू आर नॉट लेट। राइट? सो प्लीज फोकस हियर
एंड चैट से बिल्कुल गायब हो जाइए अभी के
लिए कुछ टाइम के लिए। जब हैकर्स अटैक करते
थे सिस्टम्स पे, नेटवर्क पे,
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर्स पे। तो उनके अलग-अलग
डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट अप्रोचेस होते थे। ठीक
है? कोई किसी और तरीके से हैक करता था।
कोई किसी और तरीके का यूज़ करता था। कुछ और
टूल्स, कुछ और कुछ और टेक्निक्स ये सारी
चीजें होती थी। बट उनका एक मेथोडोलॉजी एक
तरीका
उसका एक कोर जो वे होता था कोर मेथोडोलॉजी
होता था वो ऑलमोस्ट सिमिलर थे जितने भी
अटैक्स होते थे ऑलमोस्ट सिमिलर नाउ व्हाट
इज ऑलमोस्ट सिमिलर जैसे कि अगर आप अपने घर
से मान लो कि आप मुंबई में रहते हो राइट
आपको दिल्ली ट्रैवल करना है अब आप मुंबई
से दिल्ली या तो बाय बस जा सकते हो अगर
कोई बस चलती है तो बाय ट्रेन जा सकते हो
बाय फ्लाइट जा सकते हो राइट तो ये आपने
ट्रांसपोर्ट्स अलग-अलग यूज़ कर लिए बट आपके
कुछ कोर मेथोडोलॉजीस होंगे जैसे कि आप एक
पर्टिकुलर वे में जाते होंगे एक पर्टिकुलर
तरीके से जाते होंगे एक पर्टिकुलर आपका
अप्रोच होता होगा एक पर्टिकुलर चीज एक
पर्टिकुलर काम के लिए जाते होंगे कि मैं
यह काम के लिए दिल्ली ट्रैवल कर रहा हूं
एक पर्टिकुलर टाइम पे जाते होंगे कि मैं
इस पर्टिकुलर डेट रेंज में चाहता हूं तो
आपके मेथोडोलॉजीस यानी कि आपका जो एक
तरीका है वो अलग-अलग तरीके हैं। जैसे कि
अलग-अलग मोड ऑफ ट्रांसपोर्ट आप यूज़ करें।
बट आपका मकसद जो है ना मकसद वो मकसद एक है
और उसका भी एक कोर मेथोडोलॉजी जो है वो
उसका भी इंटैक्ट है वो भी सेम है सेम
तरीके से है एंड उसी को आप फॉलो करते हुए
आगे आप दिल्ली तक पहुंच जाते हैं या
दिल्ली तक आपको जाना होता है अब जब कोई
अटैकर हैक करता है जब कोई अटैकर अटैक करता
है किसी सिस्टम पे किसी इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर
पे तो उसका एक लाइफ साइकिल होता है कि वो
सिस्टम तक कैसे पहुंचा है सिस्टम तक उसने
क्या-क्या तरीकों का यूज करके पहुंच वो
अटैक कर रहा है सिस्टम्स के ऊपर में उसको
हम बोलते हैं उसी को डिफाइन किया गया है
साइबर किल चेन के अंदर में। साइबर किल चेन
के अंदर में जो लॉकिड मार्टिन ने इन्वेंट
करा या क्रिएट करा। अब इस साइबर किल चेन
का मतलब यह था कि कोई भी कंपनी, कोई भी
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर, कोई भी बड़ी
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन इस साइबर किल चेन में जो
स्टेप्स हैं उसमें से एक स्टेप को भी अगर
ब्रेकडाउन कर देता है, एक स्टेप को भी कट
कर देता है या एक स्टेप को भी रोकने में
सफल होता है या सक्सेसफुल होता है तो यह
पूरी की पूरी साइकिल यह पूरी की पूरी लाइफ
साइकिल डिसररप्ट हो जाती है। यह पूरी लाइफ
साइकिल ब्रेक डाउन हो जाती है। एंड वहीं
पे वो चेन टूट जाती है। एंड अटैकर अपने जो
भी उसका
जो भी लाइक व्हाटएवर हिज इंटेंशन या हर
इंटेंशन इज़ वो वहीं पे खत्म हो जाता है।
उसका इंटेंशन खत्म हो जाता है। वो कर ही
नहीं पाता। वो कॉम्प्रोमाइज ही नहीं कर
पाएगा। तो देयर इज़ नो कॉम्प्रोमाइज। इवन
इफ वन सिंगल स्टेज इज ब्रोक डाउन अगर ऐसा
हो जाता है तो उस केस में यह पूरी की पूरी
चेन टूट जाती है एंड अटैकर सक्सेसफुल नहीं
हो पाता है सिस्टम पे अटैक करने के लिए।
दैट्स इट। ये साइबर किल चेन का पूरा का
पूरा मतलब। अब इसको थोड़ा सा डिटेल में हम
समझेंगे। देखो अब इसको थोड़ा सा टेक्निकल
की तरफ जाए तो इट इज़ अ लीनियर मॉडल दैट
फोकसेस ऑन द अटैकर्स जर्नी फ्रॉम आउटसाइड
इन। बाहर से अटैकर अंदर की तरफ जो अटैक कर
रहा है तो उस पे फोकस करता है उसकी जर्नी
को कि अटैकर कैसे-कैसे घुस रहा है एक
सिस्टम के अंदर में कैसे इनफ में घुस रहा
है। क्या-क्या तरीकों से घुस रहा है वो
पूरी जर्नी को। बाय ब्रेकिंग द चेन एट एनी
पॉइंट यू स्टॉप द एंटायर अटैक। चेन को
कहीं से भी ब्रेकडाउन किया तो पूरी अटैक
जो है वो टूट जाएगी। पूरी अटैक जो है रुक
जाएगी। ये है साइबर किल चेन मेथोडोलॉजी
एंड इसको यूज किया जाता है ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
के तरफ से जो कंपनीज़ होती हैं उनके टीम्स
उनके सिक्योरिटी टीम्स इसको यूज़ करती हैं।
इसको ही समझते हुए एंड इसी के बेसिस पे
एक्ट करते हुए वो इस चेन को तोड़ना चाहती
है जब भी कोई अटैकर अटैक करता है। दैट्स
इट। अब देखिए
साइबर किल चेन के अंदर में मल्टीपल
स्टेजेस होते हैं। यू कैन से सेवन स्टेजेस
आर देयर इन साइबर किल चेन। साइबर किल चेन
में सात स्टेजेस होते हैं। अब यह सात
स्टेजेस क्या होते हैं? सबसे पहला स्टेज
आपका होता है रिक्नेसेंस का। द फर्स्ट
स्टेज इज रिकॉग्नेसेंस। सेकंड स्टेज इज़
वेपनाइजेशन। थर्ड स्टेज इज़ डिलीवरी। फोर्थ
स्टेज इज़ एक्सप्लइटेशन। फिफ्थ स्टेज इज़
इंस्टॉलेशन। सिक्स्थ इज़ कमांड एंड
कंट्रोल। एंड सेवन इज़ एक्शंस ऑन
ऑब्जेक्टिव्स। ठीक है? ये कमांड एंड
कंट्रोल का जो है इसको ये दो बार यहां पे
आ चुका है। इसको इग्नोर कर दीजिएगा। सात
ही होते हैं यहां पे सिक्स सिक्स दो बार
है। ठीक है? तो जस्ट इग्नोर इट। तो ये सात
स्टेजेस इस साइबर किल चेन के आपके पार्ट
होते हैं। अब ये जो सात स्टेज है ये सात
स्टेज में इतनी चीजें हैं जो आपको समझना
नहीं है। बस दिमाग में फिट कर लेना है
लाइफ टाइम के लिए क्योंकि ये आपके हैकिंग
जर्नी में साइबर सिक्योरिटी जर्नी में
स्टार्टिंग बिगिनर से लेके एंड तक काम आने
वाला है। और इसका
यूज़ आप बिगिनर होते हुए भी करेंगे और आप
सुपर एक्सपर्ट भी बन जाएंगे। तब भी आपको
करना ही करना है। आप चाहे एसओसी में हैं,
डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक्स में है, सिक्योरिटी आप
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग में है या किसी भी
किसी भी जगह पे है। यू आर गोइंग टू फॉलो
दिस साइबर कल्चर। ये इतना इंपॉर्टेंट है।
बस इतना समझ लीजिए। ठीक है? अब रेकोसेंस
वेपनाइजेशन, डिलीवरी, एक्सप्लइटेशन इन सब
में थोड़ा-थोड़ा मैं एग्जांपल के तौर पे
आपको बताऊंगा। इसको थोड़ा-थोड़ा समझाऊंगा।
उसके बाद मैं आपको थोड़ा सा एक डिटेल्ड
एक्सप्लेनेशन के साथ उस पे लेके चलूंगा।
ठीक है? पहले शॉर्ट में समझते हैं। करेक्ट
करेक्ट करेक्ट।
अब यहां पे
सबसे पहले आती है रिकनेसेंस। देखो
रिकॉग्नेसेंस में कई लोगों को पता होगा
दिस इज़ कॉल्ड इनेशन गैदरिंग आल्सो यू कैन
से फुटप्रिंटिंग। फुटप्रिंटिंग भी कह लो।
ठीक है? गैदरिंग इनेशन ऑन टारगेट। इसमें
एक अटैकर क्या करता है? टारगेट के
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन गैदरिंग का टारगेट के ऊपर
करता है। इनफेशन गैदरिंग का मतलब है द
इनिशियल लेवल ऑफ़ गैदरिंग। इनिशियल लेवल ऑफ
Intel जो Intel गैदरिंग होती है। इंटेल
गैदरिंग का मतलब है कि जो इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
गैदरिंग आप करते हैं। तो जब आप किसी अटैकर
को अटैक जब आप किसी एज अटैकर किसी अ
नेटवर्क पे या किसी कंपनी के ऊपर या किसी
सिस्टम या सर्वर के ऊपर में कोई बात नहीं
गोविंद अटैक करते हो तो उस केस में सबसे
बड़ी आपकी जो आर्सनल होती है ना वो होती
है इनफेशन गैदरिंग जो आपके आर्सनल मतलब
हैकिंग आर्सनल में पड़ी होती है। सबसे
बड़ा एक आपका तरीका रहता है इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
को गैदर करना। जितना ज्यादा आप इनेशन गैदर
करेंगे टारगेट को लेके आपके लिए वो इतनी
ही इजी हो जाएगी ये जो पर्टिकुलर आपका
अटैक है उसको सक्सेसफुल बनाना इतना इजी हो
जाएगा। एग्जांपल में क्या है? रिसर्चिंग
कंपनी एंड एंप्लाइजज़ फाइंडिंग ईमेल्स एंड
यूजरनेम्स आइडेंटिफाइंग टारगेट सिस्टम एंड
वलेबिलिटीज़। ये देखिए। अब इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
गैदर का मतलब होता है एक टारगेट के लिए।
टारगेट के बारे में कुछ भी इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदर करना जितना डीप हो सके। मान लो कि
तुम्हें एक कंपनी के नेटवर्क के ऊपर अटैक
करना है एज एन अटैकर। ठीक है? जस्ट इमेजिन
करना है। आपको रियल में नहीं करना है।
इमेजिन करना है। अब उस कंपनी का एक
नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर है। लेट्स सपोज़
देयर इज़ एन आईपी दैट यू आर दैट यू दैट यू
नो कि ये आईपी इस नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर
का पार्ट है। और मैं इस पे अटैक करना
चाहता हूं। उस एक्सेस लेना चाहता हूं। तो
नॉर्मली टेक्निकल फ्लॉज़ को वलेबिलिटीज को
एक्सप्लइट करके और उसको फिर एग्जीक्यूट
करना थोड़ा टफ होता है कि आप एक वलेबिलिटीज़
को फाइंड करो पहले फिर उसको एक्सप्लइट
करो। फिर पेलोड डिलीवरी करके फिर
एग्जीक्यूशन करो। फिर तुम सीएनसी सेटअप
करो। फिर तुम्हारे पास एक्सेस आ जाएगा। ये
सारा ये तो टेक्निकल फ्लो हो गया। राइट?
टेक्निकल फ्लो हो जाता है ये। बट मैं यहां
पे बोल रहा हूं कि अगर टेक्निकल फ्लो जो
आपका है उससे भी इजी अगर कोई फ्लो आपको
पता हो या आपको पता चले तो क्या आप उसके
साथ नहीं जाना चाहेंगे? एंड वही फ्लो है
ये रिकॉर्न फ्लो। रिकॉनसेंस फ्लो।
रिकॉनसेंस प्लस सोशल इंजीनियरिंग इज द
मोस्ट डेडली कॉम्बिनेशन इन साइबर अटैक्स।
अगर कोई रेकोसेंस में मास्टर है एंड सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग में मास्टर है तो उसको बाकी
के ये कुछ भी चीजों की जो जरूरत पड़ेगी ना
ये बाकी जो स्टेप्स हैं ये बहुत ईजी हो
जाएंगे करेगा वो सारे स्टेप्स बट बहुत
बहुत ईजीली बट अगर रेगनेसेंस अच्छा नहीं
है सोशल इंजीनियरिंग सही से नहीं कर पा
रहा है एग्जीक्यूशन अच्छे से नहीं हो पा
रही है सक्सेसफुल नहीं हो पा रही है तो ये
स्टेप्स करने पड़ेंगे थोड़े मुश्किल होंगे
बट करने पड़ेंगे मुश्किल से होंगे कंप्लीट
होंगे बट इतना इजी नहीं रहेगा जितना ईजी
इज़ आपका अगर आप एज अ मास्टर कर लेते हैं
रिकॉन एंड सोशल इंजीनियरिंग। अब देखो
रेकॉन एंड सोशल इंजीनियरिंग जब कर लोगे
मास्टर तो रेकॉन करोगे और उसके बाद
डायरेक्ट तुम यहां पे एक्शन ऑन
ऑब्जेक्टिव्स पे आ जाओगे। और ये जो बीच के
जो स्टेप्स हैं इनका बस एक सपोर्टिंग रोल
रहेगा। बहुत लोग सपोर्टिंग रोल में रहना
चाहते हैं। बहुत लोग जैसे ये दो तीन चार
के पांच के स्टेप्स हैं बीच वाले ये उस
टाइम में सपोर्टिंग रोल में आ जाएंगे।
राइट? एंड और अगर तुम्हारा रिकॉग्नोसेंस
अच्छा नहीं है ना रिकॉग्नोसेंस तो फिर ये
मेन रोल में रहेंगे। ये सपोर्टिंग रोल में
फिर नहीं रहेंगे। दीज़ विल बी इन मेन
रोल्स। तो तुम्हें इनके थ्रू भी होके बहुत
डीपली जाना पड़ेगा। पर वैसे तुम्हें जाना
नहीं पड़ेगा डीपली। तुम्हें थोड़ा-थोड़ा
थोड़ा-थोड़ा ये ये सब रोल्स जो है बहुत ईजी
हो जाएंगे। उसके बाद ये जो स्टेप्स है ना
दो तीन चार पांच ये बहुत ईजी टू
एग्जीक्यूट हो जाएंगे। तो अगर मेरे को
किसी कंपनी ऊपर अटैक करना है तो अब मैं
क्या करूंगा? मैं कंपनी में कंपनी के
नेटवर्क में वलेबिलिटीज खोजने से पहले
मोस्टेंटली कंपनी में वलेबिलिटीज खोजने से
पहले मैं कंपनीज़ का डाटा निकालूंगा। जो भी
कंपनी है उसका पूरा डाटा कि भैया ये कंपनी
काम किस चीज पे करती है? इनका नेटवर्क
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर
कैसा है? कितना कॉम्प्लेक्स है? किस तरह
के फायर वाल्स यूज़ हो रहे हैं? कौन सा
राउटर कौन सा स्विच यूज़ हो रहा है? उनमें
क्या वर्जनंस के सॉफ्टवेयर्स ऑपरेट किए जा
रहे हैं? कितने एंप्लाइजज़ हैं? आईटी टीम
जो है वो किस तरह की है? कितने ज्यादा
अवेयर्ड हैं? कितने ज्यादा स्किल्ड हैं?
उनको कितनी किस बात की नॉलेज है?
उनका जो अपर लेवल का हायरार्की है। जहां
पे सीनियर मेंबर्स आते हैं, जहां पे
मैनेजमेंट के लोग आते हैं, वो कौन-कौन है?
उसके फिर सीईओ कौन है? सीटीओस कौन है?
सीईओस कौन है?
सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर कौन है? चीफ इंजीनियर
कौन है? यह सब कुछ मैं पता लगाऊंगा।
एवरीथिंग एंड मैं पूरी लिस्ट बनाऊंगा।
Lindin पे सर्च करूंगा कंपनी के बारे में।
कंपनी के जो Lindin पे जाके पीपल सेक्शन
में जाओगे तो वहां पे पूरी उनके जो की
मेंबर्स होते हैं उनका वहां पे मेंशन होता
है।
ओके।
यहां पे राज कुलकर्णी ने बहुत ज्यादा
स्पैम कर दिया है।
इन्होंने बोला है हेलो नितेश सर आई एम
लर्निंग साइबर सिक्योरिटी एंड योर बग
बाउंट सीरीज हैज़ बीन एक्सट्रीमली हेल्पफुल
इन बिल्डिंग माय फंडामेंटल्स एंड अप्रोच।
आई वुड बी ग्रेटफुल फॉर गाइडेंस फ्रॉम यू।
थैंक यू राज कुलकर्णी बट प्लीज डोंट स्पैम
बार-बार। अह आई एम रियली हैप्पी दैट द
सीरीज इज़ हेल्पिंग यू एंड आई थिंक यू शुड
कंटिन्यू। आप ऐसे ही कंटिन्यू कीजिए,
अच्छा कीजिए। यू विल बी डूइंग गुड। ठीक
है? दैट्स ग्रेट। चलिए।
तो जब मैं सारी इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट कर
लूंगा उस पर्टिकुलर कंपनी के बारे में,
एंप्लाइजज़ के बारे में तब मैं टारगेट अपना
एक बनाऊंगा एक एंप्लई को। एक लोअर लेवल के
एंप्लई को। उसको मैं टारगेट बनाऊंगा। और
मैं एक्ट करूंगा एक सीनियर लेवल के
मैनेजमेंट एंप्लई की तरह। मैं एक्ट कर
सकता हूं एक सीडीओ की तरह। मैं एक्ट कर
सकता हूं एक सीईओ की तरह। मैं एक्ट कर
सकता हूं एक टीम लीड की तरह और मैं मुझे
पता होगा ना कि आईटी टीम का ये बंदा है जो
अलग-अलग ऑपरेशंस देखता है तो मैं उसी टीम
के टीम लीड की तरह एक्ट करके मैं उसको
फिशिंग और सोशल इंजीनियरिंग उस पे ट्राई
करूंगा एंड आई विल ट्राई सो दैट दे गेट इन
ट्रैप एंड जब वो ट्रैप में आ जाएंगे तो बस
यह वेपनाइजेशन करना आसान हो जाएगा डिलीवरी
करना और भी आसान हो जाएगा एक्सप्ल ेशन
सुपर ईजी हो जाएगा। इंस्टॉलेशन सुपर डुपर
ईजी हो जाएगा। कमांड एंड कंट्रोल मोस्ट
ईजीिएस्ट तरीके से हो जाएगी। और एक्शन एंड
ऑब्जेक्टिव्स तो बिना बताए ही हो जाएगा।
बिना टेंशन लिए ही हो जाएगा। ये पावर है
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन गैदरिंग एंड सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग का। दैट्स इट।
ये पावर है। करेक्ट। इंसाइडर थ्रेट
बिल्कुल। उसका रोल तो बहुत बड़ा रोल है
इंसाइडर थ्रेट का। वो भी हम कभी बाद में
बहुत अच्छे से समझेंगे। तो पहला हो जाता
है आपका रिकॉनसिस। दूसरा मेथड आता है
वेपनाइजेशन। अब जब तुमने सारी कलेक्ट कर
ली इंफॉर्मेशन, सारी जानकारियां ले ली है
तो अब तुम्हें अपना हथियार जो है ना उसको
सेटअप करना है। वेपन क्रिएट करना है। वेपन
का मतलब ये नहीं कि तुम्हें बॉम्ब लेके
चले जाना है। कंपनी के ऊपर बम बम फोड़ देना
है। वेपन का मतलब है पेलोड को क्राफ्ट
करना। मलेशियस पेलोड को बनाना। पेलोड्स आर
एवरीवेयर। नो मैटर हाउ मच
टेक्नोलॉजी इज एडवांसिंग या कुछ भी पेलोड
कैन नॉट बी रिप्लेस बिकॉज़ पेलोड का मतलब
ही एक कोई चीज नहीं होती। पेलोड एक
प्रोसेस है उसको आप रिप्लेस नहीं कर सकते।
तो पेलोड क्राफ्ट करना इज़ द नेक्स्ट पार्ट
मशियस पेलोड।
किस तरीके से? क्रिएटिंग मलेशियस
अटैचमेंट्स और लिंक्स डेवलपिंग मैलवेयर और
एक्सप्लइट्स। अब आप सब में से कई लोगों ने
मेटास्प्लॉयड का नाम सुना होगा। कई लोगों
ने सुना होगा। सुना है क्या आप लोगों में
से किसी ने? हैव यू हर्ड अबाउट
मेटास्प्लॉयड गाइस? प्लीज लेट मी नो।
प्लीज लेट मी नो। हाउ मेनी ऑफ यू हर्ड
अबाउट मेटास्प्लॉयड जो बेसिकली काली में
ऑलरेडी प्रीइस्टॉल्ड मिलती है। ग्राफिकल
वर्जन भी है। Uban टूल किसी भी लinक्स
स्टोर पे आप आराम से इंस्टॉल कर सकते हो।
मेटास्प्लॉयड फ्रेमवर्क की बात कर रहा हूं
मैं।
ओके। यस। मेटास्प्लॉयड फ्रेमवर्क। सो
मेटास्पॉइड फ्रेमवर्क अह इज़ मोस्टली
कलेक्शन ऑफ डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ एक्सप्लइट्स,
पेलोड्स, ऑज़िलरीज़ नब्स अ राइट
इनकोडर्स एक्सेप्ट एक्सेप्ट। ये जो
मेटास्टइड वगैरह है ये सब मतलब हम अपनी
ट्रेनिंग वगैरह में भी जैसे हमारा
डीसीजीएसपी कोर्स है। हम उसमें बहुत अच्छे
से बताते हैं। कैसे यूज़ करना है, क्या
करना है एक्सट्रा एक्सट्रा। तो अ
मेटास्प्लॉयड के बारे में आप ऑलरेडी कई
लोग जानते हैं। कई लोगों ने सुना भी है।
ये एक ऐसा फ्रेमवर्क है जिसका यूज करके आप
एक्सप्लइट्स डेवलप कर सकते हैं। एक्सप्लइट
क्रिएट कर सकते हैं। पेलोड्स डिलीवर कर
सकते हैं। इंकोडिंग अ एंड इंक्रिप्शन एंड
ऑल ऑल ऑफ़ थिंग्स यू कैन डू विद दिस हेल्प।
तो आप सेकंड स्टेप में वेपनाइजेशन में इस
तरह के पेलोड्स जो हैं वो बनाते हैं।
मैलवेयर्स जो हैं उनको डेवलप करते हैं।
एक्सप्लइट्स जो हैं उनको आप डेवलप करते
हैं। ये होता है वेपनाइजेशन कि भैया
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदर कर ली। अब हम उस
इंफॉर्मेशन के बेसिस पे पेलोड्स जो है वो
डेवलप करेंगे या क्राफ्ट करेंगे। उसके बाद
आती है भैया हमारी डिलीवरी। ये डिलीवरी।
अब डिलीवरी का मतलब है सेंडिंग द वेपन टू
टारगेट। अब वेपन बना लिया है ना। अब ऐसा
बम ही क्या जो फोड़े ना है ना? बम बना लिया
बट फोड़े ही ना। फिर क्या फायदा? तो जब भी
वेपनाइजेशन हो जाती है तो उसके बाद आती है
बात डिलीवरी की। कि अब उस वेपन को चलाना
है। तो कहां चलाना है? टारगेट के ऊपर
चलाना है। तो उसमें क्या करते हैं? अब
अलग-अलग तरह के वेपन्स हो सकते हैं। जैसे
या तो फिशिंग मेल्स भेजना जिसमें मलेशियस
अटैचमेंट्स होंगे, मलेशियस लिंक्स होंगे
या मशियस वेबसाइट्स के थ्रू मैलवेयर्स को
डाउनलोड करा लेना टारगेट के सिस्टम पे या
एक्सप्लइट्स जो हैं उनको एग्जीक्यूट करा
देना टारगेट के सिस्टम पे। तो ये होता है
डिलीवरी वाले फेज में। ये अटैकर डिलीवरी
फेज में करते हैं। एंड देन हमारी डिलीवरी
के बाद आती है एक्सप्लइटेशन। अब जब
एक्सप्लइट को भाई वहां पर डाल ही दिया है
मतलब पेलोड इन्हने एग्जीक्यूट कर दिया है
आपने सॉरी एग्जीक्यूट कर दिया है जब
सिस्टम को एक्सप्लइट कर लिया है तो अब
बारी है जब सिस्टम को एक्सप्लइट करने की
जब आपने पेलोड भेज दिया जब आपने ये वेपन
वेपन को डिलीवर कर दिया तो अब बारी है उस
पर्टिकुलर एक्सप्लइट एक्सप्लइटेशन करने की
उस पर्टिकुलर प्रोसेस में अब एक्सप्लइटेशन
में क्या होगा कि आप एक्चुअली उस
एक्सप्लइट को रन कर रहे को आप एक्चुअली उस
एक्सप्लइट को एग्जीक्यूट कर रहे हो उस
सिस्टम पे। दैट्स इट। अब उसमें रन मैलवेयर
और एक्सप्लइट कोड ट्रिक यूजर इनू इनेबलिंग
मैक्रोस क्योंकि मैक्रोज़ बेस्ड वलेबिलिटीज़
बहुत सारे अवेलेबल है एक्सप्लइट्स
इनफेक्टेड USB ड्राइव्स या रबर डकी जैसे
ड्राइव्स लगा दिया या कोई भी इनफेक्टेड
ड्राइव जहां पे आपने कोई ऐसी
एग्जीक्यूटेबल रखी है जो कि मैलवेयर या
ट्रोजन कंटेन करता है एंड जैसे ही वो बंदा
उसको एग्जीक्यूट करेगा उसका सिस्टम करप्ट
हो जाएगा। उसका सिस्टम जो है कंप्लीट
कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो जाएगा। तो ये चौथा फेज
होता है जिसमें हम एक्सप्लइट करते हैं
सिस्टम को। वी जस्ट एक्सप्लइट द सिस्टम।
ठीक है? पांचवा यहां पे है इंस्टॉलेशन। अब
भैया जब हमने सिस्टम को कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर
लिया तो उसके बाद क्या स्टेप्स है? ये
इंस्टॉलेशन का मतलब क्या है? इंस्टॉलेशन
का मतलब है कि अब आप बैकडोर इंस्टॉल करते
हैं। पर्सिस्टेंस क्रिएट करने की कोशिश
करते हैं एंड अनपैच्ड सॉफ्टवेयर
वनेबिलिटीज को एक्सप्लइट करने की कोशिश
करते हैं। ये है आपका इंस्टॉलेशन फेज। अब
इंस्टॉलेशन फेज में बेसिकली क्या होता है
कि आप बैक डोर्स या पर्सिस्टेंस क्रिएट
करने की कोशिश करते हैं। एंड एक रास्ता
बनाते हैं आप अपने लिए। रास्ता मतलब बाय
चांस किसी भी तरीके से अगर सिस्टम को या
उस पर्टिकुलर नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर में
किसी को यह पता चल जाता है कि सिस्टम शायद
कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो चुका है तो वो कोशिश
करेगा चारों तरफ से हर पॉसिबल एंगल से टू
गेट रिड ऑफ दिस कॉम्प्रोमाइज। तो अटैकर
क्या करता है कि एक रास्ता बंद हो जाए तो
दूसरा रास्ता खुल जाए। ऐसा कुछ सेटअप कर
देगा उस सिस्टम के ऊपर सर्वर के ऊपर उस
नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर के ऊपर कि बाद
में वो पीछे से बैक डोर से इसीलिए इसका
नाम है बैक डोर इट्स नेम इज़ बैक डोर पीछे
का रास्ता देखते होंगे ना पहले अ हाउ
बैकडोर इज़ क्रिएटेड ये बैकडोर क्रिएट करने
का आप लोगों को अ क्या लगता है कि ये अभी
एक कमांड में बैकडोर क्रिएट होगी नहीं इट
इट विल बी अ डिल्ट इन अह अपकमिंग फ्यूचर
क्लासेस ये पूरी एक एक पूरी पूरी वो है
यार मतलब बैकडोर क्रिएशन अपने आप में एक
पूरी क्लास है। राइट? सो हम ऐसे डायरेक्ट
नहीं वो कर सकते। अभी कांसेप्ट पे थोड़ा
सा फोकस करना है आपको। ठीक है? तभी मैंने
बोला था कि मेरे साथ जाओ फ्लो के साथ जाओ।
यू विल गेट एवरीथिंग। बस मैं इसकी गारंटी
आपको देता हूं। यू विल गेट एवरीथिंग। जो
भी आपके दिमाग में अभी चल रहा है ना जो भी
आप मैसेज में डालते हो चैट में कि सर इसका
मतलब क्या होता है? ये मैं आपको इसलिए वो
बहुत डीप अभी नहीं जा रहा क्योंकि अगर मैं
उस पे जाऊं। मान लो मैं बैकडोर क्रिएशन पे
जाऊं तो बैकडोर क्रिएशन आप बहुत तरीके से
कर सकते हैं। पर्सिस्टेंस आप बहुत तरीके
से बना सकते हैं। बहुत सारे टूल्स अवेलेबल
हैं। एंड देयर आर मल्टीपल मेथड्स। बट फिर
वो तो फिर पूरी एक क्लास है उसकी। तो वो
हम बाद में जब हमें जरूरत पड़ेगी जब हम
पर्सिस्टेंट बनाने की अगर कुछ ऐसा नीड हुआ
तो बिल्कुल हम उसको वी विल बी डूइंग दैट।
तो अब आती है बैकडोर इंस्टॉल करने की। अब
आपने देखा होगा पहले या आज भी बहुत लोग आज
तो फैशन में होता है। पहले जो होते थे ना
गांव गांव जो होते हैं आपके विलेजेज तो
विलेजेस में जो घर होती थी घर होती हैं आज
भी बहुत सारे ऐसे उसमें दो दरवाजे होते
थे। एक तो मेन गेट का जो मेन गेट होता था
जो मेन एंट्री होती थी और एक गांव के घरों
में पीछे से भी एक दरवाजा होता था। बैक
डोर पीछे से एकदम पीछे से। यह आपको पता है
आप लोगों में से यू नो कोई कोई जानता है
इस चीज को अगर आप आपने गांव की लाइफ देखी
होगी या गांव में आपका घर होगा या आप
जानते होंगे तो आपको आई थिंक पता होगा इस
चीज के बारे में राइट देखते हैं कितने
लोगों को पता है हाउ मेनी ऑफ यू हैव सीन
और नो अबाउट दिस यस सर यस सर बहुत लोग
गांव से हैं यार लगता है आप लोग गांव से
हो क्या
वाह
यस सर डाकू से बचने के लिए हां
सही है हां सही है पहले डाकुओं को इतना
दिमाग नहीं होता था ना कि आगे से भी घेर
ले पीछे से भी घेर ले बेचारे आगे से ही
घेरते थे पता नहीं होता था कि पीछे का
दरवाजा है अब तो बहुत स्मार्ट हो गए हैं
भाई अब तो पीछे पीछे जाओगे पीछे से भी
खड़े रहेंगे दो चार ठीक है अब अंडरग्राउंड
बनाना पड़ेगा ठीक है तो दो दरवाजे होते थे
वैसे ही यहां पे जब एक अटैकर सिस्टम को
कंप्लीट एक्सप्लइट कर लेता है। कंप्लीट
कंट्रोल कर लेता है। तो उसके बाद एक
रास्ता वो बना देता है बैक बैक डोर पीछे
का रास्ता ताकि कई बाय चांस अगर एक दरवाजा
बंद हो जाए तो पीछे का एक दरवाजा मैंने जो
बनाया वो खुला रहेगा। बार-बार मैं वापस
एंट्री मारता रहूंगा। एंड वहां पे वो
पर्सिस्टेंस क्रिएट करता है। पर्सिस्टेंस
सिस्टम। पर्सिस्टेंस का मतलब है कि
बार-बार जब भी वो बंदा मान लो लैपटॉप
रीस्टार्ट भी होता है, शट डाउन भी होता
है। फिर वापस जब स्टार्ट होगा तो
ऑटोमेटिकली अटैकर उस सिस्टम से कनेक्ट हो
जाएगा। यह होती है आपका पर्सिस्टेंस
क्रिएट करना। कितना कितना शानदार है ना?
ऑटोमेटिक कनेक्शन हो गई। कुछ करना ही नहीं
है। राइट? एंड इसके लिए वो उस सिस्टम पे
प्रेजेंट अनपैच्ड वनेबिलिटीज को एक्सप्लइट
कर लेता है। मतलब उस सिस्टम पे कोई ऐसी
वनेबिलिटीज वाली सॉफ्टवेयर या पर्टिकुलर
प्रोग्राम पड़ा हुआ है जिसको वो फर्दर
एक्सप्लइट कर लेता है। एंड उससे एक बैकडोर
क्रिएट कर लेता है। ये चीज़ है। बैकडोर
क्रिएट करना इतना आसान भी नहीं है।
जब तक कि कोई एक अनपैच्ड वनेबिलिटी उसको
नहीं मिल जाती एक सिस्टम के अंदर में।
इट्स वेरी टफ। या तो वनेरेबल सिस्टम वैसी
प्रोग्राम सॉफ्टवेयर फाइंड करेगा वो अटैकर
और फिर उसको एक्सप्लइट करके बैकडोर क्रिएट
करेगा या तो पहले से है उसको पता है और
वहां पे अवेलेबल है तो उसको बैकडोर क्रिएट
करने में आसानी होगी बट अगर बिल्कुल ही
पैज सॉफ्टवेयर से कुछ ऐसा नहीं है तो ये
बैकडोर क्रिएट करना उतना ही मुश्किल हो
जाता है बट जब कोई अटैकर इतने बड़े लेवल पे
अटैक करते हैं एंड इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर पे
अटैक करते हैं तो उनको बहुत कुछ ऑलरेडी
पता होता है ऑलरेडी दे अह अह ऑलरेडी दे अह
नो कि कौन से सिस्टम कौन से सॉफ्टवेयर
प्रोग्राम्स किस तरह से एक्सप्लइटेड किए
जा सकते हैं। यह होता है हमारा पांचवा।
देन हमारा आता है छठा कमांड एंड कंट्रोल।
अब ये जो कमांड एंड कंट्रोल है जिसको कि
आप सीएनसी या सी2 ये भी बोलते हैं कमांड
एंड कंट्रोल। यह होती है कॉम्प्रोमाइज
सिस्टम को रिमोटली कंट्रोल करना। इसका
मतलब यह होता है कॉम्प्रोमाइज जो भी
सिस्टम है उसको रिमोटली कंट्रोल करना।
यस क्या होता है यह कम्युनिकेट विद अटैकर
C2 सर्वर एग्जीक्यूट कमांड्स रिमोटली
अटैकर का एक C2 सर्वर होता है कमांड एंड
कंट्रोल सर्वर उससे ये कम्युनिकेट करता है
राइट एंड ये रिमोटली आप कनेक्ट हो जाते हो
उस पर्टिकुलर मशीन से और एग्जीक्यूट कर
सकते हो कमांड्स को सिंपल एक सिंपल का
मतलब एक सिंपल इसका मतलब ये समझिए
एक तरह का रिवर्स सेल एक तरह का यू कैन से
रिवर्स शेल
आप एक सिस्टम से रिमोटली कनेक्टेड हैं। एक
टनल के थ्रू एंड दैट्स व्हाट कमांड एंड
कंट्रोल डस। बस यही है। आप इसके अंदर
मल्टीपल कमांड्स चला सकते हैं। एग्जीक्यूट
कर सकते हैं। जो भी कमांड्स चलाने हैं यू
कैन एग्जीक्यूट ऑन टारगेट सिस्टम। एंड
उसके बाद उसके बाद लास्ट में आता है
एक्शंस ऑन ऑब्जेक्टिव्स। डिप्लॉय
रैंसमवेयर और ल्च डीडीओएस और गेट एनी
काइंड ऑफ फाइल सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
डाउनलोड एनी काइंड ऑफ इनेशन एग्जीक्यूट
फर्दर मालवेयर्स और ट्रोजंस की लॉगर्स एंड
फर्दर एक्सप्लइटेशन ये एकशंस ऑन
ऑब्जेक्टिव्स आ जाते हैं। मतलब कि जो भी
आपका ऑब्जेक्टिव है क्या ऑब्जेक्टिव हो
सकता है अटैकर का डेटा को चुराना सेंसिटिव
इंफॉर्मेशन को चुराना लैटरल मूवमेंट करना
नेटवर्क में नेटवर्क में लैटरल मूवमेंट का
मतलब होता है कि एक ही नेटवर्क में
मल्टीपल डिवाइसेस जब होते हैं एक नेटवर्क
में जब वो एक डिवाइस के अंदर घुस जाता है
एंड वहां पे अगर जीरो ट्रस्ट फॉलो नहीं हो
रही है तो वो मल्टीपल डिवाइसेस के अंदर
में अपनी एंट्री कर सकता है वो घुस सकता
है क्योंकि जीरो ट्रस्ट इज नॉट एप्लीके
लेके बोलते हैं। दैट्स व्हाई द ज़ीरो अह
ट्रस्ट कांसेप्ट अह जो आया था इसी के ऊपर
आया था। क्योंकि जीरो ट्रस्ट वाज़ वेरीेंट
एंड वाज़ वेरी नीडेड। क्योंकि अटैकर एक बार
नेटवर्क में घुस जाता था तो नेटवर्क उसको
ट्रस्ट कर लेती थी कि भैया अटैकर तुम तो
ट्रस्टेड हो यार। घुस गए हो तुम तो एक
डिवाइस में सब में घुसो। अब अटैकर मस्त
आराम से एकदम बैठता था। मस्त एक सिस्टम से
दूसरे दूसरे तीसरे तीसरे चौथे ड करते-करते
घुस जा घुसते रहता था। पता ही नहीं चलता
था लोगों को कि भाई इस एक सिस्टम को
इनफेक्ट किया था। यहां पे 50 सिस्टम
इनफेक्ट हो चुके हैं। और इसके बहुत सारे
एग्जांपल्स हैं। जैसे मैंने आपको बताया था
सप्लाई चेन अटैक में इसका बहुत बड़ा रोल
है। मैंने बताया था ना सप्लाई चेन अटैक
गाइस। यू रिमेंबर सप्लाई चेन अटैक? आपको
याद है? बताइए मुझे।
याद है क्या सप्लाई चेन अटैक
यार कमेंट्स देखो यार एक तो पहली बात तुम
जो जितने लोग बचे हैं लाइक ठोक दो
जिन्होंने नहीं ठोका। दूसरी चीज कि जब
पूछता हूं तो सभी आंसर करो ना चैट में।
तुम आंसर नहीं करते हो यहां पे मेरे को
मजा नहीं आता फिर।
देखो जब मैं फ्री में अगर जॉब रेडी
ट्रेनिंग दे रहा हूं ना तो पैसे के अलावा
जितनी एक्सपेक्टेशन है सब फुलफिल करनी
पड़ेगी आपको। याद रखिएगा पैसा तो वैसे ही
नहीं मांग रहा मैं। ट्रेनिंग के लिए पैसा
मैं ना मांग रहा हूं ना मांगूंगा कभी। इस
बात की मैं आपको गारंटी देता हूं।
ट्रेनिंग के लिए कोई एक पैसा किसी का नहीं
लगने वाला है। तो कम से कम वो करो। हां।
क्या बात है प्रिंस आपने वाजू को सेटअप कर
लिया है बहुत अच्छी बात है यू आर गोइंग
ग्रेट बहुत बढ़िया बहुत अच्छी बात है ये
टास्क दिया था मैंने अगर आपने कर लिया है
तो बहुत अच्छी बात है इट्स गुड
कांग्रेचुलेशंस एंड अच्छा कर रहे हो आपके
जैसे आई होप सभी लोग करें अच्छे से पूरी
ऑनेस्टी एंड डेडिकेशन के साथ तो एसओसी
एनालिस्ट एल1 बनना बहुत आसान इंसान है।
अगर आप मैं आपको गारंटी दे रहा हूं ना
मैंने पहले भी बोला हुआ है कि अगर आपने
फुल 100% डडीिकेशन और अपनी ईमानदारी दिखाई
ना इस ट्रेनिंग को करने में और मैं जो बोल
रहा हूं उसको फॉलो किया
और आप अगर एलिजिबल हैं जॉब के लिए आप 12th
क्लास के हो तो थोड़ी ना जॉब कर लोगे जाके
एलोन की तरह वो नॉलेज के लिए स्किल के लिए
बहुत बढ़िया हो जाएगा कि आपको ऐसी स्किल
अभी मिल जाएगी और कॉलेज खत्म होते-होते तो
आप मास्टर हो जाओगे। फिर तो आपको कोई रोक
भी नहीं सकता है जॉब के लिए। जॉब आपके
पीछे पीछे आएंगी। तो स्कूल वालों के लिए
नहीं थी बट कॉलेज में है, थर्ड ईयर में
है, फाइनल ईयर में, प्री फाइनल ईयर इन सब
में है। तो आपको जॉब लेने से एल1 का कोई
भी इंटरव्यूअर नहीं रोक सकेगा। मैं आपको
इस बात की गारंटी देता हूं। इंटरव्यूअर के
हर क्वेश्चन का जवाब आपके पास होगा इस
ट्रेनिंग के बाद। मैं इसको रिटेन में दे
सकता हूं। क्योंकि मैं इस ट्रेनिंग को
खत्म करने के बाद इंटरव्यूज के अलग से कुछ
वीडियोस की सीरीज चलाऊंगा। चार या पांच या
दो या तीन डिपेंड करता है उस पे चलेंगी
आपकी उसमें मैं स्पेशली इंटरव्यू के लिए
प्रिपेयर कराऊंगा आपको कि कैसे और किस तरह
के क्वेश्चंस और मैं मुझे ऐसा लगता है कि
इंटरव्यूज वालों जो है ना एसओसी के एल वन
के लिए जो इंटरव्यूज लेते हैं इंडिया में
जितनी भी कंपनीज़ इंटरव्यू लेती हैं मुझे
लगता है उनको इंटरव्यू के पैटर्न को चेंज
करना पड़ जाएगा उसके बाद क्योंकि उनको ऐसा
लगेगा कि जो भी बंदा आ रहा है वीडियोस को
देख के वो इंटरव्यू क्रैक कर ले रहा है।
हायरिंग हो रही है दो बंदों की। वहां पर
एप्लीकेशन आए हैं 50 बंदों की और 50ों का
इंटरव्यू क्लियर हो रहा है। ऐसे कैसे होगा
भाई? अब [हंसी] अच्छा ऐसा होगा तो कैसे
क्या होगा फिर कंपनी के अंदर में के किसको
हायर करेंगे? मान लो 50 इंटरव्यू के लिए
आए हैं। 50ों ने डिफ्रॉनिक्स के इंटरव्यू
सेशन देखे हैं एसओसी के। और 50ों ने
बिल्कुल हर क्वेश्चन का सही जवाब दिया है।
मुझे ये बताओ कैसे हायर करेंगे वो? और
हायरिंग करनी है सिर्फ दो लोगों की टीम
में।
राइट? तो यह पॉसिबल एलिजिबल जो होगा मैं
मैं बोलता हूं 50ों के 50ों एलिजिबल है
यार। 50ों के 50ों मान लो फ्रेशर्स हैं।
कॉलेज पास आउट हैं। ये बताओ ना। ऐसा भी तो
हो सकता है कि 100 लोग पहुंचे। 50 लोग
कॉलेज पास आउट हो। हायरिंग सिर्फ दो या
तीन को करनी हो। 50 ऐसा करें। फिर क्या
होगा?
स्टोन पेपर सीज़र। [हंसी]
स्टोन पेपर सीज़र। हां ये भी सही है। ये
मुट्ठी वाली ना ऐसेसे ट
हां स्टोन पेपर सीजा करेंगे या दांत से
ऐसे उंगलियों को ऐसे काटेंगे ना जिस पे
ज्यादा कटी वो उधर राइट लेफ्ट करके उसको
हायर कर लेंगे
यही करेंगे मुझे लगता है
हां मैं बोल रहा हूं ना उनको चेंज करना
पड़ेगा अपना प्रोसेस उनको इंटरव्यू के
क्वेश्चन शायद बहुत थोड़ा अलग टाइप से कर
लेने पड़ेंगे शायद मुझे लगता है
सीजीपीए देखेंगे हां ये भी है
फर्स्ट
हां और तुम लोग इंटरव्यू देने जाना तो
बताना जरूर कि अगर कोई पूछे ना इंटरव्यू
देने जाना तो तुम सर्टिफिकेशन कुछ भी कर
लो। कहीं से भी कर लो एसओसी के
सर्टिफिकेशन। आई डोंट केयर। बिकॉज़ जितने
भी सर्टिफिकेशन करोगे उसमें जो भी पढ़ाया
जाएगा वो यहां से कम पढ़ाया जाएगा। मैं
आपको लिख के दे देता हूं। इस बात को भी
लिख लेना कहीं पे कि आप दुनिया की जो भी
सर्टिफिकेशन कर लो एसओसी के पूरे इंडिया
ऑल ओवर वर्ल्ड के सर्टिफिकेशंस एसओसी के
जितने भी अवेलेबल हैं एल1 की मैं बात कर
रहा हूं मैं हमेशा जब बात कर रहा हूं
फिलहाल एल1 की बात कर रहा हूं क्योंकि मैं
जो कराता हूं जो मैं कराऊंगा वही मैं
बोलूंगा फालतू बातें नहीं करनी है ठीक है
तो एल1 की जो भी सर्टिफिकेशन उससे रिलेटेड
होगी कर लो और उसमें जो भी पढ़ाया जाएगा
वो मैं जो यहां पे करा रहा हूं उससे कम
रहेगा जाओ कहीं पे बोल देना किसी को भी
बोल देना और अगर इससे ज्यादा कहीं पे होगा
तो मुझे बता बता देना मैं उसी दिन सारे
वीडियोस जो है हटा लूंगा अगर आप बोलोगे तो
कि सर हटा लो आपके वीडियोस से ज्यादा मुझे
मिल गया कहीं
ठीक है
सर बग बंटी भाई बग बंटी की सीरीज में वीक
में एक वीडियो लाया करें इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट
बग बंटी की वीडियोस आएंगी भाई आएंगी टेंशन
मत लो जल्दी आएंगी बग बंटी में तो इतनी
वीडियोस अभी डाल दी है यार कि अगर उसी को
कंप्लीट कर लो तो तुम वैसे ही मास्टर बन
जाओगे। अभी रिसेंटली हमारे एक लर्नर हैं
नरेंद्र नाम है। उनकी 5000 की बाउंट लगी
है। और आप लोग बोलते हो कि सर
कर नहीं पा रहे हैं कंप्लीट। बहुत सारे
बहाने होते हैं कई लोगों के। सर हो नहीं
पाता। बाउंट नहीं मिलती। यार आप ही लोगों
में से निकलते हैं ना। सोचो उन उनका कैसे
हो रहा है। कुछ तो हो रहा है। कुछ तो बात
होगी। राइट?
नरेंद्र मोदी अरे यार नरेंद्र नरेंद्र
करके कोई एक लड़का है नरेंद्र नाम कुछ और
है नरेंद्र पटेल या कुछ ऐसे नरेंद्र मोदी
नहीं है [हंसी]
नरेंद्र मोदी बग बाउंट नहीं करते भाई उनको
जरूरत ही नहीं है बग बाउंट करने की
ठीक है
मोदी को मोदी को जरूरत नहीं है बग बाउंट
करने की
यह सब गरीबों के लिए बनी है यार। यह सब बग
बंटी यह सब गरीब लोग करते हैं। जैसे मतलब
जैसे जैसे हम लोग हैं ना हम लोग करते हैं।
हमें पैसे चाहिए तो हम करते हैं।
चलो जोक्स अपार्ट ये एक बहुत बड़ा मजाक
था। इसको कृपया सीरियस ना लिया जाए और
इसको लेके मुद्दा ना बनाया जाए। चलिए आगे
बढ़ते हैं।
तो ये एक्शन ऑन ऑब्जेक्टिव्स ये रहा। तो
लैटरल मूवमेंट करते हैं। एक डिवाइस में
घुस के पूरे नेटवर्क को बर्बाद करना। एंड
रैंसमवे एयर लिया DOS अटैक या डीडी
बेसिकली डीडीओएस अटैक ल्च करते हैं। मतलब
रैंसमवेयर अटैक ल्च कर देंगे। चलो भाई
सारे फाइल्स को इंक्रिप्ट कर दो।
इंपॉर्टेंट फाइल्स को इंक्रिप्ट कर दो।
लॉक लगा दो। अब भाई इतने बिटकॉइन, इतने
इतने इथेरियम या जो भी क्रिप्टो करेंसी है
ट्रांसफर करो फिर लॉक हटाएंगे। कई केसेस
में हट जाती हैं। कई केसेस में हटती नहीं
है। कई केसेस में बेवकूफ बना देते हैं। तो
देयर आर मल्टीपल थिंग्स राइट? देयर आर
मल्टीपल देयर आर मल्टीपल थिंग्स
सर आप पर केस कर दूंगा। हां करो भाई करो
करो केस के केस जल्दी करो यार केस करोगे
केस केस करोगे तो मुझे मजा आएगा
कम से कम थोड़ी तो पॉपुलैरिटी बढ़ेगी
इंसान उसमें आएगा तो
चलो तो ये सात फेजेस
जो आपके थे एक्सप्लइटेशन का मतलब है कि आप
अपने पेलोड को डिलीवर कर चुके हो वहां पे
सिस्टम के ऊपर में और उसको आप रन कर चुके
हो एंड उस वलेबिलिटीज को एक्सप्लइट करके
एंड उस सिस्टम का जो है एक्सेस आप ले चुके
हो। एक्सप्लइटेशन में यह होता है।
ठीक है?
दैट्स इट। गॉट इट? ये होता है
एक्सप्लॉयटेशन। चलिए
अब यहां पे आते हैं स्टेजेस ऑफ साइबर किल
चेन के कुछ
एक्टिविटी जो एथिकल एक्टिविटी होती है
एथिकल हैकिंग के अंदर में उसके ऊपर समझते
हैं हम थोड़ी सी ताकि और भी क्लेरिटी हो
आपको और भी क्लेरिटी इसको मिले। एक-एक चीज
बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है। अगर आप सोच रहे हैं
कि इसमें कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट नहीं है तो ये
आपकी बहुत बड़ी गलतफहमी है। और एक-एक चीज
इंपॉर्टेंट का मतलब है कि आपके लिए यह
छोटी-छोटी चीजें जो हैं यही आपका
जो है वह सबसे बड़ा
हथियार बनने वाला है इंटरव्यू के टाइम
में। तो इसको ध्यान रखना यह चीजें
छोटी-छोटी चीजें आपसे मिस होंगी अभी एंड
इंटरव्यू के टाइम में आप जवाब नहीं दे
पाएंगे। यू हैव टू अंडरस्टैंड इट।
ओके? सबसे पहला है रिकॉग्नोसेंस।
रिकॉग्नोसेंस गैदरिंग इंटेल ऑन द टारगेट।
बता दिया मैंने ये। ठीक है? एंड एथिकल
एक्टिविटी क्या है? पैसिव एंड एक्टिव
फुटप्रिंटिंग। इसमें हम करते हैं पैसिव या
एक्टिव फुटप्रिंटिंग करते हैं। यह करते
हैं। दूसरा है वेपनाइजेशन।
कपलिंग एन एक्सप्लइट विथ अ बैक डोर। मतलब
हम एक एक्सप्लइट को बैक डोर के साथ मिलाते
हैं। एक वेपन तैयार करते हैं या फिर
एक्सप्लइट को बेसिकली हम रेडी करते हैं।
पेलोड्स क्रिएट करते हैं। पेलोड
क्राफ्टिंग विथ मेटासइट या कोबाल्ट
स्ट्राइक। हम ये काम करते हैं। डिलीवरी
सेंडिंग द वेपन टू द विक्टिम। चाहे वो
ईमेल के थ्रू हो, USB के थ्रू हो, वेब के
थ्रू हो, कैसे भी उसमें हम फिशिंग
सेमुलेशन इसका एक एग्जांपल है। ये अ
फिशिंग सेमुलेशन करते हैं।
ओके? देन हमारा एक्सप्लॉयटेशन द बूम
मूवमेंट ट्रिगरिंग द वनेबिलिटी। अब उससे
वनेबिलिटी को ट्रिगर करते हैं।
एक्सप्लइटेशन में एग्जीक्यूटिंग अ बफर
ओवरफ्लो और एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन। जब हम
एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन को एग्जीक्यूट करते हैं
या बफर रिव ओवरफ्लो जैसी वनेबिलिटीज को
एग्जीक्यूट करते हैं। एक्सप्लइटेशन का
पार्ट है। इंस्टॉलेशन में इंस्टॉलिंग
पर्सिस्टेंट मैलवेयर ऑन द विक्टिम्स एसेट
या सिस्टम सेटिंग अप पर्सिस्टेंस शेल और
रूट किट्स जहां जब हम सिस्टम पे विक्टिम
के रूट किट्स या हम पर्सिस्टेंस शेल जो है
वो सेटअप करते हैं। जहां पे हम बार-बार
एक्सेस ले सकें वो इंस्टॉलेशन में आती है।
C2 कमांड एंड कंट्रोल एस्टैब्लिशिंग अ
रिमोट चैनल फॉर कंट्रोल। रिमोट एक टनल के
थ्रू कंट्रोल लेते हैं। वह टनल्स मोस्टली
सिक्योर टनल्स होते हैं। एंड सिस्टम पे
कंट्रोल हमारा हो जाता है। कॉन्फ़िगरिंग C2
फ्रेमवर्क्स लाइक मिथिक और हैवक। ऐसे
फ्रेमवर्क C2 फ्रेमवक्स आते हैं। इनको
कॉन्फ़िगर करते हैं। ये क्लाइंट अ C2
फ्रेमवक्स हैं। एक तरह से जो आपके विक्टिम
पे इंस्टॉल हो जाते हैं। कॉन्फ़िगर हो जाते
हैं। एंड कमांड एंड कंट्रोल सर्वर जो
हमारे अटैकर भैया की होती है उनसे कनेक्ट
हो जाते हैं। एंड फर्दर जो भी कमांड्स
वमांड रन करनी है, जो भी चीजें करनी है वो
सब चीजें जो है आप इसके थ्रू अटैकर जो है
वो करता है। देन एक्शन आता है फाइनल गोल
जिसमें कि डेटा थफ्ट होती है, इंक्रिप्शन
होता है, डिस्ट्रक्शंस होती हैं। ये सब
कुछ होता है। एंड इसमें क्या होता है?
डेटा एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन टेस्टिंग। ठीक है?
जिसमें कि डेटा को एक्सफिल्ट्रेट किया
जाता है, डेटा को चुराया जाता है, निकाला
जाता है अलग-अलग तरीकों से। एंड देन ये
हमारा लास्ट स्टेप हो जाता है। मेन थिंग
इज़ दिस। तो ये जो पर्टिकुलर पूरा ये जो
स्टेप्स हैं सात जो स्टेप्स हैं अब इन
स्टेप्स में से कोई एक स्टेप भी जैसे मान
लो कोई भी एक स्टेप को अगर सक्सेसफुली
मिटिगेट कर दिया गया या वहीं पे अटैक को
रोक दिया गया तो ये पूरा का पूरा साइबर
किल चेन जो है फेल हो जाता है एंड अटैकर
की अटैक रुक जाती है। अटैकर की वेपनाइजेशन
को रोक दिया जाए, डिलीवरी को रोक दिया
जाए, एक्सप्लइटेशन को रोक दिया जाए,
इंस्टॉलेशन को रोक दिया जाए, तो कमांड एंड
कंट्रोल को रोक दिया जाए। तो, यहां पे यह
एक अटैक फेल हो जाती है। एंड कंपनीज़ को
बेसिकली यही करना होता है टू सिंपल। यहां
पे मैंने तभी यहां पे लिखा है कि बाय
ब्रेकिंग द चेन एट एनी पॉइंट, यू स्टॉप द
एंटायर अटैक। एक किसी भी पॉइंट पे इस चेन
को आपने तोड़ा और आपने पूरे अटैक को रोक
दिया। एज एसोसिएशन एनालिस्ट आपका काम इस
चीज पे फोकस करना भी रहेगा कि आप इस चेन
को तोड़ दो कैसे भी करके चाहे आप खुद से
तोड़ दो L2 L3 की मदद ले लो अपने सीनियर्स
की मदद ले लो सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर की मदद
ले लो मैनेजर की मदद ले लो या जैसे भी
लेना है जो भी हरार्की है तुम्हारी L1 L2
L3 इंजीनियर मैनेजर और सीटीओ सीईओ जो भी
है बट इसको तोड़ो जहां इसने आपने इस चेन को
तोड़ा वहां आप हीरो बन जाते हैं एंड वहां
आपने एक बड़ी अटैक को सक्सेसफुली मिटिगेट
कर दिया है। चलिए अब हम एक-एक जो हमारा ये
चेन का पार्ट है उसको एग्जांपल के साथ
टेक्निक्स के साथ एंड एज अ एसओसी आप किस
तरीके से आपको अप्रोच करना चाहिए उसके साथ
भी समझते हैं। ठीक है? अब मैं अगर चाहता
तो मैं यहीं पे किल किल चेन को खत्म कर
सकता हूं। साइबर किल चेन का ये जो
फ्रेमवर्क मैंने आपको दिखाया सब कुछ
एक्सप्लेन करा। आई कैन एंड दिस पर्टिकुलर
टॉपिक राइट हियर एंड यू विल नॉट लेट यू
विल नॉट बी नोइंग कि यहां पे इसके आगे भी
कुछ हो सकता है। ये मैं कर सकता हूं। बट
मैंने जैसे बताया आप लोगों को मैं आपको
बार-बार इसीलिए बोलता हूं कि अ ऐसी
ट्रेनिंग आपको कहीं नहीं मिलेगी। बार-बार
मैं इसलिए फोकस इसलिए करता हूं। आप आपको
भी ऐसा लगता होगा ना अरे सर क्या एक ही
बात को बार-बार रिपीट मारते हो। तो रिपीट
मारना तो मेरी आदत है। बहुत लोग मेरे
रिपीट रिपीट करने की आदत से परेशान होते
हैं। राइट? रियल लाइफ में भी। बट मैं क्या
करूं? आदत है तो झेलना तो पड़ेगा। तो
सच्चाई रिपीट करता हूं मैं। तो रिपीट में
यहां पे ये है कि बार-बार बार-बार बार-बार
बार-बार मैं चीजों को एक्सप्लेन करता हूं।
उसके पीछे रीज़न है कि इसको मैं एक लेवल
अलग लेवल पर करा रहा हूं। ये नॉर्मल
ट्रेनिंग की तरह नहीं है। लाइव ट्रेनिंग
जो नॉर्मल कोई ट्रेनिंग हो गई।
डिफ्रॉनिक्स पे बेसिकली ऐसी कोई ट्रेनिंग
होती ही नहीं है। डिफ्रॉनिक्स के जितने
ट्रेनिंग है सब ऐसे ही होते हैं मोस्टली।
तो आपको इस चीज को थोड़ा सा समझना पड़ेगा।
सिंसियरली लेना पड़ेगा। आपने ले लिया
सिंसियरली तो आपकी लाइफ सेट हो जाएगी। मैं
आपको मैं देखो आपसे तुम जाओगे वो एमएलएम
जो होती है मल्टीलेवल मार्केटिंग वाली जो
सेमिनार्स वगैरह होते हैं ये सब जो होते
हैं उसमें देखते होंगे कि एक इंसान आता है
बोलता है कि मेरे पास सात गाड़ियां हैं
Rolls Ryce है
तुम्हारा BMW है Lamborghini है नहीं
Lamborghini नहीं बोलता है LMG
कुछ ऐसे बोला था एक Lamborghini ऐसे कुछ
बोला बोला था मतलब बोलने भी नहीं आता है
फिर भी वो सब रखते भी हैं बेचारे तो वहां
पे सोचो कितना मोटिवेशन आपको देते हैं और
लोग वहां मोटिवेट होते भी हैं। पैसा लेते
हैं वो आपसे जबकि अलग-अलग तरीके से यहां
तो पैसा बिना लिए हुए भी मैं आपको अगर ऐसी
चीज दे रहा हूं तो मोटिवेशन खुद में आनी
चाहिए आपको। राइट?
हां।
हां, देखते हैं। देखते हैं। कुछ पोस्ट को
लाइक करता हूं मैं।
लाइव में मजा आता है ना? हां, वही तो
मैंने बोला यार। लाइव में मजा आता है।
हां हां वही एमएलएम वालों को कुछ नहीं
करना। बस तीन लोगों को ऐड करना है।
इन फ्यूचर कितने क्लासेस होने वाले हैं?
ये तो डिपेंड करता है कोर्स के ऊपर। तीन
से 4 महीने का टाइमलाइन है। जितने भी
क्लासेस हो जाए पूरी कोर्स कंप्लीट हो
जाएगी उतने होंगे।
ठीक है?
तो मैं आपको ऐसे समझा के यहां पर खत्म कर
सकता था। बट यहां पर मैं और आगे सॉरी
और आगे भी मैं आपको लेकर जा रहा हूं ताकि
आपको ये प्रोफेशनल तरीके से समझ में आए और
भी प्रोफेशनल तरीके से एज अ एसओसी
माइंडसेट से आपको समझ में आए कि एज अ
एसओसी आपको कैसे टैकल करना है। तो पहला
हमारा है रिकॉनसेंस। द फर्स्ट वन इज़
रिकॉनसेंस।
यहां पे क्या होता है? अटैकर कलेक्ट्स इन
अबाउट टारगेट विदाउट टचिंग इट डायरेक्टली।
मोस्टली इसको हम बोलते हैं पैसिव
रिकॉनसेंस। जहां पे अटैकर को टारगेट से
डायरेक्ट कनेक्टिविटी कोई नहीं होती है।
उसको हम पैसिव रिकॉनसेंस या पैसिव इनफेशन
गैदरिंग या पैसिव अटैक बोलते हैं। और जहां
आप किसी टारगेट से इंटरेक्ट करते हैं उसको
हम एक्टिव रिकॉग्निसेंस बोलते हैं।
रैक्टिव अटैक बोलते हैं। एक्टिव इनफेशन
गैदरिंग बोलते हैं। याद रखिएगा। एक्टिव
मींस देखो इसको ऐसे कनेक्ट कर लो ना।
एक्टिव मींस कनेक्शन बनाना। कनेक्ट होना।
पैसिव मतलब पीछे-पीछे साइड से करना।
अटैकर्स माइंडसेट। अटैकर यहां माइंडसेट
क्या होता है? बिफोर अटैकिंग आई मस्ट नो
हु व्हाट वेयर एंड हाउ। बिफोर अटैक। तो
थ्री डब्ल्यूस एंड वन एच 3 डब्ल्यू एच
डब्ल्यू डब्ल्यू डब्ल्यू एच। ठीक है? तो
इसको ऐसे समझ लो। डब्ल्यू डब्ल्यू डब्ल्यू
यह तो पता है आपको वर्ल्ड वाइड वेब वाली
एंड देन H
समझे? वर्ल्ड वाइड वेब हैकर ऐसे समझो।
उसका मतलब है हु, व्हाट, वेयर एंड हाउ। यह
अटैकर का सोच होता है। अब मैं आपको कुछ
रियल वर्ल्ड के एग्जांपल्स अगर उसके थ्रू
समझाऊं तो फाइंडिंग एंप्लई ईमेल्स
एंप्लाइजज़ के ईमेल फाइंड करना ताकि फिशिंग
एंड अलग कैंपेन ल्च किया जा सके।
आइडेंटिफाइंग कंपनी डोमेन एंड सब डोमेनस
ताकि उन डोमेनस या सब डोमेनस का यूज करके
एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड को एक्सप्लइट करके या
एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड्स के थ्रू पता करके फिशिंग
ईमेल्स क्राफ्ट किया जा सके कंपनी के मेल
के बिहाफ में एंड सब डोमेनस पे अटैक करके
वनेरेबल सब डोमेनस या वलनेरेबल डेटाबेसिस
को एक्सप्लइट किया जा सके वहां से डिटेल्स
निकाली जा सके फाइंडिंग टेक्नोलॉजीस यूज़्ड
जैसे कि वर्डप्रेस Apacचे यूज़ हो रही है
आईएस यूज़ हो रहा है या कौन सा थीम यूज़ हो
रहा है कौन सी लैंग्वेज यूज़ हो रही है।
उसका वर्जन क्या है? ताकि हम देख सके कि
वो पर्टिकुलर वर्जन या वो पर्टिकुलर
सॉफ्टवेयर वनेरेबल है किसी पर्टिकुलर
वनेबिलिटी से या नहीं। अगर वनरेबल है तो
एक्सप्लइटेबल है कि नहीं? एक्सप्लइटेबल है
तो फिर कैसे एक्सप्लइट करना है ताकि उनको
एक्सप्लइट करके आसानी से जो है हम एंट्री
कर पाएं। स्टडिंग Lindin प्रोफाइल। Lindin
प्रोफाइल हेल्प्स यू अ लॉट। एक Lindin
प्रोफाइल से आपको एक पर्टिकुलर एंप्लई के
बारे में बहुत कुछ पता चल जाता है कि वो
किस चीज पे काम कर रहा है, कैसे काम कर
रहा है। कंपनी के lindin प्रोफाइल से उस
कंपनी के बारे में बहुत कुछ पता चल जाती
है। कौन सा प्रोजेक्ट चल रहा है, किस
प्रोजेक्ट पे कौन से लोग असाइन है। कौन सा
जो अह उसका एंप्लई है वो किस रोल पे काम
कर रहा है। एंड उससे आपको आईडिया लग जाएगा
कि किस पर्टिकुलर एंप्लई को टारगेट करना
है। फाइंडिंग लीक्ड पासवर्ड्स ऐसी बहुत
सारी कंपनीज़ हैं जिसके डेटा ब्रचेस पहले
हुए हैं। एंड उसमें पासवर्ड्स लीक हुए
हैं। बहुत सारे पासवर्ड ब्रीचेस हुए हैं।
और उन पासवर्ड्स को ही कई कंपनीज़ जो है
उनके एंप्लई यूज़ करते हैं। ब्रिज्ड
पासवर्ड को। अब तो Google वगैरह Chrome
वगैरह आपको ब्रिज्ड पासवर्ड का नोटिफिकेशन
भी दे देता है अगर आप पासवर्ड डालेंगे तो।
पर स्टिल कई लोग सोचते हैं ईजी टू यूज़ है।
ईजी टू मेमोराइज है। तो उसको यूज़ कर लेते
हैं। भाई क्या ही जाता है? कौन आ रहा है
इतना हमारे पीछे भागने? तो ये इनका एक
एग्जांपल्स है। ये ये चीजें फाइंड करने की
कोशिश करते हैं।
अब इनमें कौन-कौन से टूल्स एंड टेक्निक्स
का यूज़ होता है? तो Google डॉकिंग का काफी
ज्यादा यूज़ केस है रेनोसेंस में। हु इज
लुकअप किया जाता है वेबसाइट्स वगैरह के
लिए डोमेनस के लिए डीएनएस इनमरेशन किया
जाता है वेबसाइट्स का डीएनएस इनमरेशन से
आपको डीएनएस एंट्रीज डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड्स का
पता चलता है कि उस कंपनी के डोमेन में ए
रिकॉर्ड क्या हैं सीनेम रिकॉर्ड्स क्या है
एमएक्स रिकॉर्ड्स क्या है आपके टीएक्सटी
रिकॉर्ड्स क्या है अलग-अलग एनएस नेम सर्वर
रिकॉर्ड क्या है इससे डोमेन के बारे में
बहुत कुछ पता चलता है रजिस्ट्रार का पता
चलता है कब डोमेन का बाय कब उसका
एक्सपायरी किस किस तरीके से डोमेन सेटअप
किया हुआ है सब कुछ पता चलता है। ठीक है?
तो ये बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट फैक्टर्स होती हैं।
अब मैंने आपको बताया था कि जब भी मैं कोई
क्लासेस कराता हूं आपको तो आपको चीजों को
खुद से एक्सप्लोर करनी है। ठीक है? बिना
उसके आप आगे बढ़ेंगे तो ये डेंजरस होगा।
मैं पहले ही बता दे रहा हूं। तो अब क्या
एक्सप्लोर करना है? कुछ लोग पूछ रहे थे सर
एक्सप्लोर क्या करना है? मतलब कौन से
टॉपिक करनी है? तो मैं आपको बोला था
ऑलरेडी कि जब भी कोई इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक
आपको दिखे जब मैं करा रहा हूं। बोल रहा
हूं। जस्ट आई एम सेइंग इट। जस्ट राइट इट
डाउन समवेयर या जब रिकॉर्डिंग देख रहे हो
तो आप उसको पॉइंट आउट कीजिए पॉइंट लिखिए
जैसे Google डॉकिंग कई लोगों के लिए
Google डॉकिंग मे बी अ न्यू थिंग कई लोगों
के लिए इट्स ऑलरेडी अ ओल्ड टेक्निक या नोन
टेक्निक जो काफी लोग यूज़ करते हैं जिनको
नहीं पता Google डॉकिंग क्या होता है जाओ
ना यार एक Google पे Google डॉकिंग व्हाट
इज़ Google डॉकिंग चैट जीपीटी पे Google
डॉकिंग के बारे में लिखो सर्च करो उसके
बारे में एक छोटी इनफेशन ले लो मैं नहीं
ये बोल रहा कि इसमें डीप घुस जाओ इसमें
जाके कंफ्यूज हो जाओ Google Google डॉकिंग
इटसेल्फ हु इज़ लुक अप इटसेल्फ कैन बी अ
वेरी अ ब्रॉड टॉपिक जिसमें आप बहुत कुछ
सीख सकते हैं। बट आपको उतना नहीं घुसना
है। यू डोंट हैव टू मास्टर Google डॉकिंग
और हु इज़ लुक अप अभी फिलहाल के लिए इन अगर
हम एसओसी परसेप्शन
को लेकर आए तो अभी मास्टर नहीं करना बट
उसकी नॉलेज रखनी है। दैट्स इट। तो इसके
बारे में थोड़ी सर्च करो। डीएनएस इनमरेशन
कैसे क्या होती है? उसके बारे में सर्च
करो। एंड ओसेंट ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस इसका
भी यूज़ केस होता है। इसके बारे में सर्च
करो। अगर ओसेंट के बारे में पढ़ना है तो
हमारे डिफ़ॉनस एकडमी YouTube चैनल पे लाइव
सेक्शन या प्लेलिस्ट में ओसेंट पे जाइएगा।
वहां पे ओसेंट की पूरी प्लेलिस्ट पड़ी है।
फ्री में ओसेंट सीख लीजिएगा। अब इससे
ज्यादा क्या कर सकते हैं? अगर
स्ट्रक्चरर्ड बहुत इन डेप्थ लर्निंग के
लिए जानी है तो हमारी एक ट्रेनिंग चलती है
डीसीसीआई की डिफ्रॉनिक सर्टिफाइड साइबर
क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेटर जिसमें कि साइबर
क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन एंड ओसंट एक डिफरेंट
लेवल पे आपको स्ट्रक्चरर्ड वे में बहुत
डीपली सिखाया जाता है। तो अगर आपको पेड
ट्रेनिंग में इंटरेस्ट है एक मेंटोरशिप के
साथ तो आप DCCI में आ सकते हैं। DCCI में
कब कैसे क्या आना है नेक्स्ट बैच कब शुरू
होगी उसके लिए वेबसाइट पे जब आप हमारे
जाएंगे diffence.com पे सबसे ऊपर एक नंबर
लिखा होता है। उस नंबर पे सिंपली एक मैसेज
डाल देना है। क्वेरी आपकी जो भी है कि सर
जी डीसीसीआई की बैच कब आएगी इसके बारे में
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन देना है। हो सकता है आपको
ग्रुप में ऐड कर दिया जाए वेटिंग वेटिंग
लिस्ट में क्योंकि वेट लिस्ट हमेशा उसमें
लोग ऐड होते रहते हैं नेक्स्ट बैच के लिए
एंड जब कोई अनाउंसमेंट आएगी आपको वेट
लिस्ट वाले ग्रुप में पता चल जाएगा आप
अनाउंस आके जॉइ कर सकते हैं। ठीक है? इफ
यू वांट टू गो फॉर द पेड ट्रेनिंग तो
बिल्कुल आप आ जाइएगा। हां अब यहां पे
एसओसी का डिफेंसिव व्यू क्या है? इस
पर्टिकुलर सिनेरियो में एज अ एसओसी आपका
डिफेंसिव व्यू क्या हो सकता है? आप किस
तरीके से देखेंगे इस पर्टिकुलर रिकॉनसेंस
अटैक को तो आप मॉनिटर करेंगे एक्सेसिव
डीएनएस क्वरीज़ के लिए अगर आपके किसी
सिस्टम सर्वर के ऊपर में बहुत एक बंदा बोल
रहा है डीसीसीआई का फुल फॉर्म डेफ्रॉनिक
सर्टिफाइड साइबर क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेटर
यश तोमर इस सेइंग डीसीसीआई इज़ बेस्ट
ट्रेनिंग थैंक यू यश
आप आपको डीसीसीआई अगर अच्छी लगी है आप अगर
डीसीसीआई के पार्ट रहे हैं ऑब्वियस सी बात
है तभी आपने बोला है सो थैंक यू वेरी मच
फॉर दैट
ओके देखो हम यहां पे कोई भी चीज के लिए
बोलते नहीं है। डायरेक्ट स्टूडेंट्स खुद
ही उस पर्टिकुलर चीज के बारे में हमें
रिव्यु देते हैं। अभी कोई था शायद
डीसीसीआई में यहां पे यश के नाम से एंड ही
इज़ सेइंग डीसीसीआई इज़ बेस्ट ट्रेनिंग
क्योंकि वैसा ही मिलता है। वैसा मिलता है
तो डिफ़्रॉनिक्स में जॉब है। मिलेगी भाई
जॉब मिलेगी। जल्दी मिलेगी। बहुत बहुत
ज्यादा मिलेगी। डिफ्रॉनिक्स में जॉब
हायरिंग स्प्री एक आएगी कुछ टाइम के बाद
जहां पे वी विल बी हायरिंग अ लॉट तब आप
लोगों को जरूर इनफॉर्म किया ही जाएगा एंड
जो भी हमारे प्रीवियस स्टूडेंट्स रहे हैं
बैचेस के उनको सबसे पहले मौका मिलेगा अगर
इफ समवन फ्रॉम देम आर इंटरेस्टेड
वी डोंट फॉलो एनी अ एजुकेशनल क्वालिफिकेशन
अह अह एक मार्क कि ये होना चाहिए वो होना
चाहिए। वी डोंट फॉलो एनी प्रीडफाइंड एक
अप्रोच कि इस तरीके से ही होगा तभी आपको
जॉब दिया जाएगा। वी सिंपली बिलीव इन
स्किल्स प्योर स्किल्स। आप अगर 12थ क्लास
के भी बच्चे हैं अगर आप में स्किल है और
आप जॉब करना चाहते हैं। एंड इफ समवन रियली
वांट्स टू वर्क एंड देयर फैमिलीज़ आर टोटली
ओके विथ दैट देन वी आर आल्सो ओके विथ दैट।
तो जैसा अब जब ऐसा होगा तो आप बिल्कुल
बेफिक्र रहिए। यू विल बी इनफॉर्म्ड अबाउट
इट।
ठीक है।
ओके। सो
तो एज अ एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट आप एक्स
एक्सेसिव डीएनएस क्वेरीज को मॉनिटर करेंगे
कि बहुत ज्यादा डीएनएस क्वेरीज आ रही हैं।
तो कुछ गड़बड़ है भाई। देयर इज़ सम थिंग
दैट शुड बी अ नोटिस्ड।
ट्रैक स्कैनिंग बिहेवियर।
आप स्कैनर चला रहे हैं, स्कैनिंग कर रहे
हैं तो उसके बिहेवियर को मॉनिटर करेंगे कि
सम डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ थिंग्स यू आर गेटिंग
सम डिफरेंट कुछ अटपटा कुछ आपको मिल रहा
है, कुछ अटपटा आपको लग रहा है तो उसको आप
नोटिस करेंगे। वॉच अनयूजुअल ओसिन बेस्ड
फिशिंग पैटर्न्स। ओसिन बेस्ड अगर कोई
फिशिंग पैटर्न आपको मिल रहा है बार-बार।
किसी एक पर्टिकुलर पैटर्न पे आपका आपको
फिशिंग अटेम्प्ट्स मिल रहे हैं तो आप उसको
नोटिस करेंगे एज अ एसओसी एंड आप उसको
मिटिगेट करने की कोशिश करेंगे। एज अ L1
अगर आपसे हो पाता है तो आप उसको बिल्कुल
खुद पे सॉल्व कीजिए। एंड अगर नहीं हो पाता
है ज्यादा कॉम्प्लेक्स लग रहा है एंड
थोड़ी भी आपको दिक्कत आ रही है तो आप एक
अच्छा प्रैक्टिस होता है कि आप उसको L2 को
एस्केलेट कर दीजिए। एस्केलेशन जो होती है
वो आपकी कमजोरी वहां पर नहीं दिखाती है।
जब आप एसओसी एनवायरमेंट में काम कर रहे
हैं एक टीम के साथ तो एस्केलेशन मतलब आपकी
वीकनेस नहीं होती है। वो एक प्रोफेशनलिज्म
होता है जो आपको और प्रोफेशनल बनाती है।
अगर आपको लेट्स सपोज कंफ्यूजन हो रहा है
तो यू आर नॉट अ गॉड राइट? यू आर नॉट अ
मास्टर और यू आर नॉट एन यू नॉट यू डोंट नो
एवरीथिंग अबाउट सम टॉपिक्स। कोई नहीं
जानता है। राइट? कोई हर टॉपिक के बारे में
कोई नहीं जानता है। हो सकता है आपसे बेटर
आपसे ज्यादा जानने वाले और लोग हैं। मेरे
से ज्यादा जानने वाले बहुत से लोग हैं। तो
नोबडी कैन बी एक्सपर्ट इन अ पर्टिकुलर
थिंग या सबसे ऊपर चला जाए। तो आप एस्केलेट
करते हैं। तो आप वहां पे प्रोफेशनलिज्म
दिखाते हैं कि यस मैं इसको नहीं टैकल कर
पा रहा हूं। तो प्लीज डू इट फास्ट। सो दैट
वी कैन मेक अ सेफर नेटवर्क अह इन
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर फॉर दिस कंपनी एंड वी कैन
सिक्योर द कंपनी। राइट? तो ये एज अ
एसोसिएट उसका व्यू होता है इन टर्म्स ऑफ
किसमें? रिकॉनसेंस में। अब हम वेपनाइजेशन
की बात करते हैं। तो इसमें क्या होता है?
अटैकर प्रिपेयर्स अ पेलोड प्लस एक्सप्लइट।
अटैकर यहां पे एक एक्सप्लइट से पेलोड
जनरेट कर देता है वेपनाइजेशन में। राइट?
यस। एसओसी इज़ ऑल अबाउट टीम वर्क। एकदम
बिल्कुल सही बोला आपने। एसओसी
आदि इज़ सेइंग डीसीजीएसपी का बैच लिया था
मैंने। सर बहुत हेल्प मिली सर। क्या बात
है। बहुत-बहुत अच्छी बात है। आदि
मजा आता है। जब आप में से कोई स्टूडेंट
हो, लर्नर हो और जब वो बिना पूछे रिव्यू
देते हैं ना ऐसी चैट्स में पब्लिकली
तो एक अलग तरह का कॉन्फिडेंस बिल्ड अप
होता है। मेरा तो स्पेशली हो ही जाता है।
एंड लगता है कि यार कुछ तो हमने किया है।
कुछ तो मतलब
हमने साइबर सिक्योरिटी में फाड़ा है मतलब
बढ़िया वाला। जो अभी तक कोई नहीं कर पाया।
राइट? वो डिफ्रॉनिक्स ने किया है और कर भी
रही है। मैं आपको
एक चीज बताता हूं। साइबर सिक्योरिटी में
अभी आज के टाइम में मोस्टली इंस्टट्यूट्स
जो होंगे आपके जिसको आप जानते हैं। जिस जो
भी आपके फेवरेट इंस्टट्यूट्स हैं जिनको आप
जानते हैं जो भी हैं मैं बता रहा हूं ना
जो भी आप जानते हैं सब के सब फर्जीवाड़ा
करते हैं। ठीक है? अब आप सोचोगे अरे सर
आपने सबको बोल दिया। जी हां, सबको बोला
है। एक एक को बोला है। कंपनी के टाइप में
चला रहे हैं ना वो सब फर्जीवाड़ा कर रहे
हैं। सब स्टूडेंट्स को बेवकूफ बना रहे
हैं। पागल बना रहे हैं। उनका पैसा वेस्ट
कर रहे हैं। इन टर्म्स ऑफ गिविंग नॉलेज और
स्किल्स। एक-एक साल का डिप्लोमा कोर्स
लाखों रुपए ले लेके उसका पैसा बर्बाद,
टाइम बर्बाद कर रहे हैं। एंड पीपल आर
गेटिंग स्कैम्ड। क्योंकि उनको एक होप होती
है। उनको एक उम्मीद होती है कि मुझे यहां
से कुछ मिलेगा सीखने को। पेरेंट्स को यह
लगता है कि मेरे बच्चे मेरा बच्चा स्किल
गेन करेगा। मेरा बच्चा कुछ सीख कर आएगा।
आगे साइबर सिक्योरिटी में बहुत अच्छा
करेगा। उसको क्या पता कि उसके बच्चे के
पैसे डूबाए जा रहे हैं। उसका खुद का करियर
डूबाए जा रहा है और उनके पैसे डूबाए जा
रहे हैं। सो बाद में जब तक एहसास होता है
तब तक वो डूब चुका होता है। एंड ये मैंने
मैं इसलिए बोलता हूं क्योंकि आई हैव अ लॉट
ऑफ़ एक्सपीरियंस रिगार्डिंग दिस। अ लॉट ऑफ़
स्टूडेंट्स हैव रीच्ड आउट टू अस। एंड उनकी
बातें सुन के अजीब से थोड़ा सा फील भी
होता है कि कई ऐसे होते हैं जो सर मेरा
यहां स्कैम हो गया। ₹00 दिए थे। कुछ नहीं
सीखा। सोचो ऐसे स्टूडेंट का मैसेज आता है
कि सर ₹00 दिए थे एथिकल हैकिंग सीखने के
लिए। मैंने वहां पे कुछ नहीं सीखा ₹00 में
और आपका डीसीजीएसपी 2499 का जो मैंने लिया
हुआ था रिकॉर्डेड कोर्स उसमें उससे ज्यादा
सीखा है मैंने। इमेजिन द डिफरेंस। मैं
यहां पे प्रमोशन नहीं कर रहा डीसीजीएसपी
की हमारी जो रिकॉर्डेड कोर्स है हमारा।
मैं उसकी आई एम नॉट डूइंग प्रमोशन काइंड
ऑफ थिंग बट मैं फैक्ट जो है वो तो बताऊंगा
मैं बोलूंगा लास्ट लास्ट तक बोलता रहूंगा
चाहे आपको प्रमोशन लगे या कुछ भी लगे आई
डोंट केयर एट ऑल तो डीसीजीएसपी 2499 का एक
कोर्स लेकर सम कोई बंदा 300 के कोर्स से
कंपैरिजन कर रहा है और वो बोल रहा है कि
यहां मुझे ज्यादा कुछ मिली है तो आप सोचो
कि हम किस हम एक्चुअल देते भी हैं कि नहीं
देते हैं हां हम बस बोलते हैं हम मैं आपसे
यहां पे बोल रहा हूं तो दैट्स द डिफरेंस
बिटवीन अ बिटवीन अस एंड अदर्स और तभी
हमारे हमारे पीछे बहुत लोग पड़े भी रहते
हैं। दिक्कतें होती है बहुत लोगों को।
मुझे पता है। अब आई कांट नेम एवरीबॉडी
बिकॉज़ YouTube पे तो बिल्कुल नहीं ले सकते
हैं। नहीं तो
कभी जरूरत पड़ी तो टेक्निकल नेविगेटर
YouTube चैनल जो हमारा है उस पे वीडियो भी
लाऊंगा मैं क्योंकि वैसे भी उस पे वीडियोस
नहीं आती। तो मैं सोच रहा हूं ऐसी वीडियो
जरूर लेकर आऊं ताकि लोगों को समझ में आए
कि एवरीबडी इज नोइंग।
Lindin पे स्कैम का जब पोस्ट डालते हैं उन
कंपनीज के बारे में जो बच्चे होते हैं जब
Lindin पे पोस्ट डालते हैं तो वो कंपनीज़
फोर्सफुली उन पोस्ट्स को डिलीट करवाती हैं
धमकी देके। जी हां कि मत डालो नहीं तो
खत्म बर्बाद है करियर। ऐसा ऐसा करती हैं।
जब ऐसी पोस्ट डालती है। अब देखो धमकी और
जो चीजें हैं वो दो सही है। कोई भी दिक्कत
नहीं है। बट कुछ ऑथेंटिक चीज़ के लिए दो
ना। अगर कुछ आपके अगेंस्ट किया जा रहा है।
अगर आप सही कर रहे हो तब कोई कुछ कर रहा
है तब दो। बट आप खुद गलत कर रहे हो। ऊपर
से धमकी दिए जा रहे हो। तो ये तो गलत है
ना। गलत प्रैक्टिस है। इट्स अ रॉन्ग
प्रैक्टिस। राइट? दैट्स व्हाट हैज़ बीन डन
बाय अ लॉट ऑफ़ इंस्टीट्यूट्स इन इंडिया एंड
साइबर सिक्योरिटी को बेस बना के किया जा
रहा है।
ठीक है?
डालेंगे। टेंशन मत लो। जल्दी इसके ऊपर
वीडियो लाएंगे।
चलिए वेपनाइजेशन पे अब आते हैं। अब इधर
फोकस कर लो। अब चैट से हट जाओ यार। तुम
लोग चैट में बड़ा टाइम पास करते हो यार।
चैट चैट में बहुत इधर तुम लोग टाइम पास
करते हो। मैंने देखा है चैट में बड़ी
बातें करते हैं यार तुम लोग। आई एम श्योर
100% कि आप लोगों की गर्लफ्रेंड वगैरह
नहीं है। तभी आप लोगों को इधर चैट करने का
मजा आता होगा।
राकेश कुमार राकेश कुमार शाह ने बोला है
यह ऑर्गेनाइजेशन स्कैम है सर मैंने किया
था मुझे मैनपुलेट कर दिया था बिल्कुल वो
तो फुली स्कैम है कंप्लीट फुल स्कैम है वो
तो हमने भी डाला था उसके स्कैम के बारे
में चैनल पे [हंसी]
पूरा स्कैम करते हैं वो
पर्सनल मत जाओ सर जी अरे जाऊंगा मैं
पर्सनल
ये बोल रहा है पर्सनल मत जाओ सर जी जरूर
इसकी गर्लफ्रेंड नहीं होगी तभी यह ऑफेंड
हो रहा है कोई कोई बात नहीं यार
गर्लफ्रेंड इज नॉट एवरीथिंग फोकस ऑन योर
करियर एंड स्किल्स
ठीक है
चलो
वेपनाइजेशन में क्या होता है अटैकर
प्रिपेयर्स अ पेलोड एंड एक्सप्लइट मतलब
पेलोड एक्सप्लइट का यूज़ करके पेलोड को
एक मतलब प्रिपेयर करता है पेलोड क्या है
व्हाट रंस आफ्टर द एक्सप्लइट एक्सप्लइट के
बाद जो रन होता है वो पेलोड होता है
एक्सप्लइट क्या है हाउ वलेबिलिटी इज़
अब्यूज्ड देखो सिंपल सा फंडा है एक
सॉफ्टवेयर डेवलप होता है एक डेवलपर डेवलप
करता है सॉफ्टवेयर को। सॉफ्टवेयर को डेवलप
करने के टाइम उसमें लेट्स सपोज एक कोई
गलती से उसकी गलती से एक छोटा सा बग रह
जाता है। उस बग को वाइडली अटैकर्स जो है
वो ढूंढ लेते हैं एंड उसका एक एक्सप्लइट
लिख देते हैं। जब तक यह बग उस पर्टिकुलर
सॉफ्टवेयर डेवलपर को या उस पर्टिकुलर
डेवलपमेंट डेवलपर टीम को या उस कंपनी को
जिसको हम बोलते हैं उस पर्टिकुलर वेंडर को
नहीं पता चलती वो जीरो डे वलेबिलिटी
कहलाती है जीरो डे एक्सप्लइट हो जाता है
उसका जो एक्सप्लइट होता है और वही जब उस
डे उस उस वलेबिलिटी को यूज़ करके जो कोड
लिखा जाता है पीस ऑफ़ कोड जिसमें उस
वलेबिलिटी के अकॉर्डिंग उसको यूज़ किया
जाता है टू टारगेट एनी सिस्टम
उसको हम एक्सप्लइट बोलते हैं। और जब
टारगेट करने के लिए जो फाइल भेजी जाती है,
जो एग्जीक्यूशन किया जाता है, जिस चीज का
वो पेलोड होता है। पेलोड ही कनेक्टिविटी
बनाता है एक्सप्लइट्स को एग्जीक्यूट करने
के बाद आपके अटैकर से। तो, एग्जांपल क्या
है? मैलवेयर एंबेडेड इन अ पीडीएफ। पीडीएफ
में एक मैलवेयर एंबेडेड है। दैट इज़ अ
काइंड ऑफ़ एग्जाम एग्जांपल ऑफ़ वेपनाइजेशन।
रिवर्स शेल हिडन इन वर्ड मैक। वर्ल्ड के
मैक्रोज़ में रिवर्स शेल हिडन है। इस पे
अलग-अलग एक्सप्लइट्स अवेलेबल हैं। आप देख
सकते हैं। एक्सप्लइट्स फॉर एन अनपैच्ड
सर्विस। कोई एक ऐसी सर्विस जो अनपैच्ड है।
अभी तक पैच ही नहीं हुई है। उसके लिए
एक्सप्लइट ये भी इसका एग्जांपल है। अटैकर
के माइंड में क्या होता है? आई हैव इनफो।
नाउ आई बिल्ड अ वेपन। मेरे पास एक इनफो
है। मेरे पास इनेशन है। मेरे पास मेरे पास
सब कुछ है। आपके पास क्या है? हैं? ये
वाली तो वही बात है कि मेरे पास इनफो है।
आई विल बिल्ड अ वेपन।
यही है तो मैं वेपन बनाऊंगा। एसओसी का
पर्सपेक्टिव क्या है भैया? तो एसओसी का
पर्सपेक्टिव है बेचारे का कि फाइल के#श को
एनालिसिस करेगा। मैं देखो यार एसओसी बहुत
बड़ी रोल होती है यार। मुझे कई बार एसओसी
के लिए बहुत दुख होता है कि एसओसी वाले जो
बंदे होते हैं वो बहुत कुछ करते हैं। बहुत
कुछ बहुत उनके ऊपर पूरी सिक्योरिटी पोश्चर
का रिस्पांसिबिलिटी होता है नेटवर्क सेट
सिक्योरिटी पोश्चर का। राइट? हां ये
एग्जांपल्स हैं। स्वीट 32 नाफीज ये आप लोग
एग्जांपल्स दे रहे हैं। अच्छी बात है। आप
लोगों को एग्जांपल पता है वना क्राई ये सब
का। दैट्स ग्रेट।
बिल्कुल सही बात है। सारे स्कैमर्स का
क्लोज होने वाला है। वो तो होगा ही होगा।
श्योरली होगा।
अभी अभी अपने डिफ्रॉनिक्स पे जिस टाइम 1
लाख्राइबर मार्क कंप्लीट हो जाएगा जिस
टाइम भी 1 लाख्राइबर मार्क कंप्लीट हो
जाएगा उसके बाद से और इतने धमाके होंगे जो
आपने कभी इमेजिन नहीं करा होगा मतलब फुल
टाइम धमाका होता रहेगा उस पे बस आप लोग 1
लाख तक ले जाओ शेयर ओवर करो भेजो इधर-उधर
जो आपकी आपको जो आपके बस में है वो करना
फिर उसके बाद तुम देखना क्या होता है
500000 तो वैसे भी होने वाले हैं 1 लाख के
ऊपर ऐसा हो जाएगा तब तक तो इतनी क्लासेस आ
गई रहेंगे और उसके बाद और ऐसी चीजें आएंगी
कि डिफ़्रॉनिक्स विल बिकम अ हब हब साइबर
सिक्योरिटी हब फॉर यू जहां आप आएंगे एंड
सीख के चले जाएंगे कहीं और जाने की आपको
जरूरत नहीं पड़ेगी स्कैम होने के लिए तो
एसओसी क्या करेगा फाइल के हैश को एनालाइज़
करेगा कि कोई हैश में मिसमैच तो नहीं है
सही हैश तो परफेक्ट है जो हैश बनी थी वही
हैश है ओरिजिनल हैश है मैलस सैंड बॉक्सिंग
करेगा मैस जो है मतलब उसको सैंडबॉक्स
एनवायरमेंट में एक सेपरेट एनवायरमेंट्स
में एनवायरमेंट में एग्जीक्यूट करके उसको
चेक आउट करेगा एंड नॉन एक्सप्लइट
सिग्नेचर्स को डिटेक्ट करेगा। कोई
एक्सप्लइट सिग्नेचर जैसे हर एक्सप्लइट का
सिग्नेचर एक डेटाबेस होता है। जहां पे अगर
कोई नॉन एक्सप्लइट है उसका एक डेटाबेस बना
हुआ है तो उसमें सिग्नेचर्स को मैच करेगा
कि भैया ये वही तो नहीं है। अगर बाय चांस
वही तो चीज नहीं है। तो ये चीजें करेगा एज
एसओसी। अब आती है डिलीवरी। व्हाट हैपेंस
हियर? वेपंस इज़ डिलीिवर्ड टू द विक्टिम।
अब जो वेपन आपने बनाया है उसको डिलीवर कर
दिया जाएगा विक्टिम को। कैसे? फिशिंग ईमेल
के थ्रू, मलेशियस अटैचमेंट्स के थ्रू,
ड्राइव बाय वेबसाइट से मलेशियस ड्राइव
डाउनलोड्स वगैरह करा के USB
ड्रॉप USB के थ्रू कॉम्प्रोमाइज्ड एड्स या
कोई एड्स कॉम्प्रोमाइज हुआ है। एड्स भी
कॉम्प्रोमाइज होते हैं। उसके थ्रू। अब
आपको दिखेगा ये कोई ऐड है बढ़िया चल रहा
है। बट वो कॉम्प्रोमाइज ऐड होगा। वहां से
आपने करा एंड वहां से गया। ऐसा ऐसा होता
है। तो ये टर्न टर्म वाला काम नहीं करना
है आपको। तो इंटरनेट पे जब भी कुछ करते हो
तो उसको पहले पूरा परखो, समझो,
इन्वेस्टिगेट करो तब एग्जीक्यूट करो।
अदरवाइज फिर बड़ा दिक्कत हो जाएगा आपको।
एज एसओसी भी आपकी यही एक मोटिव होनी चाहिए
कि एसओसी का मेन मोटिव मेन माइंडसेट होना
चाहिए। व्हाटएवर देयर इज
फर्स्ट इन्वेस्टिगेट डीपली देन क्रिएट द
रिपोर्ट जो भी अलर्ट आती है उसके
अकॉर्डिंग एंड देन जो है आपका
आगे प्रोसेस जो भी है वह फॉलो करो।
यह पूरा का पूरा सिस्टम है। अब एग्जांपल
में ह्यूमन रिसोर्स एचआर रिसीव अ रिज्यूम
pdf.exec वाया ईमेल। अब यहां पे डबल
एक्सटेंशन का मामला है कि pdf.exe टू
बायपास समथिंग। एंड यहां पे आप देख सकते
हैं कि ये एक मैलवेयर बाइंडेड फाइल है। अब
इसको अगर एग्जीक्यूट किया जाएगा तो एक
मालवेयर जो है ट्रोजन जो है एग्जीक्यूट हो
जाएगी विक्टिम के सिस्टम पे। एसओसी
कंट्रोल्स एसओसी का क्या है? ईमेल गेटवे
फिल्टरिंग। इसमें ईमेल गेटवे फिल्टिंग
लगाया जा सकता है। यूआरएल रेपुटेशन बढ़ा के
यूआरएल रेपुटेशन बढ़ाई जाएगी ताकि मलेशियस
अटेमप्ट्स ना हो सके। अटैचमेंट सैंड
बॉक्सिंग मतलब अटैचमेंट्स जो है ओपन जब
किया जाए तो उसको एक सैंड बॉक्स
एनवायरमेंट एक एक डिफरेंट एक सेपरेट
एनवायरमेंट में ओपन किया जाए सो दैट कि वो
बाकी सिस्टम्स या नेटवर्क को इनफेक्ट ना
कर सके एक कंटेंड एनवायरमेंट में ही उसको
एग्जीक्यूट किया जा सके टेस्ट किया जा सके
ये डिलीवरी थी। अब जो आती है वो है
एक्सप्लइटेशन। व्हाट हैपेंस हियर? द
वबिलिटी इज़ एक्चुअली ट्रिगरर्ड। इसमें
वलेबिलिटी को एक्चुअली ट्रिगर किया जाता
है या एग्जीक्यूट किया जाता है। जैसे कि
यूजर ने क्लिक किया लिंक पे ट्रिगरर्ड हो
गई। सॉफ्टवेयर बफर ओवर फ्लो ट्रिगर हो गई।
आउटडेटेड प्लगइन से एक्सप्लइट करके ट्रिगर
हो गई। मैक एग्जीक्यूशन से ट्रिगर हो गई।
तो ये अलग-अलग ट्रिगर के तरीके हैं। जैसे
कोई भी एक पर्टिकुलर वालेबिलिटी उसको
ट्रिगर कर देना है एक्सप्लइट के थ्रू। तो
वो आपका इसमें एक्सप्लॉयटेशन में आ जाता
है। अब यहां पे एक कांसेप्ट ये है कि नो
एक्सप्लॉयटेशन इज़ इक्वल टू नो
कॉम्प्रोमाइज। अगर कोई सिस्टम एक्सप्लइट
नहीं हुआ है तो वह कॉम्प्रोमाइज नहीं
होगा। दैट इज नॉट कॉम्प्रोमाइज्ड। दैट्स
इट। सिंपल सा फंडा है। ठीक है? एंड एसओसी
टीम्स ट्राई टू ब्रेक द चेन हियर। अब यहां
पे एसओसी टीम्स ट्राई करती है चेन को
ब्रेक करना। क्योंकि यहां पे अगर चेन
ब्रेक हो गया तो बाकी सारे फर्दर अटैक्स
या बाकी जो अटैक्स है वो बिना काम के हो
जाएंगे। उनका कोई रोल नहीं रह जाएगा। उनका
कोईेंस नहीं रह जाएगा। तो एसओसी का यहां
पे मेन वर्क होता है इस चेन को यहीं पे
ब्रेक कर देना। एक्सप्लॉयटेशन इज़ द
स्टेप वेयर एसोसिएट टीम्स ट्राई देयर
बेस्ट टू ब्रेक द चेन एंड यहां पे ताकि वह
जो चेन है टूट जाए एंड वो जो पर्टिकुलर
अटैक है वो रुक जाए। दैट्स इट।
राइट?
करेक्ट। सो यहां पे अ जस्ट
यस करेक्ट अब्सोलुटली राइट पीतांबर
पीतांबर ने यहां पे आपको ईमेल गेटवे का
कुछ एग्जांपल दिया हुआ है यू कैन सी हियर
ईमेल गेटवेज के या ईमेल सिक्योरिटी टूल्स
के तो जैसे कि
ओके प्रैक्टिकल प्रैक्टिकल कब से कराएंगे
प्रैक्टिकल नहीं होगा भाई आप क्लास रहने
दो छोड़ दो प्रैक्टिकल प्रैक्टिकल नहीं
होगा
प्रैक्टिकल के पीछे मत भागो यार। क्या तुम
लोग यार मैं पहले ही बोल चुका हूं फिर भी
लगता है यू आर न्यू हियर।
चलो
तो एसओसी टीम्स जो है वो इस चेन को ब्रेक
करने की कोशिश करती है। दैट्स द मेन थिंग।
एसओसी टीम क्या करती है? इस चेन को ब्रेक
करेगी। कैसे भी करके ट्राई करेगी। अब आती
है एक्सप्लॉयटेशन के बाद इंस्टॉलेशन की।
इंस्टॉलेशन की व्हाट हैपेंस हियर
मैल्वेयर्स जो है मैलवेयर जो है इंस्टॉल
पर्सिस्टेंस यह जो एक्सप्लइट्स हैं जिनके
थ्रू आप चीजें कर रहे हो वो पर्सिस्टेंस
इंस्टॉलेशन करती है पर्सिस्टेंस का मीन का
मतलब होता है इवन इफ सिस्टम रिस्टार्ट्स
आई स्टे सिस्टम रिस्टार्ट भी होगा तब भी
मैं वहीं पे बना रहूंगा मैं सर्वत्र हूं
एंड मैं उसमें अखंड स्वरूप बना रहूंगा ये
चीज है इसका मतलब है ठीक है वो कहा है ना
मैं सर्वत्र हूं चारों तरफ हूं तो व चारों
तरफ तरफ वाला है एंड मैं हमेशा हूं। तो
पर्सिस्टेंस वही है। टेक्निक क्या है?
रजिस्ट्री रन कीज़ रजिस्ट्रीज़ के थ्रू
बार-बार स्टार्टअप पे रन कराया जाए।
शेड्यूल टास्क के थ्रू कराया जाए। रन
स्टार्टअप फोल्डर्स के थ्रू कराया जाए।
बैक डोर यूज़र्स के थ्रू कराया जाए। कोई
बैकडोर यूजर क्रिएट हो चुकी है। उसके थ्रू
ये पर्सिस्टेंस बार-बार क्रिएट किया जाए।
एक टाइम डिले के साथ किया जाए कि एक टाइम
के बाद ऑटोमेटिक फिर से वापस एग्जीक्यूशन
हो। रजिस्ट्री के अंदर एंट्री करके उसको
बार-बार एग्जीक्यूट कराया जाए या शेड्यूल
टास्क जो है उसके थ्रू कराया जाए या
स्टार्टअप फोल्डर्स के थ्रू स्टार्टअप
प्रोग्राम्स के थ्रू कराया जाए। डिपेंड
करता है। एसओसी का क्या फोकस है? एंड
पॉइंट डिटेक्शन रिस्पांस ईडीआर यहां पे
यूज़ किया जाता है। बेसिकली ईडीआर के थ्रू
डिटेक्शन करने की कोशिश की जाती है।
रजिस्ट्री के अंदर में डिफरेंट चेंजेस या
रजिस्ट्री के अंदर में अलग-अलग तरह के
मलेशियस चेंजेस या कुछ ऐसे अह चेंजज़ जो
आपको डाउट क्रिएट आपके अंदर करें। उस टाइप
के चेंजेस को मॉनिटर किया जाता है। एंड
ऑटो रन एनालिसिस ऑटो रन होने पे
एग्जैक्टली या स्टार्टअप प्रोग्राम्स में
क्या-क्या है? ऑटो रन क्या-क्या चीजें किस
तरीके से हो रही है? वो सब पे भी
मॉनिटरिंग की जाती है कि ऑटो रन ना हो रहा
हो। सारी चीजें ऑटो रन नाउ में चल जाए।
स्टार्टअप प्रोग्राम्स में कुछ
अनआइडेंटिफाइड स्टार्टअप एप्लीकेशनेशंस या
सॉफ्टवेयर्स ना हो या कोई फाइल ना हो। इस
तरह की चीजें आपको मॉनिटर करनी पड़ती है
एज अ एसओसी।
अब जब मैंने कमांड एंड कंट्रोल की बात करी
थी तो कमांड एंड कंट्रोल के ऊपर थोड़ा सा
एक्स्ट्रा फोकस करना इज़ वेरीेंट क्योंकि
ये डिर्व करता है
एक्स्ट्रा फोकस
ये कमांड एंड कंट्रोल का लाइफ साइकिल है
टोटल फाइव यहां पे हायरार्की है। पांच
तरीके से मैंने यहां पे आपको समझाया हुआ
है। ये कमांड एंड कंट्रोल का पूरा
हायरार्की है। तो पहला जो होता है फर्स्ट
कमांड कंट्रोल में वो है इनिशियल
कॉम्प्रोमाइज होता है। जैसे अलग-अलग तरह
के टेक्निक यूज़ किए हैं। फिशिंग, ईमेल,
एक्सप्लइय जो भी टेक्निक यूज़ किए, उससे आप
इनिशियल कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर लेते हैं। हो
जाता है। देन मैलवेयर इंस्टॉल्ड हो जाते
हैं। मतलब जो भी आपका विक्टिम होता है
उसके ऊपर मैलवेयर या ट्रोज़न आपने इंस्टॉल
कर दिया जो आपका जो आपके उस पर्टिकुलर
सेशन को कंटिन्यू रखेगा जो आपके उस सिस्टम
का एक्सेस आपको देके रखेगा। देन C2 चैनल
इस्टैब्लिश होता है। यानी कि एक C2
कनेक्शन बनाई जाती है जो कि एक टू वे चैनल
होता है अटैकर को उस सिस्टम से जोड़ने के
लिए। देन कमांड्स को इशू किया जाता है।
देन रिमोटली जो है ना कमांड्स जो है वो
एग्जीक्यूट किया जाता हैकर के द्वारा उस
पर्टिकुलर सिस्टम पे। एंड देन डेटा
एक्सप्लटेशन या लेटरल मूवमेंट होती है। या
तो एक सिस्टम से दूसरे सिस्टम में फिर
घुसा जाता है। या तो अगर ऐसा नहीं है कुछ
लेटरल मूवमेंट पॉसिबल नहीं है तो उसी
सिस्टम से जो भी डेटा निकालनी है या जो भी
आपको फाइल्स या जो भी डेटा फैच करनी है वो
किया जाता है। यह पूरा सीएनसी का एक
प्रोसेस है।
उसके बाद है कमांड एंड कंट्रोल। यह जो
स्टेप है कमांड कंट्रोल का तो उसमें अब
देखते हैं एग्जैक्टली इस तरीके से कैसे
क्या होता है। तो कॉम्प्रोमाइज्ड सिस्टम्स
क्या होता है? कॉम्प्रोमाइज सिस्टम्स
टॉक्स टू अटैकर सर्वर। जो भी कॉम्प्रोमाइज
सिस्टम्स हैं वो अटैकर्स के सिस्टम से बात
करते हैं। दैट्स इट। अटैकर के सिस्टम से
इंटैक्ट करते हैं। उसे कम्युनिकेट करते
हैं। एग्जांपल क्या है? बेकनिंग एव्री 60
सेकंड्स डीएनएस टनलिंग एसटीडीपीएस बेस C2।
तो देयर आर डिफरेंट टाइप ऑफ कम्युनिकेशन
जो अलग-अलग तरीके से अटैकर के सिस्टम से
बातचीत हो सकती है। ठीक है? अब एक तरीका
ऐसा हो सकता है जिसमें कि जो विक्टिम का
सिस्टम है उस सिस्टम से हर कुछ-कुछ टाइम
पे हर कुछ-कुछ टाइम इंटरवल पे जो है वो एक
मैसेज जा रहा है। एक पर्टिकुलर
कनेक्टिविटी मैसेज पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट
पर्टिकुलर एक कनेक्टिविटी करने की जा रही
है हर एक टाइम इंटरवल के ऊपर में। तो वो
बेसिकली जब ऐसा होता है तो पर्सिस्टेंस के
थ्रू होता है एंड वो पर्सिस्टेंस होना
चाहिए। अदरवाइज ये पॉसिबल ही नहीं है। मैल
जब एग्जीक्यूट हो चुका है तो एक पर्टिकुलर
फिक्स टाइम पे वो चीजें एग्जीक्यूट हो रही
है। तो वो कोई भी टाइम हो सकता है। यहां
60 सेकंड 1 मिनट 2 मिनट व्हाटएवर टाइम
डिसाइड डिसाइड इज़ डिसाइडेड बाय द अटैकर इट
इट इज़ पॉसिबल। ठीक है? डीएनएस टर्नलिंग के
थ्रू डीएनएस टर्नलिंग इज़ अ डिफरेंट
कॉनंसेप्ट। अब जैसे ये एक इंपॉर्टेंट
टॉपिक आपको मिल गया। इसके ऊपर थोड़ा सा
रिसर्च आप कर सकते हैं। यू कैन अ लिटिल
बिट ऑफ़ रिसर्च यू कैन डू। तो डीएनएस
टनलिंग के थ्रू होती है। यानी कि डीएनएस
का मतलब होता है डोमेन नेम सिस्टम जहां पे
आपका एक होस्ट नेम या एक डोमेन रिॉल्व
होती है IP एड्रेसेस में। तो उसमें टनल के
थ्रू उसमें टनल क्रिएट करके टनलिंग के
थ्रू उसके
उसके भीतर से रिज़ॉल्विंग फीचर को यूज़ करते
हुए बेसिकली अब इसको मैं बहुत ज्यादा डीप
में जाऊंगा तो आपको आपको कंफ्यूजन होने
लगेगा। रॉल्विंग फीचर को यूज़ करके एंड हम
अपना जो डीएनएस कैश का यूज़ कर लिया या
व्हाटएवर फीचर दैट डीएनएस ऑफर्स उसका यूज़
करके हम कनेक्ट करते हैं। अटैकर जो है
कनेक्ट करता है उस पर्टिकुलर विक्टिम से।
मतलब विक्टिम ने इधर कुछ और ओपन किया वहां
अटैकर के वेबसाइट से
आईपी पे रिज़ॉल्व हो गया एंड वहां पे वो
अटैकर के सर्वर से कनेक्ट हो डीएनए
स्टलिंग का मतलब बेसिकली कुछ इसी तरीके का
हुआ कि आपने एज अ विक्टिम खोला कुछ और है
डोमेन और आप एक्चुअली किसी और डोमेन पे
ट्रांसफर हो गए किसी और डोमेन का बैक एंड
आप एक्सेस मतलब फ्रंट एंड आप एक्सेस कर
रहे हैं जो सिमिलर वैसे ही देखने में
मिलता है आपको लगता है बट वो है अटैकर के
कंट्रोल में अटैकर कंट्रोलोल्ड डोमेन को
ओपन कर लेते हैं आप डोमेन ओपन करते कुछ और
बट यू ओपन अट्रैकर कंट्रोल डोमेन तो वो
इसके थ्रू https बेस c2 जो कि थोड़ी सी
इंक्रिप्शन को सपोर्ट करती है एंड एंड
अटैकर्स भी बहुत शातिर हो चुके हैं। एंड
यहां पे अटैकर्स जो है वो सिक्योर टनल का
यूज़ करते हैं टू अ कनेक्ट विद द विक्टिम।
एसओसी के डिटेक्शन में क्या आएगा भैया?
एबनॉर्मल आउटबाउंड ट्रैफिक मतलब बाहर के
साइड में आपके नेटवर्क से कुछ एबनॉर्मल
ट्रैफिक जाएंगे। आउटबाउंड फायर वाल रूल्स
मैंने बताया था आपको। दिखाया भी था लास्ट
पिछले के पिछले शायद पिछले वीडियोस में।
उसमें बताया था कि आउटबाउंड रूल होता है
फेयरवल में इनबाउंड रूल होता है। तो जब
आउटबाउंड ट्रैफिक अन एबनॉर्मल तरीके से जा
रही है तो उसको आपको मॉनिटर करना होता है
एसओसी में वो डिटेक्शन में आएगी। बेकनिंग
पैटर्न्स किस पैटर्न पे जो पर्टिकुलर आपका
कम्युनिकेशन हो रहा है हर एक मान लो एक
पैटर्न मतलब कि हर एक कुछ टाइम फ्रेम पे
हो रहा है कम्युनिकेशन हर एक टाइम फ्रेम
पे कुछ चीजें आपकी डेटा पैकेट्स जो हैं वो
ट्रैवल कर रहे हैं एग्जीक्यूशन हो रही है
वो सब एक पैटर्न उसको आप मॉनिटर करेंगे
नोन बैड आईपीस या डोमेनस ऐसे नोन आईपीस या
डोमेनस जो है आपके पास एक लिस्ट होनी
चाहिए या आपके पास एक डेटाबेस होना चाहिए
जहां पे बैड आईपीस एंड डोमेनस हो जो कि
मलिशियस पर्पस से यूज़ में लिए जाते हैं।
जहां पे सीएनसी का सेटअप मोस्टली C2 का
सेटअप मोस्टली किया जाता है। इनका लिस्ट
होना चाहिए ताकि अगर वैसी आईपीस को आप
डिटेक्ट करें तो आप समझ जाए कि ये अटैकर
की आईपी हो सकती है या किसी हैकर की आईपी
हो सकती है। ठीक है? अब आते हैं एक्शंस ऑन
ऑब्जेक्टिव जो आपका आई थिंक लास्ट लास्ट
होगा। ठीक है? एक्शन ऑन ऑब्जेक्टिव्स। ये
है इसमें क्या होता है? अटैकर डज़ व्हाट दे
कम फॉर जिस चीज के लिए आए थे वही काम करते
हैं। अटैकर क्या करते हैं? डाटा चुराते
हैं। रसमवेयर डेप्लॉय करते हैं।
क्रेडेंशियल्स यूजर पासवर्ड्स ये सब
डिप्लॉय करते हैं। लैटरल मूवमेंट नेटवर्क
के अंदर डिवाइस टू डिवाइस घूमते रहते हैं।
कोई काम नहीं होता है। फाइनेंसियल फ्रॉड
मतलब वही फाइनेंस रिलेटेड कोई फ्रॉड करते
हैं ताकि एक कंपनी के इन अह फाइनेंशियल
कंडीशन को डिसरप्ट किया जा सके। कंपनी का
जो भी अह फाइनेंसियल कंडीशन है उसमें
प्रॉब्लम लाया जा सके ताकि कम वो डिसररप्ट
कर दे कंपनी के ऑपरेशंस को। तो ये एक
फाइनेंसियल फ्रॉड भी होता है। सो यहीं पे
सबसे ज्यादा मैक्सिमम डैमेज होती है जो
एक्शन ऑन ऑब्जेक्टिव्स है जहां पे
एग्जैक्ट डैमेज जो है आपका किया जाता है
उस कंपनी या उस पर्टिकुलर नेटवर्क
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर में। आई थिंक यहां तक
सबको क्लियर हो चुका होगा। बताइए मुझे
प्लीज लेट मी नो एवरीबॉडी। जितने लोग हैं
यहां पे प्रेजेंट आप सबका यहां तक क्लियर
हुआ?
प्लीज लेट मी नो।
ओके। क्लियर हुआ या नहीं बताइए मुझे।
क्लियर है सबका?
ग्रेट।
अच्छी बात है। क्लियर है तो?
अच्छा। ठीक है।
थैंक यू ब्रदर।
लव यू टू।
थैंक्स निशा।
साइबर किल चेन का बेस्ट एक्सप्लेनेशन था।
थैंक यू।
ओके मनीष। लेटरल मूवमेंट बताओ। अरे बताया
तो यार लैटरल मूवमेंट। एक नेटवर्क के अंदर
जब आप घुसते हो और वहां जीरो ट्रस्ट
अप्लाई नहीं हुई है और एज अटैकर आप घुसते
हो एक सिस्टम के अंदर एक डिवाइस के अंदर
और आपको ट्रस्ट कर लिया जाता है नेटवर्क
के द्वारा कि आप एक ट्रस्टेड यूजर हो
ऑथेंटिकेटेड यूजर हो फिर आप उसी नेटवर्क
के अंदर जितने बाकी के डिवाइसेस हैं उसमें
भी ट्रेवल कर रहे हो यानी उसमें भी आप घुस
रहे हो उस उसको भी एग्जीक्यूट उसके अंदर
भी जा रहे हो उसको भी आप कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर
रहे हो एक सिस्टम से मल्टीपल सिस्टम्स
कॉम्प्रोमाइज करते हुए आगे की तरफ बढ़ रहे
हो
इतना तो कोई एक्सप्लेन नहीं देता सर। थैंक
यू हिमांशु।
बेस्ट क्लास। थैंक यू ब्रदर।
क्रेडेंशियल्स डंपिंग का मतलब क्या है?
सुजोए। क्रेडेंशियल्स डंपिंग का मतलब है अ
क्रेडेंशियल्स का मतलब होता है किसी भी
तरह का
सेंसिटिव लॉगिन डिटेल्स
या
कोई भी ऐसी डाटा जो सेंसिटिव होती है जैसे
क्रेडिट कार्ड क्रेडेंशियल्स का मतलब हुआ
क्रेडिट कार्ड का नंबर अ उसका सीवीवी
एक्सपायरी ये क्रेडेंशियल्स हो गए लॉगिन
के सेंस में यूजरनेम पासवर्ड्स ओटीपी ये
क्रेडेंशियल्स हो गए तो ये होता है
क्रेडेंशियल तो इनको डंप करना मतलब इनकी
जानकारी लेना ठीक है
सर आप T20 वर्ल्ड कप देख रहे हैं क्या देख
लूंगा यार इंडिया का मैच जब जबजब होगा तभी
देखूंगा वैसे मेरे को ज्यादा कुछ खास
इंटरेस्ट होता नहीं है
पाकिस्तान तो शायद रिफ्यूज कर चुका है
इंडिया से खेलने के लिए 15th को है या पता
नहीं कब है पाकिस्तान इंडिया का शायद आई
डोंट नो होगा भी कि नहीं पाकिस्तान हैज़
रिफ्यूज्ड टू प्ले वि इंडिया
उनको पता है हार जाएंगे क्योंकि अभी
इंडिया की टी20 टीम बहुत डेंजरस है। तो वो
उस उस डर से सोच रहे हैं कि छोड़ो खेलो ही
मत। अच्छा बहाना मिला है।
बट कोई बात नहीं यार।
फ्रॉम सेकंड टाइम एक्सप्लेनेशन लर्न्स अ
लॉट। थैंक्स ब्रदर।
हम
अच्छा हुआ आपके पहले ही आपके चैनल पे आ
गया स्कैम होने से बच गया हां बिल्कुल सही
बात है बिल्कुल बच गए आप बिल्कुल बच गए
सर हम खाना खाने जाएं मेस बंद हो जाएगा
जाओ ना यार मोबाइल पे चला के रख लो जाओ
डिनर करो डिनर करने से कौन रोक सकता है
मैं रोक सकता हूं आपको खाना खाने से ना
इट्स गलत
नवाज अली शेख सर आई एम फ्रॉम पाकिस्तान।
अरे भाई
बट बिग फैन थैंक यू नवाज। आप जैसे
पाकिस्तानी हो तो हमें भी बहुत अच्छा लगता
है। बट कुछ लोग हैं पाकिस्तान से ऐसे जो
बहुत नासमझ और
अनपढ़ की तरह बातें करते हैं। बट कई ऐसे
पाकिस्तान के मेरे स्टूडेंट्स हैं जो काफी
समझदार और अच्छे तरीके से बात भी करते हैं
और अभी भी हमसे कनेक्ट रहते हैं। एंड दे
लर्न फ्रॉम अस। सो आई वेलकम ऑल दोज़ काइंड
ऑफ पीपल।
लोगों से दिक्कत नहीं है।
बाकी हर चीज से दिक्कत है। चलिए। सो या
सीखिए आप अच्छे से नवाज। आई होप कि आप
अच्छा आपको अच्छा लग रहा होगा। अच्छा से
अच्छे से आप सीखेंगे।
ओके।
इफ एक्सेस इज गेन वाया एंड एक्सप्लइट बट
नो पर्सिस्टेंस इज़ एस्टैब्लिश्ड एंड द
डिफेंस टीम ब्लॉक्स इट व्हाई इज़ द अटैकर्स
एक्सेस लॉस्ट। ये तो सिंपल सा है ना फंडा।
आप ये सिस्टम है ना। आपने सिस्टम को
कॉम्प्रोमाइज किया। आप कोई भी ऐसी जब चीज
हो ना सिचुएशन तो आप उसको रियल लाइफ के
साथ जोड़िए। आपका आसान हो जाएगा आंसर। आप
आप खुद ही आंसर इसका दे लेंगे। रियल लाइफ
से कैसे जोड़िए कि अगर आप किसी सिस्टम को
आप एज अ हैकर अटैक करते हैं। आपको उसका
एक्सेस मिल गया है और आपने अगर
पर्सिस्टेंस इस्टैब्लिश नहीं करा है तो अब
वो मान लो कि वो पर्टिकुलर एक्सप्लइट या
वो फाइल या पेलोड वो सिस्टम से वो हटा
दिया जा रहा है। डिलीट कर दिया जा रहा है
या रिफॉर्मेट सॉरी फॉर्मेट कर दिया जा रहा
है या सिस्टम को रिबूूट करने के बाद वो
फाइल काम नहीं कर रही तो कनेक्शन लॉस्ट हो
जाएगा। बट अगर पर्सिस्टेंस होगी तो वो जब
भी सिस्टम रिबूूट होगा या व्हाटएवर देयर
विल बी तो वो पर्टिकुलर एक एक्सप्लइट या
फाइल जो होगी वो वापस से एग्जीक्यूट होगी
रजिस्ट्री के थ्रू हो जाए स्टार्टअप
फोल्डर के थ्रू स्टार्टअप प्रोग्राम्स के
थ्रू हो जाए किसी एक सर्विस की कॉपी करके
उसका एग्जीक्यूशन हो जाए विंडो सर्विज
स्टार्टअप सर्विसेस के थ्रू हो जाए
डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ़ थिंग्स तो फिर वो
बार-बार आती रहेगी यही तो फर्क है
थैंक्स नवाज। थैंक यू वेरी मच ब्रदर।
हां, मैं इसके बारे में बताऊंगा प्रिंस।
मैं इसको एक डील करूंगा फोर अलर्ट्स के
बारे में। ठीक है? ताकि क्लेरिटी आ जाए।
बताऊंगा। अच्छे से बताऊंगा थोड़ा डिटेल
में। है ना? की लॉगर और पेलोड को थोड़ा
एक्सप्लेन करो ना। अरे की लॉगर और पेलोड
देखो पेलोड इज समथिंग दैट यू आर डिलीवरिंग
टू विक्टिम
जो कि एग्जीक्यूट होके एंड कनेक्शन अटैकर
की कॉम्प्रोमाइज करने की जो प्रोसेस है
उसको कंप्लीट करता है। एंड की लॉगर इज़
काइंड ऑफ़ पार्ट ऑफ़ दैट पेलोड। इट कैन बी अ
पार्ट ऑफ़ पेलोड जो कि आगे प्रोसेस आपके
पेलोड के अंदर जो भी एक्शंस परफॉर्म किए
जाएंगे अटैकर के द्वारा वो उसमें हेल्प
करेगा। वो की लॉगर उसका काम करेगा। जैसे
कि मान लो कोई रिमोट एक्सेस ट्रोजन है आर
एटी रैट है। उसके अंदर की लॉगर एक
फंक्शनैलिटी हो सकती है। जहां पे की लॉग्स
जो है वो बेसिकली जो भी कीज़ आप स्ट्रोक्स
हैं वो लॉक्स हो जाए। दैट कैन बी अ
फंक्शनैलिटी। की लॉगिंग एक जस्ट कांसेप्ट
है। जहां पे कीज़ को लॉक किया जाए। बस
दैट्स इट और कुछ भी नहीं है।
आई स्टार्टेड विद डीसीजीएसपी डीईएचई बग
बंटी एंड नाउ एसओसी। थैंक यू सर फॉर
गेटिंग सच अ वंडरफुल क्लास टू ऑल। वाओ
ग्रेट। बहुत अच्छी बात है अश्विन। आपने तो
पूरा एक हायरार्की फॉलो कर लिया है।
डीसीजीएसपी, डी, एची बग बंटी एंड एसओसी
एंड बिल्कुल सही। आशीष ने लिखा है जो अगर
आप में से किसी ने कंप्लीट कर लिया इस
तरीके से कि आपने एक डीसीजीएसपी इनरोल कर
ली मान लो बेसिक सारा क्लियर कुछ नहीं पता
सारा क्लियर इधर डीएई देख ली ईजेपीटी लेवल
की कंटेंट फ्री में दे रहे हैं वहां पे
दिया हुआ है ऑलरेडी बहुत सारी चीजें बग
बंटी की सीरीज देख ली वेब पेन टेस्टिंग का
पूरा वहां पे भर-भर के आपको मिला हुआ है
वो एस टॉप 10 कवर किए गए हैं एंड एसओसी कर
लिया तो जॉब मतलब कंप्लीट है यार आपका बस
दैट्स इट यू आर ऑल ऑल कंप्लीटेड एंड सॉर्ट
इट।
नोट्स तो मिलते ही है भैया। नोट्स मिलेगा
क्या? ये पूछ रहे हो तो गलत पूछ रहे हो
क्योंकि जरूर आप WhatsApp ग्रुप में नहीं
हो। WhatsApp ग्रुप में आ जाइए। नोट्स
वहां पे मिलते हैं सारे। जो भी मैं यहां
पे पीपीटी आपको दिखा रहा हूं वो पीडीएफ
फॉर्मेट में आपको मिलता है। बट मैं आपको
ऑलरेडी वार्न कर चुका हूं कि आप सिर्फ इस
पीपीटी और पीडीएफ पे डिपेंड मत रहिएगा।
एनी टाइम इन फ्यूचर हो सकता है मैं आपको
पीडीएफ और पीपीटी देना बंद कर दूं एज अ
नोट्स। फिर आप बोलेंगे कि सर नोट्स तो दे
दो। फिर आप आके इधर मेरा दिमाग खाएंगे। वो
नहीं करना है आपको। आपको अपनी नोट्स बनानी
है। उसी पे डिपेंडेंसी रखनी है। उसी पे
भरोसा रखना है। मेरे नोट्स और पीडीएफ पे
ये ट्रस्ट नहीं करना है कि मैं दे ही
दूंगा। कभी भी दिमाग इधर-उधर घूमेगा नोट्स
देना बंद कर दूंगा मैं। तो फिर आपका अपना
नोट्स होना चाहिए। मैं इसलिए ऐसा करूंगा
कि आपके नोट्स भी बनने चाहिए। नोट-प ये
स्पून फिडिंग थोड़ी ना करनी है मुझे कि
ऐसा चम्मच में ऐसे घोला चम्मच मुंह में
लगा के खिला दिया, पिला दिया और आपको
स्किलफुल बना दिया। ऐसा नहीं होता। खुद से
भी करना है। ठीक है।
क्या बात है यार। यहां तो बहुत लोग हैं
यार यार। आई स्टार्टेड विद ओसंट फ्री
कोर्स डीएचई बग बंटी नाउ एसओसी। थैंक यू।
वेलकम ब्रदर। क्या बात है। आई आल्सो
स्टार्टेड विद डीसीजीएसपी, डीसीसीआई बग
बंटी एंड नाउ इन डीसीएपीटी। यस पीतांबर।
पीतांबर का तो नाम मुझे याद हो गया है। ही
इज़ वन ऑफ़ आवर वन ऑफ़ फ्रॉम आवर बैच। एंड आई
होप यू लव दोज़ ट्रेनिंग्स एंड ऑल। चलिए
अच्छी बात है।
सर आई वांट टू कंडक्ट वेबिनार सेशंस फॉर
साइबर सिक्योरिटी अवेयरनेस। हाउ डू आई गेट
स्टार्टेड? द यूनिवर्सिटी देन यूनिवर्सिटी
की तरफ से फिजिकल सेशन दे पाऊं।
डायरेक्टली साइबर सिक्योरिटी को
कंट्रीब्यूट कर सकूं। ये तो वेबिनार
कंडक्ट करना है। तो सिंपली आप अह पहले तो
अपनी ऑनलाइन प्रेजेंस को इस्टैब्लिश
कीजिए। किसी भी सोशल मीडिया की तरफ से एंड
देन आपके पास ऑडियंस आएगी। अदरवाइज ऑडियंस
नहीं आने वाली है। एंड देन जब ऑडियंस में
कॉन्फिडेंस आएगा तो आपको लोग जानेंगे एंड
आप अप्रोच कर सकते हैं कॉलेज अपने
यूनिवर्सिटीज को कि आई वांट दिस ऐसा करना
है, ऐसा ट्राई करना है। एंड इफ दे थिंक कि
आप फिट हैं। आप यू आर अ गुड टू गो देन दे
विल श्योरली वेलकम यू एज अ स्पीकर।
तो बहुत सारे मेरे स्टूडेंट हैं जो आज कई
ऐसे ऐसे सिक्योरिटी टॉक्स एंड सेमिनार्स
वेबिनार्स आज भी देते हैं दे चुके हैं।
एंड
मैं चाहूंगा कि ऐसे लोग निकलें ऐसे लोग
जाएं डिलीवर करें वहां पे ताकि थोड़ा सा
डिफ्रॉनिस का भी नाम रोशन हो जाए आप लोग
के थ्रू भी।
चलिए सो यहां पे ये समझ गए आप एक्शन ऑन
ऑब्जेक्टिव्स। अब आते हैं स्टैंडर्ड
हैकिंग मेथोडोलॉजीस के ऊपर। यह जो अभी तक
आप देख रहे थे, यह साइबर किलचेन का सारा
कुछ था। साइबर किलचेन में कैसे किस तरीके
से चीजें होती हैं, ऑपरेट करती है। अब
यहां पे है स्टैंडर्ड हैकिंग मेथोडोलॉजीस
क्या होती है? अभी यार 119 लोग हो गए।
बताओ अभी तो यार चीजें बची हुई हैं। अभी
तो कराना है साइबर स अब ये स्टैंडर्ड
हैकिंग मेथोडोलॉजीस क्या होती है? इसमें
आता है आपका रिकॉनसेंस, स्कैनिंग, गेनिंग
एक्सेस, मेंटेनिंग एक्सेस एंड क्लियरिंग
ट्रैक्स। यह हमारी स्टैंडर्ड हैकिंग
मेथोडोलॉजी है जिससे कि हैकर्स जो है ना
जब मैंने पहले स्टार्टिंग में बताया था
आपको
स्टार्टिंग में बताया था साइबर किल चेन
अटैकर के लाइफ साइकिल को बताता है और
हैकिंग मेथोडोलॉजी जो होती है वो
प्रैक्टिकल एग्जीक्यूशन फ्लो को जो अटैकर
का प्रैक्टिकल एग्जीक्यूशन फ्लो होता है
उसको दिखाता है। तो अटैकर के प्रैक्टिकल
एग्जीक्यूशन फ्लो क्या होते हैं? वो ये
पांच मेन स्टेप्स में फॉल करते हैं। पहले
रिकॉनसेंस इनेशन गैदरिंग। दूसरा स्कैनिंग
होती है स्कैन करना सिस्टम्स को। वनरेबल
सर्विज पोर्ट्स को फाइंड करना। गेनिंग
एक्सेस सिस्टम में एक्चुअली एंटर करना
कॉम्प्रोमाइज करना। मेंटेनिंग एक्सेस
पर्सिस्टेंस क्रिएट करना एंड क्लियरिंग
ट्रैक्स। अपने जो भी लॉग्स हैं या अपनी जो
भी एस्टैब्लिशमेंट है या अपनी जो भी वहां
पे डिजिटल फुटप्रिंट्स हैं उसको रिमूव
करना उस सिस्टम से ताकि जो है आपको पकड़ा
ना जाके आपकी ट्रेसेस ना रहे डॉक्सिंग ना
की जा सके और आप तक पहुंचा ना जा सके। ये
जनरली अटैकर करते हैं। अब एज अ हैकर आप
पकड़े जाओगे तो फिर थोड़ा मुश्किल है ना।
वैसे तो नो वन इज़ फुल्ली सिक्योर। नो वन
इज़ फुली अ
लाइक यू कैन से कि फुली आप सेफ अपने आप को
सेफ कर सको किसी पर्टिकुलर डॉक्सिंग से या
किसी पर्टिकुलर रिवर्स अ आपका डॉक्सिंग हो
या कैसे भी हो तो ये सही चीज नहीं है।
इट्स नॉट ट्रू।
एनी हैकर इन दिस वर्ल्ड कैन बी ट्रेड डाउन
एंड नन नो मेथड्स कैन मेक यू स्केप आउट ऑफ
दैट ये पॉसिबल नहीं है। बट स्टिल जितना बच
सकते हैं बचेंगे। राइट? जितना बच सकेंगे
बचेंगे। जैसे एक चोर चोरी करता है तो कुछ
ना कुछ सुराख या एविडेंस छोड़ ही जाता है
ना। वैसे ही जब कोई बहुत बड़ा भी हैकर
हैकिंग करता है ना तो कुछ ना कुछ तो मिल
जाता है उसके अगेंस्ट जो उसको डिजिटली
ट्रैक्स ट्रेस बैक किया जा किया जा सके।
ठीक है? सो सिक्योरिटी इज जस्ट एन
इल्ल्यूजन ये तो पता ही है।
बट क्लियरिंग ट्रैक्स 100% इज़ आल्सो एन
इल्यूजन या एनोनिमिटी इज़ आल्सो एन
इल्यूजन। ये भी याद रखिएगा। चलिए तो ये
स्टैंडर्ड मेथोडोलॉजीस है। अब मैं आपको
दोनों के बीच की थोड़ी डिफरेंस समझाता
हूं। देखो
साइबर किलचेन की जब मैं बात करूं या मैं
बात करूं स्टैंडर्ड हैकिंग मेथोडोलॉजीस
की। दोनों ऑलमोस्ट आपको सिमिलर दिखेंगे।
बट दोनों में
बहुत डिफरेंस है। साइबर किल चेन आपके
अटैकर के परसेप्शन को बताता है एंड हैकिंग
मेथोडोलॉजी उसके प्रैक्टिकल फ्लो को बताता
है। ये दोनों में डिफरेंस है। साइबर किल
चेन में रिकॉनसेंस होती है। इसमें भी
रिकॉनसेंस होता है। इस जगह पे दोनों सेम
है। इसमें वेपनाइजेशन हम बोलते हैं। इसमें
एक्सप्लइट की प्रिपरेशन बोलते हैं। काम एक
ही है। डिलीवरी इसमें होती है। इसमें
पेलोड डिलीवरी ऑलमोस्ट एक ही है। इसमें हम
एक्सप्लइटेशन करते हैं। इसमें हम एक्सेस
गेन करते हैं। ये भी ऑलमोस्ट सेम है।
इसमें हम इंस्टॉलेशन करते हैं। इसमें
मेंटेनिंग एक्सेस करते हैं। एक्सेस मेंटेन
करते हैं। यहां पे C2 का सेटअप होता है।
यहां पे पर्सिस्टेंस के थ्रू हम बेसिकली
कंट्रोल लेते हैं। वो भी मतलब बैक एंड में
सब कुछ सेम है। बैक एंड में सब कुछ सेम
है। बट यूज़ केसेस इज़ क्वाइट डिफरेंट। एक
प्रैक्टिकल एक ये जो आपका एक परसेप्शन हो
गया। एक पूरा एक वर्क फ्लो जो होता है वह
हो गया। एक जर्नी हो गई अटैकर की और यह
उसका प्रैक्टिकल इंप्लीमेंटेशन हो गया।
एंड ये एक्शंस पोस्ट एक्सप्लॉयटेशन इसमें।
तो यह दोनों के दोनों का मतलब एक ओवरव्यू
मैंने एक चैट प्रिपेयर किया आपके लिए ताकि
आपको एग्जैक्ट थोड़ा सा आईडिया लग सके कि
दोनों क्या चीजें हैं। बस यही मैंने आपके
लिए क्रिएट किया है ताकि दोनों है तो
सिमिलर बैक एंड में बैकग्राउंड में सब
चीजें सेम हो रही है। बट एक जो है वो एक
अटैकर के लाइफ साइकिल को फ्लो बताता है और
दूसरा उसके प्रैक्टिकल एक्सप्लॉयटेशन
प्रैक्टिकल जो उसका प्रोसेस है उसको
डिफाइन करता है। यह दोनों के बीच में अगर
कोई पूछे आपसे कि दोनों क्या अलग-अलग चीज़
हैं? कैसे हैं? तो वह आप बता सकते हैं इस
तरीके से चीज़। दैट्स इट। अमेजिंग कंटेंट।
थैंक यू ब्रदर।
थैंक यू वेरी मच। दृश्यम का अजय देवगन बना
है। हां, सही बात है। परफेक्शन इज़ मच
करेक्ट। जस्ट स्किल मैटर। सर, नेवर स्टॉप
दिस कोर्स। योर टीचिंग मेथड इज़ एक्सीलेंट।
हां, ठीक है। थैंक यू। नहीं कर रहा।
सॉरी सर मैं जा रहा हूं पक्का कल कल ले
लूंगा वीडियो क्योंकि अभी फंक्शन अटेंड
करने जा रहा हूं। सो सॉरी सर कोई बात नहीं
जाइए बढ़िया है जाइए कोई बात नहीं फंक्शन
इज़ वेरीेंट चलिए अब यहां पे आते हैं
देखो विराट कोहली विराट कोहली विराट कोहली
कैसे बन गया पता है बाकी बाकी और भी कोहली
बाकी और भी प्लेयर्स होंगे ट्राई मारा
होगा वो क्यों नहीं बन पाया विराट कोहली
सचिन तेंदुलकर टाइप लोग क्योंकि विराट
कोहली विराट कोहली था सचिन तेंदुलकर सचिन
तेंदुलकर था इसलिए वह कोहली ली बन गया वो
तेंदुलका बन गया। क्यों? बहुत सारी
स्टोरीज हैं, चीजें हैं। आई डोंट नो व्हाट
इज ट्रू, व्हाट इज फॉल्स। बट अगर इवन 1%
भी ट्रू है या एक भी स्टोरी ट्रू है। तो
अब सम बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट चीज कोई किसी का है
एंड स्टिल
ही इज़ डिवोटेड टू क्रिकेट। लिविंग ऑल
दोज़ेंट थिंग्स। जो क्रिकेट से भी बड़ा हो
सकता था उसके लिए या होगा। राइट? सो वही
लोग विराट कोहली फिर बनते हैं। फिर बाद
में रोना रोते हैं लोग। चले मैं तो विराट
कोहली नहीं हूं। ऐसा ऐसा होता है ना मैं
तो विराट कोहली की तरह नहीं खेल पाया या
मैं विराट कोहली नहीं बन पाया तो भाई
विलाट कोहली कैसे बन जाओगे जब विराट कोहली
वाले लक्षण नहीं है आपके तो एसोसिएट
एनालिस्टन कैसे बन जाओगे लक्षण ही नहीं है
तो फंक्शन में जाना है अरे तुम्हारे जाने
से फंक्शन रुक मतलब नहीं जाने से फंक्शन
रुक जाएगी क्या भाई रुक जाएगी तो जाओ
गजब हाल है भाई
क्या फंक्शन है
ये है वो है पता नहीं क्या होगा।
खैर
लेट्स गो। मैं ज्यादा कमेंट नहीं करूंगा
इस पे। अपनी-अपनी पर्सनल चॉइस है। चलिए।
अबे यार एक बात बताना। मेरे मेरे
दोस्त की
वेडिंग का इनविटेशन आया था। मेरे को पहले
जाना था वहां। मैं उस उसमें नहीं जा पाया।
मैं यहां बैठा हूं आप लोगों के सामने बहुत
अच्छा दोस्त सोचो तो मेरे लिए भी तो था
भाई मैं भी तो जा सकता हूं बाकी बाकी
डेट्स पे और भी इवेंट्स होते हैं ना शादी
के अलावा
उसमें भी तो जाते हैं अच्छे दोस्त होते
हैं तो वन वीक 10 दिन पहले से बट मुझे पता
है फिर ये डिस्टरप्ट होंगी तो मैं कहां
गया लेकिन आप लोगों को जाना है जाइए जाइए
मिठाई खाइए
मतलब दो चार पनीर दो चार पूरी और दो चार
फ्री के मस्ती लूटने के लिए लोग चले जाते
हैं अच्छा चीज छोड़ ओके
चलिए सर आप असली वाले विराट कोहली हो। मैं
विराट कोहली नहीं हूं भाई। मैं नितेश सिंह
हूं। विराट कोहली बनना भी नहीं है। मैं
नितेश सिंह ही ठीक हूं। अपने आप में
बेस्ट। चलो यहां पे है अलर्ट रिपोर्टिंग।
अब हम आते हैं हमारे नेक्स्ट
टॉपिक पे जिसका नाम है अलर्ट रिपोर्टिंग।
प्रीवियस सेशन में हमने प्रीवियस सेशन में
हमने अलर्ट
ट्राय के बारे में पढ़ा था। पढ़ा था ना
भाई बता दो एक बार।
मैं कब अरे नहीं यार रोस्ट नहीं करा।
अरे रोशन कुमार यह फूल पत्ती मत भेजो भाई
कमेंट में नहीं तो
वो कर दूंगा मैं तुम्हें टाइम आउट
अलर्ट ट्रैक के बारे में पढ़ा दिया था
मैंने आपको अब जब अलर्ट ट्रैक जब हो गई तो
ट्रैग के बाद मतलब अलर्ट के बाद सॉरी
अलर्ट और अलर्ट ट्रैक दोनों हमने देखा था
अब उसके बाद जो होती है आपको रिपोर्टिंग
भी करनी होती है। रिपोर्टिंग करने के बाद
एस्केलेशन भी होता है एंड फिर कम्युनिकेशन
होती है। तीन चीज़ें होती हैं। ठीक है? हम
वह तीनों चीज़ें थोड़ा सा देखेंगे।
देयर आर थ्री थिंग्स दैट शुड बी
अंडरस्टुड। पहला होता है रिपोर्टिंग,
अलर्ट, ट्रैग, अलर्ट, अलर्ट। देखो ऐसे
होता है। मैं आपको थोड़ा सा ओवरव्यू देता
हूं।
अलर्ट होती है। देन आप ट्रायग होती है।
देन रिपोर्टिंग आप करते हैं। देन आप
एस्केलेशन करते हैं। देन आप कम्युनिकेशन
करते हैं।
कुछ इस फ्लो में यह आपकी फ्लो जो है वो
बनी होती है।
ठीक है?
बेस्ट टीचर लव फ्रॉम बांग्लादेश लव फ्रॉम
इंडिया ब्रदर
ओके
फ्लो फ्लो सही है बिल्कुल सही है बढ़िया
अच्छी बात है। थैंक्स।
ये एक सिंपल सा जेरिक फ्लो है। मैं बहुत
जेरिक देखो मैं जो भी चीजें आपको सिखा रहा
हूं ना जेरिक फ्लो के साथ जेरिक वे में
बता रहा हूं। मैं बहुत डीप बहुत ज्यादा
कॉम्प्लेक्स वे में नहीं जा रहा बिल्कुल
भी ताकि आपको समझ में आ जाए। तो बेसिकली
ये एक फ्लो बनी है जिसमें सबसे पहले एक
अलर्ट होता है। देन उसको ट्रैक करते हैं।
देन रिपोर्टिंग होती है। देन एस्केलेशन
होता है। देन कम्युनिकेशन होती है। तो इस
फ्लो को समझना होता है हमें। तो हमने पहले
ही अलर्ट एंड ट्रायग वाली फ्लो को देख
लिया था पहले ही। अब हम आज जो है
रिपोर्टिंग एस्क्लेशन एंड कम्युनिकेशन को
देखेंगे। इसी इसके साथ ही हमारा अलर्ट
वाला जो फंडा है वो खत्म हो जाएगा। अलर्ट
वाली चीजें खत्म हो जाएगी। राइट? तो जब
अलर्ट आता है तो उसको ट्राई करते हैं।
देखते हैं। मतलब कि दैट इज ट्रू पॉजिटिव
या फॉल्स पॉजिटिव। ठीक है? ये सब चीजें हम
थोड़ा सा मेजर करते हैं। दो और जो अलर्ट्स
के वो हैं वो भी हम बाद में देख लेंगे। ये
ट्रैक करते हैं। देन उसके बाद जब ट्रैक हो
जाती है तो आपको एक रिपोर्ट लिखना होता
है। एक डॉक्यूमेंटेशन बनानी होती है। एंड
उसके बेसिस पे फिर आप एस्केलेशन एंड
कम्युनिकेशन होती है। एस्केलेशन की जरूरत
पड़ी तो एस्केलेट करोगे। कम्युनिकेशन की
जरूरत पड़ी तो कम्युनिकेशन होती है। ये
सारी चीजें होती है। अब आ जाते हैं अलर्ट
की रिपोर्टिंग पे।
चलिए लेट्स गो। सो
व्हाट इज अलर्ट रिपोर्टिंग? अलर्ट
रिपोर्टिंग इज द प्रोसेस ऑफ फॉर्मली
डॉक्यूमेंटिंग। इसको डॉक्यूमेंटेशन बोलते
हैं। जैसे आप लोग बग बाउंट में रिपोर्ट्स
लिखते हो ना सेम उसी तरीके का यह कुछ फंडा
है। यहां रिपोर्ट बनानी है आपको। एक
डॉक्यूमेंटेशन करनी है। व्हाट वाज़
डिटेक्टेड, व्हाट वाज़ एनालाइज़्ड, व्हाट
कंक्लूजन वाज़ रीच्ज़्ड, व्हाट एक्शन वाज़
टेकन और रिकमेंडेड। इसमें आप बेसिकली आपने
जो फाइव डब्ल्यूस पढ़े थे, याद है आप लोगों
को? फाइव डब्ल्यूस? डू यू रिमेंबर गाइस? द
फाइव डब्ल्यूस वी हैड लर्नड अबाउट इन
प्रीवियस सेशंस
किटी को याद है बताइए
5 डब्लूस बताओ तो जल्दी से जल्दी से बताओ
भाई फाइव डब्ल्यूस को क्या थे यार व्हाट
व्हेन
हु
वेयर
वाई यही थे हां चलो एक ने लिखा मिस्टर
रोबोट बहुत अच्छी बात है द हैमजा गुड गुड
आदि गुड साइबर नक्स बढ़िया अ
दर्शन इज़ दर्शन ओके बढ़िया प्रिंस ओके
बढ़िया प्रिंस प्रिंस गोखले
अ ओके
ओके
चलिए अच्छी बात है सॉरी तो ये फाइव
डब्ल्यूस का आंसर करना होता है उस
रिपोर्टिंग में जब आप रिपोर्ट करते हैं
डॉक्यूमेंटेशन करते हैं सो ये कोशिश आपकी
रहनी चाहिए कि आपका जो रिपोर्ट है वो
डॉक्यूमेंटेशन है उसमें वो पांच डब्ल्यूस
का आंसर मिल जाए आपको पांच डब्लू का जैसे
व्हाट व्हेन वेयर
हु
व्हाई इसका आंसर मिल जाए अगर ये आंसर मिल
जा रहा है आपके रिपोर्टिंग में वो परफेक्ट
रिपोर्टिंग कहलाएगी दैट रिपोर्टिंग डोंट
नीड एनीथिंग एल्स दैट दैट्स जस्ट परफेक्ट
रिपोर्टिंग
इफ इट्स नॉट डॉक्यूमेंटेड इट डिड नॉट हैपन
एसओसी यह एक गोल्डन रूल है। अगर
डॉक्यूमेंट नहीं हुआ है तो यह हुआ ही नहीं
है। इट्स द ट्रुथ। यही माना जाएगा। नॉट नो
डॉक्यूमेंटेशन नथिंग हैज़ हैपन। दैट्स इट।
व्हाई अलर्ट रिपोर्टिंग मैटर्स? मैटर
क्यों करता है ये? व्हाई इट मैटर्स? तो ये
मैटर करता है टू क्रिएट ऑडिट ट्रेल। ऑडिट
ट्रेल्स क्रिएट करने के लिए इनेबल्स
हैंडवर्क बिटवीन शिफ्ट्स
सपोर्ट्स इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस प्रोटेक्ट्स
एनालिस्ट लीगली हेल्प इंप्रूव डिटेक्शंस
तो अलग-अलग चीजों के लिए ये मैटर करता है
ताकि इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस में हेल्प हो सके
जो एनालिस्ट्स हैं जो भी उनको प्रोटेक्शन
दी जा दी जा सके लीगली ताकि मतलब किसी तरह
का कोई लीगल ट्रबल होता है बाद में
डिटेक्शंस को इंप्रूव करने के लिए किया
जाता है। एंड मान लो कि आप एक शिफ्ट में
आप काम कर रहे हो। अब आपके बाद दूसरा
शिफ्ट किसी और एनालिस्ट का स्टार्ट होने
वाला है। तो आप उसको स्विफ्टली हैंड ओवर
कर पाओ। इसके थ्रू ये पता चलेगा क्योंकि
इस रिपोर्टिंग के बेसिस पे जब दूसरा है
टेकओवर करेगा शिफ्ट को तो उसको पता चलेगा
कि एग्जैक्टली आपने क्या लिखा है।
एग्जैक्टली ये किस बारे में अलर्ट है।
इसकी क्या डिस्क्रिप्शन है, क्या इंपैक्ट
हुआ है, किस तरीके से हुआ है, क्या
इंपैक्ट हुआ है। ये सब कुछ क्लेरिटी इससे
मिलेगी। इन रियल एसओसीस बैड रिपोर्टिंग इज
इक्वल टू बैड एनालिस्ट इवन इफ ट्रैग वाज़
करेक्ट। ट्रैग आपने सही कर दिया है बट अगर
रिपोर्ट सही नहीं बनाई है तो आप एक अच्छे
एसओसी नहीं है। अच्छे एसओसी होने के लिए
अच्छा रिपोर्ट बनाना पड़ेगा। दैट्स इट।
अब इसको एग्जांपल के थ्रू इंटरव्यू
लेवल के उस पे थोड़ा समझते हैं। मान लो
इंटरव्यू टाइप से एक इंटरव्यू टाइप समझा।
एक समरी दी जाएगी। मान लो इंटरव्यू में
पावर शेल एग्जीक्यूटेड विद इनकोडेड कमांड
ट्रिगरर्ड बाय वर्ड डॉक्यूमेंट ऑन फाइनेंस
यूजर सिस्टम। ये एक समरी है। इस समरी को
समझिएगा थोड़ा दिमाग में डालिएगा। पावर शेल
को एग्जीक्यूट किया गया है इनकोडेड कमांड
ट्रिगर हुआ है एक वर्ड डॉक्यूमेंट से।
किसके किस किस सिस्टम पे? एक फाइनेंस यूजर
सिस्टम पे। कोई फाइनेंस का फाइनेंस
डिपार्टमेंट का यूजर होगा उसके सिस्टम पे।
अब इसमें एनालिसिस में आप किस तरीके से
मतलब ये जो आपने पर्टिकुलर रिपोर्टिंग करी
है इसमें किस तरीके से रिपोर्टिंग करी है
इसको थोड़ा सा हम समझ रहे हैं तो उसमें
समरी में आप इस तरीके से आप ये मेंशन हो
गया समरी के टाइम में मतलब उसके बाद
एनालिसिस में आप कुछ इस तरीके से मेंशन
करेंगे एग्जीक्यूशन अकरर्ड ठीक है ये समरी
हो गया आपका ठीक है ये समरी इस तरीके से
हो गई अब एनालिसिस में डिटेल में क्या
लिखेंगे एग्जीक्यू ्यूशन अकरर्ड आउटसाइड
बिज़नेस आवर्स पैरेंट प्रोसेस वाज़ विनव exc
एक्सटर्नल कनेक्शन ऑब्ज़र्व्ड ये एक
एनालिसिस हो गया आपका ठीक है जब आप
रिपोर्ट लिखेंगे ये रिपोर्ट लिखने का मैं
तरीका
आपको बता रहा हूं पहला समरी है ये एक जस्ट
एक समरी है फिर एनालिसिस है फिर वर्डिक्ट
है एंड देन आपका रिकमेंडेशन है तो
एनालिसिस में आप ये लिखेंगे कि
एग्जीक्यूशन आउटसाइड बिज़नेस आर हुआ है
पैरेंट प्रोसेस विनर्ड exe है जो कि वर्ड
का ऑफिशियल प्रोसेस है एंड एक्सटर्नल
कनेक्शन ऑब्जर्व किया गया है। मतलब कि एक
एक्सटर्नल कम्युनिक जो कनेक्शन है वो
ऑब्जरवेशन में आई है। वर्डिक्ट क्या है?
वर्डिक्ट इज़ ट्रू पॉजिटिव। वर्डिक्ट क्या
है आपका? ट्रू पॉजिटिव है। तो वर्डिक ट्रू
पॉजिटिव का मतलब ये बिल्कुल सही है।
सस्पिशियस एग्जीक्यूशन हुआ है। इट्स अ
सस्िशियस एग्जीक्यूशन। रिकमेंडेशन क्या
है? एस्केलेट टू एसओसी एल2 फॉर कंटेनमेंट।
इसको एस्केलेट कर दीजिए L2 को क्योंकि
आपको लगता है कि एक सस्िशियस एग्जीक्यूशन
है एंड यहां पर फर्दर डीप इन्वेस्टिगेशन
होना चाहिए तो आप L2 या डीएफआईआर जो टीम
होती है यानी डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक्स एंड
इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस की टीम होती है उसको आप
इसको ट्रांसफर कर सकते हैं। तो एक कंपनी
के अंदर में L1 जो है वो L2 L3 को
ट्रांसफर कर सकता है। मतलब एस्केलेट कर
सकता है। या तो L2 डीएफआईआर भी है उसमें आ
जाते हैं। वो आ सकते हैं उसमें उसमें
इंटरेस्ट ले सकते हैं या उसमें सपोर्ट कर
सकते हैं एंड उसमें हेल्प हेल्प आउट कर
सकते हैं जो डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक एंड इंसर्ट
रिस्पांस की टीम होती है। तो यहां पे
एस्केलेट हो जाएगा। राइट? बस ये क्लियर
रिपोर्ट आपका तैयार है। समझ में आ गया? अब
आते हैं एस्केलेशन। एस्केलेशन क्या है?
व्हाट इज एस्केलेशन? एस्केलेशन मींस दिस
अलर्ट इज बिय्ड टियर वन अथॉरिटी एंड
रिक्वायर्स हायर एक्सपर्टीज और एक्शन।
एस्केलेशन तब किया जाता है
एस्केलेशन तब किया जाता है जब एल1 के बस
की बात ना हो। एल1 को लगे कि भैया ये
हैंडल ना हो पाएगा हमसे। बस की बात नहीं
है हमारे। ठीक है? तो उस समय एस्केलेशन
होती है। तो टिएर वन इसको फिक्स नहीं
करेगा। एल वन मतलब फिक्स नहीं करेगा। एंड
टियर वन इसको सिर्फ आइडेंटिफाई करके एंड
इसको आगे एस्केलेट कर देगा। यह एस्केलेशन
में होता है। आइडेंटिफाई करेगा देखेगा
डॉक्यूमेंट करेगा और उसको एस्केलेट
डॉक्यूमेंट करना तो जरूरी है भाई। तुम कुछ
भी करो डॉक्यूमेंट करना है। एस्केलेट भी
करोगे तो डॉक्यूमेंट करना है। क्लोज भी
करोगे डॉक्यूमेंट करना है। फॉल्स पॉजिटिव
को क्लोज करोगे फिर भी डॉक्यूमेंट करना
है। डॉक्यूमेंटेशन इज द मेन की फॉर
एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट। एंड उसके बिना आपका जो
रिपोर्ट या आपका जो भी आपने फाइंडिंग करी
है वो सब बेकार है। ठीक है? बस सब बेकार
है। गॉट इट? इतना समझ में आ गया होगा?
एवरीथिंग गॉट? समझ में आ गया? गुड। बहुत
बढ़िया।
अब आते हैं यहां पे
व्हेन शुड
जो एल वन है, टियर वन है, वो एस्केलेट? कब
ये एस्केलेट
करना चाहिए? व्हेन शुड टियर वन एस्केलेट?
यह तब अगर कोई भी नीचे के कंडीशंस आपको
ट्रू इसका आंसर मिलता है तो आप एस्केलेट
करेंगे एज एसोसिएशनलिस्ट एल1 इन सारे
कंडीशंस में कोई भी एक कंडीशन अगर आपको
ट्रू मिलती है आप खुद से पूछेंगे
इन्वेस्टिगेट करेंगे अगर ट्रू है तो
एस्केलेट करना है जैसे कोई मैलिसिस
एक्टिविटी कंफर्म्ड आपको मिल रही है तो
आपको एस्केलेट करना है। यू हैव टू
एस्केलेट प्रिविलेज्ड अकाउंट कोई इनवॉल्वड
हो रहा है तो आपको एस्केलेट करना है। जैसे
कि मैलवेयर एग्जीक्यूशन हो गई। प्रिविलेज
में एडमिन यूजर यहां पे है। क्रिटिकल
एसेट्स कोई अफेक्ट हुआ है। जैसे कि कोई
सर्वर आपका अफेक्ट हो गया है। मान लो कोई
भी सर्वर आपका अफेक्ट हो गया है। तो उस
केस में आप उसको एस्केलेट करेंगे। मल्टीपल
अलर्ट्स कोरिलेट मल्टीपल अलर्ट्स जो है एक
साथ रिलेट अगर आप कर पा रहे हैं। उस केस
में भी आप एस्केलेट करेंगे। जैसे फिशिंग
प्लस एग्जीक्यूशन हो गया। तो ये एस्केलेट
करेंगे। सबको एक्सलेट नहीं करना भाई।
सबको एस्केलेट नहीं करना है। ये गलत देखो
ये ये अप्रोच नहीं रखना है कि कि सर सबको
एस्केलेट कर देंगे। फिर तो आपका वो खराब
हो जाएगा वो।
फिर तो आपका वो खराब हो जाएगा।
हां
[हंसी]
वो वो खराब हो जाएगा।
ऐसे नहीं करना। वो फिर आपकी वो रेपुटेशन
डाउन हो जाएगी।
ठीक है?
डीसी नहीं पता जिनको डोमेन कंट्रोलर होता
है। यह बेसिकली एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी में
इसके बारे में आप पढ़ते हैं। डोमेन
कंट्रोलर सर्वर अभी फिलहाल हम देख रहे
हैं। मल्टीपल अलर्ट्स कोलेट कर पा रहे
हैं। डेटा रिस्क एकिस्ट्स अगर कोई डेटा
रिस्क है या एक्सप्लरेशन रिस्क है तो उसको
एस्केलेट करेंगे। पॉलिसी रिक्वायर्स
एस्केलेशन या कोई अगर मान लो कि हाई या
क्रिटिकल ऐसा कुछ अलर्ट है तो उसको
मोस्टली आप एस्केलेट कर दें तो ज्यादा
अच्छा है। मैंने पहले ही बोला है
एस्केलेशन फेल्योर नहीं है। इट्स अ
प्रोफेशनललिज्म। ये फेलोर नहीं बोलेंगे।
इसको हम प्रोफेशनलिज्म बोलेंगे। ये आपका
प्रोफेशनलिज्म है। बीइंग अ गुड एसओसी। यह
एस्केलेशन का पार्ट। अब एस्केलेशन को
एग्जांपल के थ्रू समझते हैं। ठीक है? क्या
है? किस तरीके से आप इसको डॉक्यूमेंट
करेंगे। एस्केलेशन का रीजन कंफर्म्ड
सस्िशियस पावर शेल एग्जीक्यूशन विद
एक्सटर्नल कम्युनिकेशन। ये कंफर्म आपने कर
दिया कि एक रीज़ दे दिया आपने। एविडेंस आप
अटैच करेंगे। प्रोसेस ट्री कमांड लाइन
डेस्टिनेशन डोमेन। यह आपने डाल दिया
एविडेंस में। सीवियरिटी हाई आपने मार्क कर
दिया। रिकमेंडेड एक्शन में आपने डाल दिया
एंड पॉइंट आइसोलेशन एंड मेमोरी एनालिसिस।
मतलब एंड पॉइंट से बिल्कुल आइसोलेट कर दो
पर्टिकुलरली अभी मतलब आपका जो भी लैपटॉप
डेस्कटॉप जो भी है आपका या जो भी वर्चुअल
डेस्कटॉप एनवायरमेंट है एंड मेमोरी
एनालिसिस करो ताकि वहां पे किसी तरह की
कोई इनफेक्शन की बात ना हो। ये चीज आप
एस्केलेशन के टाइम में रिपोर्ट करेंगे या
डॉक्यूमेंट करेंगे एंड इससे एल2 को मजा आ
जाएगा। L2 को लगेगा वाह क्या रिपोर्टिंग
करी है। तो रीज़ बताएंगे एस्केलेशन का।
उसके साथ एविडेंस को अटैच करेंगे,
सीवियरिटी बताएंगे और रिकमेंडेड एक्शन अगर
आप बता सके तो बता दीजिएगा। नहीं भी
बताएंगे कोई बात नहीं। एल2 वाला हैंडल कर
लेगा। राइट?
ठीक है? ओके। जेडी कोडर
अब आती है एसओसी कम्युनिकेशन की बात। अब
हम बात करेंगे एसओसी से कम्युनिकेशन। यह
बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है। इसको
अंडरएस्टीमेट किया जाता है क्योंकि
कम्युनिकेशन के बिना सारा चीज कोलैप्स हो
जाएगा। ऐसे कई केसेस आएंगे जब आप एज अ
एसओसी आपको कम्युनिकेट करना पड़ेगा। बिना
कम्युनिकेशन का आप आगे कुछ कर ही नहीं
पाएंगे। टीम्स को आपस में कम्युनिकेट करना
होता है। एक टीम एक टीम जो है दूसरे टीम
से कम्युनिकेट करती है। क्रॉस टीम
कम्युनिकेशन करनी पड़ती है। एक सेम टीम का
जो कम्युनिकेशन है वो अपने हायर अथॉरिटी
या मैनेजमेंट से होता है। तो ये सारी
चीजें आपको करनी होती है। व्हाट इज एसओसी
कम्युनिकेशन?
एसओसी कम्युनिकेशन इज एनालिस्ट का
एनालिस्ट से कम्युनिकेशन होना। एनालिस्ट
का इन इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस टीम से
कम्युनिकेशन होना। एनालिस्ट का आईटी या
एडमिन डिपार्टमेंट से कम्युनिक अ
होना।
एसओसी का मैनेजमेंट से कम्युनिकेशन होना
या एनालिस्ट का या पूरे एसओसी टीम का
मैनेजमेंट से कम्युनिकेशन होना। तो इस
तरीके के कम्युनिकेशंस होते हैं। तो हर
कोई एक दूसरे से कम्युनिकेट कर रहा है।
तभी एक टीम वर्क होती है। तभी टीम की तरह
काम होता है। और तभी एक इफेक्टिव
सिक्योरिटी जो है ना पोश्चर तैयार किया जा
सकता है। तो यू आर ट्रांसलेटिंग टेक्निकल
रिस्क इंटू एक्शनबल इंटू एक्शननेबल
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन। आप एक टेक्निकल रिस्क को
एक्शननेबल इंफॉर्मेशनेशन में कन्वर्ट कर
रहे हैं। बस यही काम कर रहे हैं आप
कम्युनिकेशन के थ्रू। इट्स अ वेरी बिग
थिंग। अगर आप सोचेंगे तो आपको समझ में
आएगा। इट्स अ ह्यूज थिंग। अब कम्युनिकेशन
प्रिंसिपल्स क्या हैं? जो आपके स्टैंडर्ड
होने चाहिए वो क्या होने चाहिए?
बहुत ही क्लियर होना चाहिए जो आपका
कम्युनिकेशन हो। फ़क्चुअल होना चाहिए।
एजम्पशंस नहीं होने चाहिए उसमें। पैनिकिक
लैंग्वेज अरे इट्स इट्स अ वेरी अ वेरी अह
लार्ज अह इट्स अ वेरी डेंजरस अह मलेसियस
अटैक। प्लीज डोंट डू दिस। प्लीज डोंट डू
दिस। प्लीज डिस्कनेक्ट द वॉइस, डिस्कनेक्ट
द हार्ड वॉइस, डिस्कनेक्ट द
किल स्विच प्लीज एग्जीक्यूट द किल स्विच
एंड ऑल ऐसे करके पैनिकिक आपको नहीं क्रिएट
करना है टीम के अंदर में। नो ब्लेम ये
नहीं मैंने नहीं L2 वाले की दिक्कत है। L3
वाले की गलती है। L1 मेरा मेरी गलती नहीं
है। मैंने तो सब सही किया था तो उसकी गलती
है। ये सब काम आपको नहीं करना है। तो जैसे
कि अगर एक लाइन बोलनी है कि सिस्टम को हैक
कर लिया गया है। तो ऐसे नहीं बोलेंगे।
सिस्टम इज़ हैक्ड वेरी बैडली। सिस्टम इज़
हैक्ड एंड अ एवरीथिंग इज़ कॉम्प्रोमाइज्ड
बैडली। ऐसा करके नहीं बोलना है। आपको
बोलना है सस्िशियस एक्टिविटी डिटेक्टेड
इट्स अंडर इन्वेस्टिगेशन।
प्यार से प्यार से बोलोगे तो ज्यादा समझ
में आएगा। है ना? सस्िशियस एक्टिविटी
डिटेक्टेड अंडर इन्वेस्टिगेशन। हो गया। इस
तरीके से पैनिकिक नहीं रखना है।
या करेक्ट। नो पैनिकिक लैंग्वेजज़। और
इमोशनल में नहीं होना है भाई। इमोशनल में
नहीं। सिस्टम अटैक हो गया। सिस्टम
कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो गया। अब कैसे करें? अब
क्या करें? बहुत दुख हो रहा है भाई। ऐसे
नहीं करना है। ठीक है?
दुख में भी ज्यादा नहीं रखना है।
चलिए। अब आते हैं कम्युनिकेशन टाइप्स।
कौन-कौन से होते हैं? ये तो कम्युनिकेशन
इस तरीके से होता है। कम्युनिकेशन के भी
टाइप्स होते हैं। एक इंटरनल इंटरनल
कम्युनिकेशन होता है। आईटी या एडमिन
कम्युनिकेशन होता है एंड मैनेजमेंट
कम्युनिकेशन होता है। ये तीन कम्युनिकेशन
के टाइप्स होते हैं। इंटरनल एसओसी
कम्युनिकेशन में क्या होता है? ये कब यूज़
किए जाते हैं? शिफ्ट जब चेंज होते हैं,
एस्केलेशन जब होता है, कोलैबोरेशन जब होती
है। तो ऑब्वियस सी बात है ये इंटरनल टीम
के बीच की कम्युनिकेशन है। तो जब कोई
शिफ्ट चेंज हो रही है, आपकी जगह कोई और L1
आ रहा है तो उससे आपको कम्युनिकेट करना है
तो वो इंटरनल कम्युनिकेशन हो गई। एस्केलेट
करना है L2 L3 को इंटरनल कम्युनिकेशन हो
गई। कोलैबोरेट करना है दूसरे मान लो आप L1
है L2 के साथ L3 के साथ कम्युनिकेट
कोलैबोरेट करने आया डीएफआईआर डिजिटल
फॉरेंसिक्स या इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस टीम के
साथ कम कोलैबोरेट करना है तो वो इंटरनल
अपना कम्युनिकेशन हो गया। ठीक है? जैसे
अलर्ट एस्केलेटेड टू एल टू एंड पॉइंट
पेंडिंग आइसोलेशन मॉनिटरिंग ऑनगोइंग। तो
ये आपका बेसिकली इंटरनल कम्युनिकेशन। आईटी
या एडमिन कम्युनिकेशन क्या होता है? यूज़्ड
व्हेन एक्शन इज़ नीडेड। अब मान लो कोई
एक्शन लेना है एकदम प्र्पली तो भैया आईटी
का जो टीम है उसके थ्रू आपसे कम्युनिकेशन
आपको करना होगा। एडमिन का जो टीम है प्लीज
आइसोलेट फिन लैब 07 ये एक मान लो कोई
सिस्टम या सर्वर का नाम है फ्रॉम द
नेटवर्क एज सस्पिशियस एक्टिविटी वाज़
डिटेक्टेड। मतलब एक कोई सिस्टम है यहां पे
पर्टिकुलर। इस पे सस्िशियस एक्टिविटी
डिटेक्ट हुई थी। तो यहां पे आईटी टीम को
बोला जा रहा है प्लीज आइसोलेट इट। जल्दी
से आप बाकी नेटवर्क से इसको हटाइए। नहीं
तो लैटरल मूवमेंट के थ्रू बड़ी बैंड बजेगी
पूरे नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर की अटैकर
पूरे नेटवर्क में फैल जाएगा या यह मैलवेयर
या वायरस या वार्म पूरे नेटवर्क में फैल
जाएगी। देयर इज़ मालवेयर एवरीवेयर। भागो
भागो मैलवेयर चारों तरफ है। भागो भागो
मैलवेयर चारों तरफ है। देन आती है
मैनेजमेंट कम्युनिकेशन। ये हाई लेवल
कम्युनिकेशन है। मैनेजमेंट डज़ नॉट वांट
लॉग्स। मैनेजमेंट को आपके लॉग्स फॉग्स से
कोई मतलब नहीं है। मैनेजमेंट को क्यों
मतलब? टेक्निकल चीज़ों से क्या मतलब रहेगा
भाई? मैनेजमेंट इज़ मैनेजमेंट। आईटी में
उसके लिए टेक्निकल चीज़ों के लिए दे वांट
इंपैक्ट प्लस स्टेटस। उनको मतलब है कि
भैया लास्ट में क्या इंपैक्ट है? क्या
स्टेटस रहा एक पर्टिकुलर अटैक सिनेरियोस
का? उस पे उनको जाना है। उससे मतलब होता
है। एग्जांपल में सस्िशियस एक्टिविटी
डिटेक्टेड ऑन वन फाइनेंस यूज़ सिस्टम। नो
एविडेंस ऑफ़ डेटा एक्सपिल्ट्रेशन सो फार
इंसिडेंट अंडर इन्वेस्टिगेशन। ये
मैनेजमेंट से कम्युनिकेशन हो गई कि एक
भैया सस्िशियस एक्टिविटी हुआ था। डिटेक्ट
हुआ था एक फाइनेंस यूजर के सिस्टम पे।
डेटा एक्सपिल्ट्रेशन की कोई ऐसी कुछ खास
न्यूज़ है नहीं। कुछ खास ऐसा कुछ पता नहीं
चला है। इन्वेस्टिगेशन ऑनगोइंग है। जैसे
ही आगे कुछ होता है वी विल अपडेट यू।
मैनेजमेंट खुश हो गया। हां, ठीक है। बताओ।
अब नहीं कुछ पता चलेगा कुछ टाइम में तो
फिर आपको ऊपर से प्रेशर आएगा कि भैया इसका
कुछ अपडेट दो। मैनेजमेंट प्रेशर देगी।
डीएफआईआर L3 इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस इन सब टीम
को मान लो या यू कैन से कि आईटी आईटी टीम
को आईटी टीम फिर उसको ऐसे मतलब
जो डाउनवर्ड है हायरार्की है उसके थ्रू ये
काम करेगा। सबसे सीनियर उस अपने जूनियर
उसके उससे जूनियर उससे जूनियर ऐसे बोलते
चले जाएंगे और लास्ट वाला पिसता है
बेचारा। यही तो होता है कॉर्पोरेट में।
हां कम्युनिकेशन इज द की। बिल्कुल सही बात
है। तो बेसिकली रिपोर्टिंग
बेसिकली रिपोर्टिंग
एस्केलेशन कम्युनिकेशन
ये सब कैसे फिट होते हैं?
मैंने आपको पहले ही बता दिया। अलर्ट
डिटेक्ट होती है।
अलर्ट को ट्राई किया जाता है। रिपोर्ट
बनाया जाता है। रिपोर्ट लिखा जाता है।
एस्केलेशन होती है। अगर नीडेड है
कम्युनिकेशन होती है। एंड देन एक्शन जो है
परफॉर्म किया जाता है। दैट्स इट।
यस
यस वी वांट द ओनली स्टेटस बिल्कुल सही बात
है बिल्कुल सही
और कितने टाइम में आज की क्लास होगी बस
भाई क्लास खत्म होने वाली है टेंशन नहीं
लेना है बिल्कुल बिंदास रहना है इतना
टेंशन लोगे तो कैसे लाइफ में कैसे काम
चलेगा मिस एनी स्टेप एसओसी फेल्योर इन इन
स्टेप्स में से कोई भी एक स्टेप मिस हुआ
तो एसओसी फेल्योर माना जाएगा पूरी टीम की
फेलियर मानी जाएगी तो कोई भी स्टेप जो है
वो मिस नहीं होना चाहिए राइट दिस इज द मेन
थिंग अबाउट एसोसिए कम्युनिकेशन एंड अबाउट
रिपोर्टिंग एस्केलेशन एंड कम्युनिकेशन। बस
ये आपको समझ में आ गया होगा एंड आई होप कि
ये सारी चीजें क्लियर होंगी। राइट?
एवरीथिंग इज नाउ क्लियर। चलिए अब यहां पे
मैं आता हूं। एंड आई एम गोइंग फॉर द ट्राई
हैक मी पे। पे मैं चलता हूं यहां पे। अब
मैं आपको एक चीज़ देता हूं। एज अ टास्क
देता हूं। आप सबको करके लाना है। बहुत इजी
टास्क आपको मिलेगा। यहां पे एक है एसओसी
एल1 रिपोर्टिंग। लैब है। इसको आप ओपन कर
लीजिएगा।
यहां पे की तरफ नीचे की तरफ आप आएंगे।
आई थिंक देयर इज़ सम नेटवर्क देयर इज़ सम
इशू।
ओके। यहां नीचे की तरफ आएंगे तो आपको यहां
पे अ
या
रिपोर्ट गाइड
इसमें कुछ आपको बेसिकली आंसर्स करने हैं।
इसको आप आंसर कीजिएगा। एस्क्लेशन गाइड में
आपको यहां पे नीचे की तरफ आएंगे तो आपको
फ्लैग सबमिट करने हैं। इसको आप सबमिट
कीजिएगा। एसओसी कम्युनिकेशन में यहां पे
कुछ आंसर करने हैं। ये आप नहीं भी करेंगे
चलेगा। मेनली आपका जो है एस्केलेशन गाइड
जो है इसमें जो आपको फ्लैग्स हैं यहां पे
यह फ्लैग्स को आपको आके एंड इनको इन
फ्लैग्स को आपको सबमिट करना है एंड देखना
है कि आप खुद से ये फ्लैग सबमिट कर पा रहे
हैं कि नहीं। ये टास्क है। तो आप प्लीज इस
टास्क को कंप्लीट कीजिएगा। इट्स अ
रिक्वेस्ट टू ऑल ऑफ यू। ठीक है?
क्या बात है। बहुत अच्छी बात है। जिन
लोगों ने ऑलरेडी कंप्लीट कर लिया है उनको
नहीं करना है। जिन लोगों ने नहीं करा है
कंप्लीट प्लीज कंप्लीट दिस रूम। अगर आप इन
टोटल अगर कर सके तो अच्छी बात है। नहीं तो
आप एस्केलेशन जो गाइड है इसके भी सिर्फ
रूम को बाकी पूरा तो पढ़ना ही पड़ेगा। तो
पढ़ लीजिएगा। एस्केलेशन गाइड के जो यहां
पे अ फ्लैग्स हैं इनको आप यहां पे
करेक्टली आंसर करके फिल कर दीजिएगा। आपको
थोड़ा आईडिया इसके बारे में लग जाएगा।
राइट?
ओके सर हुकुम करें रिक्वेस्ट नहीं है। ओके
ब्रदर थैंक यू। हुकुम कर दिया मैंने। इसको
करके लाना है। ठीक है? चलिए ये एक छोटा सा
टास्क था। एंड जैसा कि मैंने बोला है कि
जितने भी इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक्स इसमें आपको
दिखते हैं उन सब टॉपिक्स को खुद से भी आप
एक्सप्लोर करेंगे। जैसे कि आपने अगर देखा
साइबर किल चेन तो हालांकि मैंने तो सब कुछ
बहुत डिटेल में पढ़ाया बट स्टिल थोड़ा सा
एक्सप्लोर आप करेंगे। हैकिंग मेथोडोलॉजी
उसको आप थोड़ा एक्सप्लोर करेंगे। यहां पे
आपको फिशिंग ईमेल दिख रहा है। तो फिशिंग
क्या होती है उससे रिलेटेड कुछ एक्सप्लोर
करेंगे। यहां पे आपको दिख रहा है अ लाइक
ड्राइव बाय वेबसाइट्स क्या होती हैं? उसको
आप एक्सप्लोर थोड़ा सा करेंगे। यहां पे
आपको ईडीआर क्या होता है उसके बारे में
थोड़ा एक्सप्लोर करेंगे। देन आप लाइफ
साइकिल ऑफ़ सीएनसी इसके बारे में एक्सप्लोर
कर सकते हैं आप। देन यहां पे रेंसवेयर
डिप्लॉयमेंट क्या होती है? इसके बारे में
आप एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं। लैटरल मूवमेंट
क्या होती है? इसके बारे में थोड़ी खुद से
एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं। जेरिक हैकिंग
मेथोडोलॉजीस क्या होती है? इसके बारे में
आप एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं। यू कैन डू ऑल
दिस थिंग्स। राइट? तो ये आप एज अ टास्क
करके लाइएगा। दूसरी चीज़ मैं बार-बार बोल
रहा हूं कि आपके लिए बहुत बढ़िया रहेगा।
अगर आप जो मैं बता रहा हूं जैसे वैसे आप
करेंगे तो आपके लिए बहुत सही रहेगा। जो भी
आप क्लासेस करते हैं लाइव में लाइव में तो
आप बिल्कुल कीजिए अच्छी बात है। बट लाइव
के बाद दोबारा से आप रिकॉर्डिंग को देखिए
और उस टाइम में नोट्स बनाइए। खुद के नोट्स
बनाइए। डोंट डिपेंड ऑन माय नोट्स। डोंट
डिपेंड ऑन माय पीपीटीस पीडीएफ। वो मैं
दूंगा बट कभी नहीं भी दूंगा। फिर बड़ा दुख
होगा आपको। ऐसा हो सकता है कि मैं एक अभी
तो मैं रेगुलर दे रहा हूं। ऐसा हो सकता है
कि मैं अगले दो-तीन क्लासेस की पीपीटी दूं
ही ना आपको पीडीएफ बाद में दूं 10 दिन बाद
तो आपका फ्लो टूटेगा कि नहीं टूटेगा बट
नोट्स रहेंगे तो नहीं टूटेगा तो आपको
नोट्स खुद के बनाने हैं खुद से प्रिपेयर
करने हैं और जो भी की पॉइंट्स आपने बनाए
हैं उन की पॉइंट्स को Lindin पे डालना है
और Lindin पे डाल के हमें टैग करना है।
जितना भी आप Lindin पे डाल सके आप डालिए।
सभी लोग डालिए। Lindin पे प्रोफाइल नहीं
है, प्रोफाइल बनाइए, फ्री में बन जाती है।
एंड टैग अस डिफ़्रॉनिक्स सर्च करके टैग
कीजिए या मे को भी आप टैग कर सकते हैं।
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स और मुझे दोनों को टैग कर सकते
हैं या फिर डिफरों को ओनली सर्च आप टैग कर
दीजिए। हमारे को पता चल जाएगा। राइट? तो
हमें थोड़ी आपकी एक्टिविटी दिखती है। हो
सकता है आपके पोस्ट पे हमारे तरफ से सारे
पोस्ट्स पे सब लोगों के लाइक ना जाएं। बट
हम पोस्ट्स देखते जरूर हैं। मैं खुद
पर्सनली देखता हूं आपके सारे पोस्ट्स जो
भी आप लोग डालते हैं। राइट? तो आप लोग
डालते रहिए। हमें पता चलेगा आपके बारे में
कि आप कितना एक्टिव हैं, कितना सिंसियर
हैं। एंड ये आपके लिए बहुत बेनिफिशियल
होगा आगे चलके। क्योंकि आप जितना एक्टिव
सिंसियर रहेंगे आपको लास्ट में उतनी ही
ज्यादा हेल्प मिलेगी हमारी साइड से। मैं
आपको ये चीज़ बार-बार अभी बोल रहा हूं।
हिंट दे रहा हूं। बट जितने लोग समझना है
समझ रहे हैं? नहीं समझ रहे हैं कुछ नहीं।
कोई बात नहीं है। लास्ट में आपको समझ में
आएगा। बट आपको ज्यादा गाइडेंस, ज्यादा
आपको सपोर्ट एंड ज्यादा चीजें आपको
मिलेंगी आने वाले कमिंग मंथ्स एंड कमिंग
डेज में। तो प्लीज कीजिए और जो भी आप
क्लासेस को कंप्लीट करें जैसे आप क्लास
फोर को कंप्लीट कर चुके हैं तो क्लास फोर
के कमेंट्स में आइए एंड वहां पर लिखिए
अपना फुल नेम एंड कंप्लीटेड ऐसा लिखिए
अटेंडेंस मार्क है वो अटेंडेंस मार्क है
तो आपको करना है हो सकता है कि हम उन
कमेंट्स से गिव अवे कर दें तो उन कमेंट्स
से हम गिव अवे कर दें कि भाई सबसे ज्यादा
कमेंट्स मतलब चार वीडियोस में हैं जिनका
आजकल तो एआई का जमाना है यार इट्स वेरी
ईजी कि इन चार वीडियोस में सबसे ज्यादा
कमेंट्स जो कर रहा है रेगुलर बेसिस पे उन
कमेंट्स को फ़्टर आउट करो और टॉप थ्री को
हम गिव अवे के तौर पे ट्राईक के वाउचर दे
दे या Zomato के वाउचर blink के वाउचर
sविg के वाउचर Amazon के वाउचर Flipkart
के वाउचर बुक्स Book Mysho के वाउचर जो
वाउचर चाहिए भाई वो वाउचर देंगे बट करो तो
सही देखा है सब फ्री में पढ़ा भी रहा हूं
मैं क्वालिटी ट्रेनिंग भी दे रहा हूं
वाउचर भी दे रहा हूं अब क्या भाई अब क्या
चाहिए बताओ
इससे ज्यादा क्या करूं
तुम कम से कम अच्छे से कर लो पढ़ लो
ठीक है? यू आर वेलकम गाइस। हैं तो आप लोग
कमेंट्स में आके कर दीजिएगा क्योंकि आप
देखो ये बहुत ये अच्छा चीज नहीं है।
फर्स्ट क्लास में 350 प्लस कमेंट्स हैं।
फिर 300 कमेंट्स, 250 कमेंट्स हैं। यहां
पे 200 कमेंट्स लगभग पूरे हुए हैं बहुत
बोलने के बाद। तो आप एवरेज 250 कमेंट्स तक
लेके चलो ना ताकि पता चले कि यहां 250 लोग
कंटिन्यू देख रहे हैं। तो मजा भी आएगा।
राइट? तो ये करिए आप। प्लीज ये करना है
आपको। को कमेंट्स तो बिल्कुल करने नहीं तो
पता नहीं चलेगा।
आई एम जस्ट सेइंग इट लाउडली एंड क्लियर।
प्लीज डू इट। एंड वीडियोस को शेयर कीजिएगा
जब तो उसके स्क्रीनशॉट रखिएगा अपने पास।
जब वीडियोस को शेयर करेंगे आप तो उसके
स्क्रीनशॉट रखिएगा। क्योंकि हम वो जो
वाउचर या जो भी गिव अवे कर रहे हैं वो हम
शेयरिंग बेसिस पे, कमेंट बेसिस पे, दोनों
बेसिस पे हर बार अलग-अलग बेसिस पे लेकर
आएंगे। एक बार शेयरिंग बेसिस पे, एक बार
कमेंट्स बेसिस पे। तो आपके पास स्क्रीनशॉट
टाइम के साथ होना चाहिए। देन ओनली वी विल
बी
अ सिलेक्टिंग यू राइट
ओके करता हूं बहुत अच्छी बात है जो लोग
शेयर करते हैं थैंक यू वेरी मच आई एम
रियली डिलाइटेड चलिए यहां पे फैंस की टॉप
फैंस की बारी आ गई टॉप फैंस की लिस्ट देख
लेते हैं एक बार लेट्स सी द टॉप फैंस
लिस्ट हियर अगेन
पॉप अप कर लेते हैं चैट को बड़े में दिखेगा
थोड़ा
टॉप फैंस तो ये है हमारे आज के टॉप फैंस
लास्ट सेशन में में नहीं हो पाया था। एंड
मिस्टर अ
मिस्टर जेट टॉप ऋषु द रूट मिस्टर रोबोट
प्रिंस गोखले ओके तुष ललित आदि पीतांबर
आकाश मोहक कश्मीर कश्मीर गौरव
इश्लर्न निशा दमजा हिमांशु अमन शेख हरिक
वैद पॉल देखो भाई प्रोन्सिएशन में गलती हो
तो माफ़ कर देना। इस शैलिन नारायण
मनीष राजपूत अमित यादव राधिका
शर्मा अनामिका आदित्य सिंह अशोक सहनी लोगन
मास्टर गेमिंग अभिषेक देवानंद देवानंद
देवानंद साहब आए हैं हमारी वीडियो देखने।
नमस्कार देवांद जी देवानंद भी आ गए हमारी
एसओसी की क्लास लेने भाई क्या बात है यार
सो पॉपुलर आवर क्लास इज सो पॉपुलर
अभिषेक
सुदामा
भाई तुम लोग नाम सच में है या ऐसे ही रख
देते हो कुछ भी यूजरनेम में बताओ भाई
देवांद के साथ सुदामा भी आ गए हैं हमारे
क्लास लेने सुजोए साइबरनक्स मिस्टर एलियट
सागर विकास
शुभ हैक
राहुल शुभ हबीबुल्लाह नमन गब्बर देखो
गब्बर भी आया है गब्बर इज बैक गब्बर भी आ
गया है देखो शफ
ईमो नाममीन जोकर जोकर भी है जोकर भी आ गया
है सब आ गए हैं यार सब इसी क्लास में है
लोकी लोकी भी आ गया भाई अवेंजर वाला
रेडियो पंजाबी पंजाबी रेडियो भी है क्या
बात है यार एनिम
सही है यार नाम पढ़ पढ़ पढ़ के मजा आ जा
रहा है। सही है। मैं सोच रहा हूं कि अब से
कपिल शर्मा, तारक मेहता छोड़ के आप लोगों
के नाम ही पढ़ लूंगा। टॉप फेंस में ज्यादा
मजा आ रहा है इसमें।
अगली बार डॉक्टर स्ट्रेंज आ जाना, आयरन
मैन आ जाना, सब आ जाना। चलो ठीक है ओके
गाइस। सो थैंक यू वेरी मच फॉर अटेंडिंग द
सेशन। आई होप यू एंजॉयड द सेशन। आई होप यू
लर्न समथिंग एंड यू लर्न समथिंग डिफरेंट।
एंड आई होप कि आप अपने स्किल्स को ऐसे ही
आगे बढ़ाते रहेंगे। ऐसे आप स्किलिंग करते
रहेंगे एंड इस सेशन को लाइव अटेंड करते
रहेंगे। मैं यही उम्मीद करता हूं जितने
टाइम तक जब तक आप लाइव अटेंड करते रहेंगे
तब तक मैं खुश रहूंगा और मैं खुश हुआ तो
मोगंबो खुश हुआ। मोगंबो खुश हुआ तो
क्लासेस आती रहेंगी। सो कीप मोकंबो ऑलवेज
हैप्पी व्हाइल अटेंडिंग द लाइव सेशंस।
थैंक यू गाइस। थैंक यू वेरी मच। हैव अ गुड
नाइट। मिलते हैं भैया नेक्स्ट एसओसी की
क्लास में। टाटा गुड नाइट। गुड नाइट गाइस।
गुड नाइट। अरे भैया गुड नाइट।
गुड नाइट गुड नाइट
हां जी राम राम सत श्री अकाल केम छो
आगे कुछ आता नहीं है तो सॉरी बाकी लोग
बुरा मत मानिएगा सीख लूंगा धीरे-धीरे
भाई मैं नॉन ह्यूमन वाले काम करके बीइंग
ह्यूमन नहीं बनता ठीक है
[हंसी]
वी लव यू सर अरे आई लव यू टू गाइस राधेधे
राधे-धे भाई
ओके
नेक्स्ट सेशन कब आएगी? आएगी भाई जल्दी आ
जाएगी यार। जैसे आज आई है वैसे आ जाएगी।
बता दूंगा ग्रुप में WhatsApp ग्रुप जो
लिंक दिया है वीडियो के डिस्क्रिप्शन में
उसमें जॉइन रहो। WhatsApp चैनल पे जॉइन
रहो सब पता चल जाएगा।
सर आई रियली एप्रिशिएट हाउ यू मेक
कॉम्प्लेक्स टॉपिक्स इजी टू अंडरस्टैंड
एंड यू हैव मेड अ लास्टिंग इंपैक्ट ऑन माय
लर्निंग। क्या बात है ललित। थैंक यू वेरी
मच ललित। इफ आई हैव लाइक
एनी काइंड ऑफ़ इंपैक्ट ऑन योर लर्निंग
जर्नी।
थैंक यू वेरी मच।
सर आप डैश डैश टेक के बारे में जानते हो
क्या? हां जानता हूं। YouTube चैनल है पता
है मुझे। वो लोग भी सुन सुना है मैंने। वो
लोग भी स्कैम करते हैं। नेटवर्क
मार्केटिंग। मैंने सुना है। वो लोग भी
पागल बनाते हैं पेड ट्रेनिंग के नाम पे।
ऐसा सुना है पता नहीं।
यू आर वेलकम। टुडे सेशन वाज़ अमेजिंग। थैंक
यू। थैंक यू ब्रदर इफ यू फाउंड द सेशन
अमेजिंग।
सर आप हमारे लिए बहुत कुछ करते हैं सर। वो
स्केच तो आपके लिए गिफ्ट है मेरी तरफ से।
थैंक यू आदि। आदि आपने ईमेल पे भेजा है
क्या वो स्केच? ईमेल जो मैंने मेंशन किया
था उस पे भी भेज दिया है क्या आपने? अगर
नहीं भेजा तो आपके कमेंट्स में ईमेल दिया
हुआ है मैंने। तो आप प्लीज उस ईमेल पे भी
भेज दीजिएगा। उसका एचडी क्वालिटी जो भी या
ओरिजिनल क्वालिटी होगी। सो इट विल बी
ग्रेट।
सर क्लास की गैप थोड़ा ज्यादा हो रहा है।
नहीं यार ज्यादा नहीं हो रहा है। बिल्कुल
सही हो रहा है। क्लास की गैप ज्यादा नहीं
हो रहे। ये जानबूझ के गैप दिया जा रहा है।
सो दैट कि जो लोग पीछे रह गए जो लोग अभी
तक नहीं कमेंट्स ही नहीं अगर कमेंट्स नहीं
करोगे तो पता कैसे चलेगा कि आपने वो
क्लासेस कर ली हैं। जो लास्ट डे फोर की
क्लास थी उसमें सिर्फ 100 कमेंट्स थे।
इसका मतलब है बाकी जो पहले के कमेंट्स हैं
जो लोग हैं उन्होंने नहीं देखा। उन्होंने
कमेंट नहीं करा। तो कमेंट करोगे तो मैं
समझूंगा कि आप रेडी हैं फॉर नेक्स्ट
क्लास। तो ये आपके ऊपर डिपेंड करता है।
राइट? और एक कमेंट एक बार ही आनी चाहिए।
मल्टीपल टाइम्स नहीं।
ठीक है। थैंक यू। थैंक यू। ओके गाइस। थैंक
यू वेरी मच। हैव अ गुड नाइट।
मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट एसोसिएट सेशन में।